have you ever been amazed by how google
home and amazon alexa assist in finding
information when asked over voice or
have you ever wondered how e-commerce
companies send you personalized emails
for shopping suggestions based on the
products that you bought online recently
well it's all because of machine
learning that these virtual assistants
and product recommendations work swiftly
in this video we're going to look at
machine learning roadmap for 2022
we will give you the step-by-step
process that you need to follow to build
a successful career in machine learning
so before we get started make sure that
you subscribe to the simply learn
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simplylearn
so what is machine learning
machine learning is a subset of
artificial intelligence that uses data
algorithms and statistical techniques to
build intelligent systems
these systems learn by themselves and
improve with experience
the goal of machine learning is to
create computer models that can imitate
human behavior machine learning has
found its usage in almost every business
sector
from self-driving cars medical imaging
and diagnostics speech recognition
facial recognition to online fraud
detection all of these are possible
because of machine learning
in recent years ai and ml technologies
have made several breakthroughs and the
rising demand for ai applications across
different industries has led to the
significant growth of machine learning
as for markets and markets.com the
machine learning market is expected to
grow to 9 billion dollars by 2022 at ac
agr of 44
another report from
verifiedmarketresearch.com
suggests that the machine learning
market was valued at 2.4 billion us
dollars in 2019 and is projected to
reach 47.29 million usc by 2027
growing at a cagr of 44.9 percent from
2020 to 2027.
keeping these facts and forecasts in
mind let's look at the roadmap and
critical skills required to build a
career in machine learning
first and foremost is programming skills
for a machine learning engineer
programming languages form the building
blocks to develop complex machine
learning models
you need to learn at least one
programming language preferably python
or r
you should be familiar with various
computer science concepts such as data
structures including stack cues trees
and graphs
algorithms for searching and sorting
dynamic and greedy programming space and
time complexity etc you also need to
know libraries like numpy pandas
matplotlib seaborn deep blur tidier and
gg plot for data analysis and
visualization
the second skill you need to possess is
applied mathematics
while solving business problems using
machine learning you have to use machine
learning algorithms to understand the
mechanisms behind the algorithms you
need to have a good knowledge of
mathematical concepts such as linear
algebra calculus statistics and
probability
so mathematics and machine learning is
not just processing the numbers but
understanding what is happening why it's
happening and how to obtain the best
results the third skill to become a
machine learning expert is
data wrangling and sql
data analysts and machine learning
specialists often work with raw data
collected from various sources that are
not fit for analysis
it has been observed that 80 percent of
data analysis spend too much time on
data wrangling
so it's crucial for machine learning
experts to clean structure and enrich
raw data into desired format and make it
ready for analysis using data wrangling
techniques
sql is another crucial set that you
should carry
machine learning tasks involve using
data stored in the form of tables that
are present inside relational databases
a good understanding of sql commands
enables you to store manipulate retrieve
and handle structured data
the next skill set is machine learning
algorithms it's incredibly essential to
grasp all the standard machine learning
algorithms
implementing any machine learning
techniques requires choosing the
suitable model determining the correct
learning method and an in-depth
understanding of hyper parameter tuning
so you should be really good with
different supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning algorithms such
as linear regression logistic regression
svm knn decision trees k means
clustering etc now coming to the final
scale we have data modeling and
evaluation the objective of a machine
learning engineer is to train the best
performing model possible
depending on the problem at hand you
will need to choose a suitable error
measure and an evaluation strategy for a
machine learning model
the most vulnerable part of a machine
learning candidate's resume is the
absence of experience working on diverse
machine learning projects
with all the essential skills acquired
you can now build an impressive machine
learning portfolio highlighting some
exciting machine learning projects
machine learning engineers need a
portfolio that showcases their expertise
to implement machine learning techniques
to real-world problems
with your resume ready you can now look
for the best machine learning jobs in
top product companies and startups
you can become a machine learning
engineer a data scientist a data analyst
or a research scientist
some of the top companies hiring for
machine learning roles are google amazon
ibm uber graminer navidia and linkedin
machine learning engineers are some of
the highest paid professionals in the
world
according to glassdoor.com the national
average salary for machine learning
engineers in the united states is one
lakh thirty one thousand us dollars per
year in india you can earn nearly eight
lakh rupees per annum
this salary may vary based on your
experience the industry you are applying
for and the company policy there are
immense opportunities in machine
learning for sectors such as e-commerce
manufacturing logistics retail and
healthcare
if you are interested in a career in
machine learning then start your journey
now with simplylearn's postgraduate
program in ai and machine learning that
is in partnership with purdue university
and in collaboration with ibm
you will learn all the in-demand machine
learning skills and work on programming
with hands-on examples
the program also offers job assistance
to know more about the learning part
tools covered and projects that you'll
be working on please click on the course
page link in the description below
first you will learn the basics of
machine learning with the help of an
animated video then you will look at the
various applications of machine learning
next ajay will help you understand our
programming in detail richard and pete
will take you through some of the
important machine learning algorithms
such as linear regression logistic
regression decision tree and random
forest support vector machines and
clustering techniques you will implement
all these algorithms and solve business
problems using our programming finally
ajay will make you understand time
series analysis in r let's begin by
understanding the basics of machine
learning from this short animated video
we know humans learn from their past
experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from their past data
and do what humans can do and much
faster well that's called machine
learning but it's a lot more than just
learning it's also about understanding
and reasoning so today we will learn
about the basics of machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this on the basis of the
song's tempo
genre
intensity
and the gender of voice for simplicity
let's just use tempo and intensity for
now so here tempo is on the x-axis
ranging from relaxed to fast whereas
intensity is on the y-axis ranging from
light to soaring we see that paul likes
the song with fast tempo and soaring
intensity while he dislikes the song
with relaxed tempo and light intensity
so now we know paul's choices let's say
paul listens to a new song let's name it
as song a song a has fast tempo and a
soaring intensity so it lies somewhere
here looking at the data can you guess
whether paul will like the song or not
correct so paul likes this song by
looking at paul's past choices we were
able to classify the unknown song very
easily right let's say now paul listens
to a new song let's label it as song b
so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast neither light nor soaring now can
you guess whether paul likes it or not
not able to guess whether paul will like
it or dislike it are the choices unclear
correct we could easily classify song a
but when the choice became complicated
as in the case of song b yes and that's
where machine learning comes in let's
see how in the same example for song b
if we draw a circle around the song b we
see that there are four votes for like
whereas one would for dislike if we go
for the majority votes we can say that
paul will definitely like the song
that's all this was a basic machine
learning algorithm also it's called k
nearest neighbors so this is just a
small example in one of the many machine
learning algorithms quite easy right
believe me it is but what happens when
the choices become complicated as in the
case of song b that's when machine
learning comes in it learns the data
builds the prediction model and when the
new data point comes in it can easily
predict for it more the data better the
model higher will be the accuracy there
are many ways in which the machine
learns it could be either supervised
learning unsupervised learning or
reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised learning
suppose your friend gives you one
million coins of three different
currencies say one rupee one euro and
one dirham each coin has different
weights for example a coin of one rupee
weighs three grams one euro weighs seven
grams and one dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here your weight becomes the
feature of coins while currency becomes
the label when you feed this data to the
machine learning model it learns which
feature is associated with which label
for example it will learn that if a coin
is of three grams it will be a one rupee
coin let's give a new coin to the
machine on the basis of the weight of
the new coin your model will predict the
currency hence supervised learning uses
labeled data to train the model here the
machine knew the features of the object
and also the labels associated with
those features on this note let's move
to unsupervised learning and see the
difference suppose you have cricket data
set of various players with their
respective scores and wickets taken when
you feed this data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance so it plots this data
with the respective wickets on the
x-axis while runs on the y-axis while
looking at the data you'll clearly see
that there are two clusters the one
cluster are the players who scored
higher runs and took less wickets while
the other cluster is of the players who
scored less runs but took many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen and bowlers the important
point to note here is that there were no
labels of batsmen and bowlers hence the
learning with unlabeled data is
unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled and the unsupervised learning
where the data was unlabeled and then
there is reinforcement learning which is
reward based learning or we can say that
it works on the principle of feedback
here let's say you provide the system
with an image of a dog and ask it to
identify it the system identifies it as
a cat so you give a negative feedback to
the machine saying that it's a dog's
image the machine will learn from the
feedback and finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly that is
reinforcement learning to generalize
machine learning model let's see a
flowchart input is given to a machine
learning model which then gives the
output according to the algorithm
applied if it's right we take the output
as a final result else we provide
feedback to the training model and ask
it to predict until it learns i hope
you've understood supervised and
unsupervised learning so let's have a
quick quiz you have to determine whether
the given scenarios uses supervised or
unsupervised learning simple right
scenario one facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an album of
tagged photographs
scenario two netflix recommends new
movies based on someone's past movie
choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions and flagging the
fraud transactions think wisely and
comment below your answers moving on
don't you sometimes wonder how is
machine learning possible in today's era
well that's because today we have
humongous data available everybody is
online either making a transaction or
just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data every
minute and that data my friend is the
key to analysis also the memory handling
capabilities of computers have largely
increased which helps them to process
such huge amount of data at hand without
any delay and yes computers now have
great computational powers so there are
a lot of applications of machine
learning out there to name a few machine
learning is used in healthcare where
diagnostics are predicted for doctor's
review the sentiment analysis that the
tech giants are doing on social media is
another interesting application of
machine learning fraud detection in the
finance sector and also to predict
customer churn in the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered surge pricing often where it
says the fear of your trip has been
updated continue booking yes please i'm
getting late for office
well that's an interesting machine
learning model which is used by global
taxi giant uber and others where they
have differential pricing in real time
based on demand the number of cars
available bad weather rush r etc so they
use the surge pricing model to ensure
that those who need a cab can get one
also it uses predictive modeling to
predict where the demand will be high
with the goal that drivers can take care
of the demand and search pricing can be
minimized great hey siri can you remind
me to book a cab at 6 00 pm today okay
i'll remind you thanks no problem
comment below some interesting everyday
examples around you where machines are
learning and doing amazing jobs so
that's all for machine learning basics
today from my site keep watching this
space for more interesting videos until
then happy learning machine learning has
improved our lives in a number of
wonderful ways today let's talk about
some of these i'm rahul from simply
learn and these are the top 10
applications of machine learning first
let's talk about virtual personal
assistants google assistant alexa
cortana and siri now we've all used one
of these at least at some point in our
lives now these help improve our lives
in a great number of ways for example
you could tell them to call someone you
could tell them to play some music you
could tell them to even schedule an
appointment so how do these things
actually work first they record whatever
you're saying send it over to a server
which is usually in a cloud decode it
with the help of machine learning in
neural networks and then provide you
with an output so if you ever notice
that these systems don't work very well
without the internet that's because the
server couldn't be contacted next let's
talk about traffic predictions now say i
wanted to travel from buckingham palace
to large cricket ground the first thing
i would probably do is to get on google
maps so
search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get to large cricket ground now here
the map is a combination of red yellow
and blue now the blue regions signify a
clear road that is you won't encounter
traffic there the yellow indicate that
they're slightly congested and red means
they're heavily congested so let's look
at the map a different version of the
same map and here as i told you before
red means heavily congested yellow means
slow moving and blue means clear
so how exactly is google able to tell
you that the traffic is clear slow
moving or heavily congested so this is
the help of machine learning and with
the help of two important measures first
is the average time that's taken on
specific days at specific times on that
route the second one is the real time
location data of vehicles from google
maps and with the help of sensors some
of the other popular map services are
bing maps maps dot me and here we go
next up we have social media
personalization so say i want to buy a
drone and i'm on amazon and i want to
buy a dji mavic pro the thing is it's
close to one lap so i don't want to buy
it right now but the next time i'm on
facebook i'll see an advertisement for
the product next time i'm on youtube
i'll see an advertisement even on
instagram i'll see an advertisement so
here with the help of machine learning
google has understood that i'm
interested in this particular product
hence it's targeting me with these
advertisements this is also with the
help of machine learning let's talk
about email spam filtering now this is a
spam that's in my inbox now how does
gmail know what spam and what's not spam
so gmail has an entire collection of
emails which have already been labeled
as spam or not spam so after analyzing
this data gmail is able to find some
characteristics like the word lottery or
winner from then on any new email that
comes to your inbox goes through a few
spam filters to decide whether it's spam
or not now some of the popular spam
filters that gmail uses is content
filters header filters general blacklist
filters and so on next we have online
fraud detection now there are several
ways that online fraud can take place
for example there's identity theft where
they steal your identity fake accounts
where these accounts only last for how
long the transaction takes place and
stop existing after that and man in the
middle attacks where they steal your
money while the transaction is taking
place the feed forward neural network
helps determine whether a transaction is
genuine or fraudulent so what happens
with feed forward neural networks are
that the outputs are converted into hash
values and these values become the
inputs for the next round so for every
real transaction that takes place
there's a specific pattern a fraudulent
transaction would stand out because of
the significant changes that it would
cause with the hash values stock market
trading machine learning is used
extensively when it comes to stock
market trading now you have stock market
indices like nikai they use long short
term memory neural networks now these
are used to classify process and predict
data when there are time lags of unknown
size and duration now this is used to
predict stock market trends assistive
medical technology now medical
technology has been innovated with the
help of machine learning diagnosing
diseases has been easier from which we
can create 3d models that can predict
where exactly there are lesions in the
brain it works just as well for brain
tumors and ischemic stroke lesions they
can also be used in fetal imaging and
cardiac analysis now some of the medical
fields that machine learning will help
assist in is disease identification
personalized treatment drug discovery
clinical research and radiology and
finally we have automatic translation
now say you're in foreign country and
you see billboards and signs that you
don't understand that's where automatic
translation comes of help now how does
automatic translation actually work the
technology behind it is the same as the
sequence of sequence learning which is
the same thing that's used with chat
bots here the image recognition happens
using convolutional neural networks and
the text is identified using optical
character recognition furthermore the
sequencing sequence algorithm is also
used to translate the text from one
language to the other hi everyone
welcome to this tutorial on r
and this is for beginners
let's see what is our programming
and how it helps
so r
is
well known as a language of data science
now if you
really look at the ranking
from survey of data mining experts
based on the softwares they have often
used in their work
r is used more than python when it comes
to data science python is also used
however r is
predominantly more used for data science
kind of activities it's a open source
programming language used for
statistical computing it is one of the
most popular programming languages today
it was inspired by s plus
and it is similar to s programming
language so when it comes to data
science
what we can say is r is
a popularly used programming language
across the globe
it is free and open source as i
mentioned it is optimized for vector
operations which we will learn about
later
it has an amazing
community
has
in fact 9000 plus
contributed or community packages
allowing us to do
almost anything or everything using r
now when we talk about features of r
as i said it's open source programming
language so you can install r for free
and you can straight away start working
you wouldn't have to really go for a
licensed version or pay for the software
non-coders can also understand and
perform programming in r as it is easy
to understand
and it has various data structures and
operators it can be integrated with
other programming languages like c c
plus plus java and python
it consists of various inbuilt packages
a lot of sample data sets which can be
used
and that makes
reporting the results of an analysis
easier by using r
now before we start learning about
variables loops how you work with r and
so on it would be good to know how you
can set up r and work on r so for that
what you can do is you can just go to r
minus project
dot org
and
once we get to the home page
of our project for statistical computing
using this link
we can click on download r here
now that brings you to a page to
download it now there are various links
here so it shows you the comprehensive r
archive network that is cran mirrors
and it is available at different urls
however i would choose the first one
which is zero cloud you can just click
on this one and then based on your
operating system whether you are working
on a linux machine on a macbook or
windows you can install it so you can
just click on this one as of now i'm
using a windows machine so i can click
on download r for windows and that takes
me to this link which says binaries for
base distribution now this is what we
can use to work with r straight away
however there is one more package
that is r studio we will see how we can
set up that now this one
takes us to the best mirror possible
for our location from where we can
download r
so you can click on this base and then
you can download by clicking on this
link i have already downloaded this so
once you click on this one you can just
save it so i have it here already in my
downloads and that's more than enough
then you can just double click and you
can
go through the instructions
to set up r
that would also allow you to basically
set up a desktop shortcut which i have
already done here on my machine and if i
go in here i see our base you can click
on this one and that brings you to the
page which you can use to straight away
start working with r
now
yes there is
one more package called rstudio which is
set up on top of base r which makes
working with r easier now here also you
can start working so it shows you our
console
and you can click on file and if you
have some scripts or files already
written in the format of r you can use
those so i can click on open script and
that takes me to a page where i have
some files which are already existing i
can just select this one and click on
open
and that shows me some options here so i
have an editor which shows me say if i
want to get a library to use built-in
data sets i could summarize the data i
could do a cleanup and we'll see all of
this but i would suggest using rstudio
rather than just using base r however
installing base r would be required and
depending on your machine configuration
like mine is a 64-bit i have chosen
64-bit while i was setting up base r
now when it comes to r studio
it is basically a
package which makes working with are
easier
so to install our studio what you can do
is you can go to the rstudio home page
or you can just go to google and say
type r studio download
and then it takes you to this page you
can click on this which says download
rstudio you can choose your version you
can go for the free version that is our
studio desktop and you can click on this
download and then you can download
rstudio for windows which i have already
done and then you have to run through
the steps so just click on this one and
i already have our studio here
right now i can just basically use that
so for example if i go to downloads and
if i look for r studio if i do a double
click i can say yes
and then it takes me to the r studio
setup just click on next
and here
you can choose the location if you would
want to place it in a specific location
click on next and then it says select
the start menu folder so let our studio
be chosen here click on install
and then it will basically start
installing
this in a particular location now in my
case it is already existing right so
we can even click on show details and
see what it is doing what packages or
what executables it is extracting now
once this is done then you will be able
to use our studio you can also add a
shortcut to your taskbar
and you can continue using it so i've
already done this this might take couple
of seconds just wait for this to
complete
and you would have r studio
which is an easier way of working with r
so a lot of developers across the globe
would be using r studio when they are
working with r to work on their data
science or programming requirements
now let's just wait it is almost done
and now i can click on finish
so so that part is done you can add it
as a shortcut so rstudio has consistent
commands
it has unified interface it makes easy
to navigate and manage through r
and it is set up on top of your
our base now if i click and open on this
so
that's my r studio which is coming up
now
here you see console
which
will show you the result where you can
give your commands
so where we can get text output now
again i can choose a file so i can just
say open file and then i can go into a
particular location where i have
downloaded some data
and then basically i can choose say for
example rstudio
and that brings me here
so now you have your script which has
some commands
right
on the left
bottom you have console where you can
see the output
on the right side you also have
environment
now that is to use or provide variables
and then we can also have plots which
we can see here now we can look at this
as an example so here i am
loading the built-in data sets so what i
can just do is i can place my cursor
here and i can just do a control enter
and that basically loads the built-in
data sets which we can see here that has
been done now there is an inbuilt iris
data set
and we can just use head option to look
at the first six lines of iris data set
so
just place your cursor and do a control
enter and that shows you a summary
basically the first six lines of this
data set what it contains we will look
into this data set later this is a
default data set
which you can easily find when you're
working with r you can also have your
cursor placed on summary and then just
do a control enter so that basically
shows you summary statistics for iris
data you can do a plot
and that basically shows you the plot
which you can also maximize and look at
it in full screen you can just do a zoom
if you are interested in looking into
this and we will discuss how
or what kind of information we can infer
from the plots now when it comes to
cleaning up you can just do detach and
then we can say package data sets
and here we had loaded those data sets
so we are just doing a detach and we can
say unload equals true so i'll just do a
control enter i can also clear off the
plots by doing this
for whatever plots we had and we can
either do a edit and then we can do a
clear console from here or the shortcut
is ctrl r and you can clear of the
console
so that's a simple way of starting
your working with r by installing our
studio
so let's continue learning
about working with r
and basically the first thing which we
should learn here is about variables in
r
so variables
as in any programming language is a way
to store
your data value
factor of list values or a data set or
object in r
it allows us to conveniently reference
the variable name
basically saving us from rewriting
the data value or object many times in
our program so when we talk about
variables in r
they are mainly used to store
data with named locations that your
programs can manipulate
a variable can be a combination of
letters digits period and underscore
so you can have some valid variables as
total sum
you can also have dot notation so there
are different naming or style
conventions in r and we can use dot to
separate names in description of a
variable we can also start a variable
with dot
we can include numbers in a variable and
remember r is case sensitive so we have
to whenever we declare a variable we
need to remember what case was used
as in
in the name of the variable and there
can be other conventions also such as
using an underscore or even using a case
in between the variables so variables
can only consist of letters numbers
periods
underscores
your dot
followed by a letter not a number
and we can declare our variables we can
also look at the type of the variables
and the class to which it belongs so
there are some invalid variables which
we are seeing here so that also needs to
be remembered so this is an example
where you can use an assignment operator
which you see here between x and 10 to
assign a value to a variable you could
also do that by doing a dot y
and then assign a value you could be
doing that by using a z
and then having a
computation done between x and y and
finally you could do a print so let's
see some example here before we move
further and for that i can bring up my r
studio here so as i said we can
basically have different
kind of variables or naming conventions
for example i could do something like
model one
and then i can basically assign this so
this is just
a
variable and i could be assigning
anything to it i could be assigning
different data types which are available
here for example i could do something
like this and i could do a control
enter
so
that's my variable i can always do a
type
of and then basically
i can check what's the type of my
variable so it tells it's a character
i can also
do a class
and then i can basically say show me the
class and that shows me it belongs to
the character class we'll learn about
data types later but we are using
assignment operator now if i say what is
model 1 it shows me the value but if i
would do something like this
then it says object model not found and
why because it is case sensitive the
variable which we had created was all in
lower case
and the one which we tried to call was
starting with an upper case
so you could have variables created in
such way i could also do something like
hello
underscore string
and this could be my variable where we
are using an underscore
and then we can just given something
here
and that becomes my variable which you
can always call
and check what is the value of that you
could also be doing something like this
so you could
be using
different cases
and then i could say
something like this and that's also my
variable
and then i can basically look at the
value of this variable now
if we
try to create a variable where we start
the variable name with the number what
would happen so if i say something like
this and then if i try to assign a value
to it
for example let's say 100 now this one
will throw an error message because you
cannot have
your variable starting with a number but
if i used period and then basically
give
something like this
and let's try doing this
by giving it a number
so
if you see here
since we gave a period
the rule is that it should be followed
always by
a
letter and not a number so i could just
remove this and that works perfectly
fine
so these are some naming conventions
which when you practice you will learn
about so now i can assign a variable by
just doing a dot pairs and then assign
any value to it but always remember if
you are using a period if you are using
a notation then in that case that should
always be followed by a letter
one more thing which is always practiced
in a real time environment is that
we cannot have spaces
when we are creating variables so for
example if i say first
num and then i try to assign this a
value
it basically fails but obviously i could
have done this by doing it underscore
and that perfectly works fine and you
can basically then call the value for
this one always remember one more
standard practice which is followed in
real time environment
is you will try to have variable names
with
a little meaning to them so for example
if i would create a variable
and i would say for example
let's say bird
that's my variable name
and then if i assign this a value tiger
it works fine but then it really does
not make sense
and that would basically create a lot of
ambiguity in our coding so it is always
good to say for example animal
and then i would say okay so tiger is an
animal and that basically not only
allows me to assign a value to the
variable but it is also little bit more
meaningful
now when we talk about variables it is
also good to know the different data
types which are available in r now like
any other programming language
r also supports different data types
so you have your logical data type such
as true and false you have numeric
values which is say these numbers you
could also be creating an integer
which is 3l and 40 l for l and so on you
can have a complex number you can have
characters which can be just letters or
a set of letters or anything which is
within the quotes or you can even have
raw data so these are different data
types we can again see quick examples
here on data types let me come out of
this one
and as we saw already when we created
model 1 this was character now i can
just say x and let's say
100 and obviously this is going to be
not my integer
okay so let's see this what is this one
this one by default is double
it is by default double so if i would
want an integer then i would say for
example something like
like this
and this one you can check
by using type off and you can see the
value for this one so this is an integer
so similarly you can have character you
can have
complex you can have raw data you can
have numeric values so all these are
different data types you could also be
saying for example i would want to check
the boolean so i could check this
and select this one
and now when i check the value for a it
is true
and we will learn about logical
operators where we can basically be
using these values assigned to the
variables to compare to compute between
different variables
so this is a simple small example of
using variables
so we have seen here using variables and
also
using the assignment operator
and then assigning values to the
variables and different naming
conventions we can also be
using different data types which are
supports
and work with the variables
now once we have learnt about variables
or data types let's also just
first learn about your operators
and how they can be used in your r
programming language
now
we might be
intending to do some calculations on
numeric values uh find out differences
between values
or say for example compare values so in
that we can be using different kind of
operators so we have
various operators we have arithmetic
operators we have rational
operators we also have logical operators
so before we straightaway look into
logical operators let's also understand
about the basics such as your arithmetic
operators which supports for example let
me pull up a notepad file here
and
when we talk about arithmetic
operators
here we are talking about
your
addition
[Music]
you have subtraction
you have multiplication
you have division
and you have remainder or modulus
and you have exponent
and what makes it also important is that
when you are using arithmetic operators
you also need to know about the order of
operations
so when you say order of operations
always the priority is to parenthesis
so that takes the priority you have then
exponent
or your computation if that would
involve
exponent
so let's say
x one end here
which is then followed by your
multiplication
and division
and that one also follows an order of
left to right
whichever comes first when we talk about
multiplication and division and
similarly when we talk about addition
and subtraction
it is left to right
whichever comes first so these are some
of the arithmetic operators now we can
see some examples here quickly
although these are some simple examples
so for example i can say 100 plus 100
and that gives me the value right you
can always do a 100 minus
50.
you can do a hundred multiplication
you could do a hundred division two
or you could also use modulus
to
which basically gives you an error here
so i will
oh
just give me a minute
so let's give here one more percentage
sign
and that basically says what would be
the remainder
so if we would want to look at the
ordering when we are using this
arithmetic operators
we can see an example so for example if
i say 34 plus 46
divided by 2 gives me 57
however if i use 34 plus 46 in
paranthesis which gets the priority and
then i divide my result is different so
understanding what arithmetic operators
you can use
and also the ordering in which
that leads to the computation is very
important
so we can use all of these arithmetic
operators and to control the ordering we
can be using paranthesis
or we can have our computations ordered
with what kind of operation we would
want whether that would be
multiplication or division addition or
subtraction now at any point of time i
can always do a control l
and that allows me to clear my console
let's continue our learning and let's
learn about operators
so when we speak about arithmetic
operators we see that allows us to do
computations but we have also rational
and logical operators which help us in
doing our computations or comparing
values or sometimes finding
difference between different values
whether those are group of values or
whether those are individual values so
with your rational and logical operators
you can compare data values
so
if we would want to see if the values
match or not match or if the values are
above or below equal to something and so
on
so when we talk about your rational
operators we basically have
in case of rational or
logical operators
national or logical operators
so we obviously have greater than
you have
less than
you have greater than or
equal
you have less than
or equal
you have equal to
and you have not equal
these are some of your
rational operators we can say
and when you talk about your logical
operators then you have and you have or
and you have not
so and is
when it compares two values so it
returns true if both the conditions are
true else it will return a false
so for example if i have 10 greater than
and 10 is less than 20 now that's not
possible and we are comparing
the result of both of these so we are
checking if both the conditions are true
and that's not
really true here so we see the value is
false now if i would have replaced this
one this and with r
it would check
even if one of the conditions is true it
would basically show me a result as true
you can also use a not operator which
takes each element of the vector
and gives the opposite value
so we can be using any one of these
operators
and then basically do our computations
so let's see some examples about these
logical operators now either you could
just be assigning values to your
variables and check or you could also be
picking up a data set
from your machine
and then try to use these logical
operators so for example if i say x
has been assigned 100
y
has been assigned 200
and if i try to say x
equals
y
so that already
checks the value and compares and tells
me that's not true it is false
and if i would have used a not operator
for example if i would have said
something like
this one
so it tells me true so i can just check
simple conditions like this
i can say
is my y greater than x
and that tells me yes it is true
if i say y is greater than or equal to x
well
it would still say true
because when you are saying greater than
or equal to x so when you are saying
this one it works fine right now we can
also be picking up some data set and for
that what i can do is i can pick up one
of the data set from my machine so i can
go in here and i have some data sets
let's look into that and i would be
interested in taking this auction data
set and loading the values here so i'll
get this path
and i will come here i can use auction
as my variable name you could have given
a dot separated name for example i could
have said auction dot data if this is
what you want to do
and then you can assign variable
a value so here i'll say read.csv and i
intend to pick up a file so i give this
path
and when we are working on windows
machine we need to give a double slash
so i'll say
auction.csv now i could give other
things like header being true
what is the separator
if you would want to fill values to take
care of missing values we can look at
all of those so here i'll just add a
backslash
i will add a backslash
and i will basically just do a ctrl
enter now i can look at the values of
this by just doing a auction.data
and i can see what values it has so it
has a lot of data here
it has a lot of your data here you could
have used some other functions which we
can see later
where
i can choose
head
and i can see the first top five values
so we can basically
assign
data to the variable and continue
working on this
now we can keep it simple so let me
repeat this step
and here i will say auction
as my variable name and i'll assign this
so i can basically do a also a view
on auction
so auction
and then basically that shows me a
tabular format of the data which allows
me to look into the data and basically
understand it and then i can
you know
use this to work on variables so what i
can do here is i can say x and let's say
assign some value to this for which i
would want to work on my data set which
is auction
now what do i want to do here so let's
use auction and then i can use a dollar
symbol and i can choose which column i'm
interested in so for example let's
choose bidder
and i can just give a value to this one
and let's pick up a name
so let's say tweak
and that's the name
and i can be assigning all the values to
this
or i could say i would want to use
another condition so i'll say option
dollar
and then let's take this value of bid
and let's say it is equals to
and then i ended up with comma and i can
try doing this now here it gives me a
problem because what we did was
we
did not use the right operator so we
will say for example and
so i will say
x
is being assigned the value of
auction bidder
being
tweak
and auction bid value being hundred
so now once we do this i can look at the
value of x and that shows me the value
so this is just a simple example of
using a logical operator now i could
have
just said
instead of and i could have used or
which is basically a pipe
which you have to use
and that gives you or condition and now
hit on enter and if i now look at the
values of x it will show me lot of
values because we have given an or
condition which basically matches one of
the conditions so in this way we can use
logical operators and continue working
and
continue doing our computations
let's learn about print formatting and
how print can be used to
view your data
when you talk about r r uses print
function to display the variables
so for example if i have assigned number
10 to x
i can do a print x and that will show me
the value of
x
what we see here with one in square
brackets that also has a meaning which
basically means it is a vector and we'll
learn about vectors later so r uses the
paste and paste
0 functions to format strings any
variables together for printing in few
different ways for example
if i would do this which i says print
paste
and then
pass in
two strings here or two words here such
as hello and world
that would be
printed as follows now i could also do a
print paste
and then use a separator
so my print would look something like
this
if i use page zero then that avoids any
space between these two words
or for example these three words
so let's see some basic examples here
when we talk about
print so for example if i bring up my r
studio here is an example so x
as we say now this is your assignment
operator which we already discussed
now i can be assigning a value to this
so i can just place my cursor here
and i can just hit on control enter so
value has been assigned now let's look
at the value of x
now i could also be doing a print x
explicitly by
using print function for example if i do
similarly for message as hello
and then i can print the message
by using print
now if for example i do something like
this
this is not going to print anything
until i call the variable or i use a
print function so for example if i do a
y
pc auto printing
shows us the value or i could do
explicitly by using the print function
by explicit printing now whenever we
look at this number one as i mentioned
it means y
is a vector
and 5
is its first element
now you can also use operator to create
integer sequences and we'll learn about
sequences or list later but this is just
a simple example so i am creating an
integer sequence of length 20
i can place my cursor here
which would start with 10 and end at 30
so let's look at this values
for
our sequence
of integers
now at any point of time you can always
use a class
to look at
the
class
of say x
and that shows me the classes
of integers
now looking further when we talk about
different data types as we learned
few minutes before so r has basically
five basic or atomic classes of objects
so you have character numeric values
that is real numbers you have integers
you have complex and you have logical
values
let's
spend some time in understanding some
basic arithmetic operations and how you
can do it using your r programming
language now here i've opened up rstudio
and these are some basic examples such
as performing arithmetic operations
now for example we can add two numbers
and i can just place my cursor here and
please press ctrl enter
that shows me the addition i can do a
subtraction
i can do multiplication division
also going for exponential power
or use modulo which returns the
remainder
now
when we are performing operations what
we can also do is we can change the
order of operations
and in this case we are using
parenthesis so i am putting in 500 into
2 in a paranthesis
plus
80 divided by 2 so first it operates
what is given in parenthesis
and that's why i get a result 1040
similarly i can change the order of
operations so here i can give 500 into
and then something in the paranthesis so
that gets operated first and hence you
get result of thousand five hundred now
we have already discussed about the
assignment operator and what we can do
here is we can assign variables
some value so for example
i create a variable called selling and
then i would assign it a value
similarly for cost and then we can do
some calculation so we can say profit
is selling minus cost
we can do that and here i can look at
the value of profit which shows me 250.
now let's also spend some time in
understanding data types in our so we
can have different types
of data so
this one shows me an example of
assigning a decimal value which is part
of a numeric class so i can do this
and then if i would be interested in
seeing the value of num so i can just
look at the value of num
if i would be interested in looking at
the type of num so i can do that here by
just typing in type off
and
then select this one and pass in your
num and it shows me the value is double
i can also look at what class it belongs
to and that shows me
it is numeric
so in this way you can not only assign
values to a variable but you can look at
the class and type of it now here we can
assign whole numbers
which are also known as integers now if
i look at the type of this it shows me
double so if i would want to explicitly
assign an integer i could have done for
example i
let's say j
and i could have used the assignment
operator and i could have done this
and then if i look at the value of j it
shows me the value but what we would be
interested in looking at the class of j
so we can do this and it shows me it is
an integer so explicitly either i can
assign this by using a capital l
or i could use a function called
as dot integer so we'll see that later
now we can also assign boolean values or
basically your logicals so here we
assign true and then we do a false
and we can look at the type of t and
that tells me it is a logical class
now similarly you might be interested in
working on
text or string values and here we can do
this by saying
ch and then passing in a value look at
the class of this it tells me it is
the data type is character and if you
look at the type of it it says me
character
similarly r also supports complex data
types so we can do that too by just
doing this and look at the class of it
it tells me it is complex and you can
also pull out the length of this
by
now here we are doing a length on
the character so let's look at this one
and it shows me what is the length of
this
now
one of the useful functions which we
usually use in r is print now i can
simply do a print hey and that prints
whatever values pass to print i can
assign a value to a variable and then
print it so that is also fine you could
have also without using function just
type y and that also shows the value
however sometimes using print as an
explicit function can be useful it makes
your code more readable now here we
would use an inbuilt data set that is
empty cars
and then if you would want to print the
data set that shows me the values which
shows me
the car models and different other
features such as mileage cylinder
horsepower and so on now one of the use
case of print
with a paste function can also be seen
here so i'm doing a print paste and that
basically prints whatever was passed in
a concatenated way i could also do a
print paste with a separator
if i would want to format my data in a
particular way so here i've used
separator as comma
there is one more function paste 0 which
can be used so i'm just doing here paste
0 and that tells me just concatenate
these values without any space so paste
0 shows no space between these two
elements which were passed now we can
explicitly do some printing and for that
i'm using a s print f
option
i am going to pass in percentage s which
is for string and percentage f for float
and we can print the values of this so
these are some basic operations or usage
of your functions to
basically
do some computations or look at your
results
so when you talk about basic type of any
r object it is a vector
and when we talk about vectors empty
vectors can be created with vector
function
a vector can contain objects of same
type or a class now when we talk about
list
list is a vector which contains objects
of different classes
so these are some basic examples so
apart from your print formatting we can
be looking at what we call as our
objects such as vectors or lists and so
on so when we talk about vectors it is a
sequence of data elements of same basic
type
we use
the function to declare a vector so we
can always do a c function to declare a
vector
for example here we are creating a
variable v 1 and we are assigning it a
vector by using c and then giving some
basic type so numbers one to five or for
example words you can always do a print
or you can also use a class
to find out what is the class
of the elements or
the values which have been passed to the
particular object so we can look at some
examples like this for example
we can see here so list
is a vector which contains objects of
different classes
so
you can have numeric objects so that is
your numbers such as 1 2 etc
which are your numeric values for
example here what we are doing is we are
assigning a value 1
to a
and that
can then be used i can either do a print
or i can just use auto printing i can
also do
here a value for a i
or i could be doing something like this
which shows me 0
which can be for missing value so if i
would want to
use auto printing i can just call a and
it shows me the value what has been
assigned to it you can always use a type
of
to look at the value of a which is
double by default and if i look at type
of a i
that is basically an integer because we
used l here
so in this way we can continue working
with say
our different classes
of objects so for example let's create a
vector here so i can say v1 and then
basically assign it by using a c
function
and then pass in the values to this one
and that basically
gives me a variable and you can look at
what are the values assigned to it now
if i look at the class of v1
that shows me it is numeric if you use
type off
and then you would want to see the
values of v1 that shows me the values
are double now as we were seeing here we
can be looking at the class so for
example if i create one more
variable and then assign values to it
using c
so
passing in some words here
for example let's go and say hello world
and then i can basically
do this
and look at the values of this one i
could also explicitly print as we
discussed earlier
by doing a print v2 we could also be
having a paste function
if we would want to use that so for
example if i would do a paste function
i could be using
and this is missing a bracket so let's
complete this
and that shows me the value i could have
also used for example
paste 0 function
and that also works fine
so it depends on what we are looking at
here so if i look at class
of v1 which we had it is numeric and v2
is basically
having elements which are of the class
character
so this is just a simple example of
having
your print functions
having vectors created printing out the
values of those printing out class and
type of these
to continue our learning on vectors
as i mentioned earlier we can use the c
function
which can be used to create vectors of
objects by concatenating things together
so for example if we look at this
one which says x and then i use c
function and i say
0.5 and 0.6 so we can have a vector of
numeric types
so let's
do this
and then we can look at the value of x
so it shows me my vector which has 0.5
and 0.06 i can also have my vector of
logical values
and now let's look at the value of x so
it has true and false or we could have
done it in this way
where we can then look at the values so
we can use the short form by using
capital t and f
i can create a vector
with character types and then look at
the values of those
i can also be
creating a sequence of integers as we
saw in previous example and then look at
the values which start at 9 and end at
29. now you can also create with complex
types and look at the values so these
are some simple examples of creating
vectors now we can also use vector
function to initialize vectors
so for example if i would do this
where i'm saying my vector will be of
type numeric length is 10 and then look
at the values so it just shows me
a vector which has
all zeros and the length is 10. now you
can create a vector of numbers
by doing this as we saw in previous
example
and use explicit printing to look at the
values or might be a letters
and then use a print statement to print
function to basically look at the values
of the vector now we can also try
concatenating the above two
so that creates a mixed vector which has
two different kind of types here so i
can do a mixed vector
by using the c function and then passing
in my numbers
which has numeric types and letters
which has character types
and then we can basically do a printing
of this which shows me the value but
here what we see is coercion that is
basically
casting if you would know as the word in
different programming languages so it
basically coerces the numbers to
character as characters cannot be
coerced into numbers
and then you can print the values of
this mixed vector where everything is of
character types so for example
at this point of time if i would have
done something like class
of mixed
vector
and if i would want to look into the
values of this one it shows me
everything is of character types here
now
data type of different vectors can be
returned by the function class as we saw
just now so it is common to use the
class function to integrate an object
asking what is the class
now we can create one dimensional object
such as an integer vector which we have
done earlier and then look at the class
of it which tells me it is an integer i
can also create a numeric vector
by giving in some values here
so when we do this
so i have given the vector function c
and then giving in the value and look at
the class it shows me it would have
numeric values
now you can create a character vector
and then basically look at the values of
it now at any point of time in all of
these for example if i would do num
i can see what are the values assigned
to it
i can do letters
and i can see the values of this so let
me just create some space here now i can
create a factor vector
and then look at the values of it or
also you can see
what is the value in this factor vector
so here we said as
dot
factor so factor function is being used
here and we are creating a vector of
letters
and then we look at the class
we also look at the values what are
assigned to this
or what are in this particular vector so
if you look into all of these vector
examples
initially we were
using an assignment operator where we
were using the c function and when we
started creating vectors by say
concatenating or vectors of particular
types we are using equals here and that
also is fine
now looking further
when we look at concatenating two
different kind of vectors so for example
here we have
say
numbers and letters
as we discussed earlier
it will do coercion that is change
one type
into other
now when we talk about one dimensional
objects we can have integer vectors
or say float which we saw just now
ending at
10.5 so when we say c 1 is to 10
it basically starts with one but then
there is also you can say a question
happening here and then you have the
values ending at 10.5 that is float
and i can look at the class of it
and when we did a class of
did we do a class here so let's come
here and let's do a class of this one it
saves me it is numeric you can look at
the values of it
similarly you can create a character
vector which is
1 to 10 and then basically look at the
class of it or basically the value of
this vector
or as we did the factor vector now for
two dimensionals we will explore that
when we are learning about matrix so as
of now let's forget that now when you
talk about mixing objects there are
occasions when
classes of our objects get mixed
together so that could be accidentally
or that could be intentional so if you
look at this example here we have y
which has been given values which is 1.7
and a
and at this stage if i would look at the
value of y
that's my vector
if you look at the class of y
that shows me
it is
as character now when you look at some
other examples so let's pass in
logical and numeric values
what would happen in this case so we can
again
use
class
of y
and that basically has numeric
and if you would want to look at the
value of y that shows me
1 and 2 here
let's go further
so
let's look at the value of this one so y
and then basically see what is the value
of y so it is a
true
and you can also look at the class of it
now we are mixing objects of two
different classes in a vector remember
when we talk about vector we always talk
about vector having elements of same
type
but when we talk about
lists which we will learn later
that would have
basically
or that can have
your each element of different type
so for vectors it is not allowed so when
different objects are mixed in a vector
coercion occurs so that every element in
the vector is
of the same class
now
we have seen earlier the implicit
coercion where our r tries to find
a way to represent all the objects or
elements as i say so all the objects in
the vector in a reasonable fashion so we
can also be doing explicit coercion so
that is
from one class to another by using a as
dot and then using a relevant function
so if i have x here now if i look at the
class of x it tells me it is an integer
but i can convert that to numeric by
doing a as dot numeric or as dot logical
or as dot character to basically do a
coefficient and change the class of the
objects now if r cannot figure out how
to coerce an object this will result in
nas being produced which we can also
relate to missing values or not
applicable values so for example if we
create x and look at the class of x it
tells me this character let's try
changing character to numeric which will
not work and it says n a's are
introduced if you do it even in logical
that would not work and it shows me any
values or if you do a complex it says
values have been introduced so at this
point of time if i look at the value of
x it tells me
it was assigned a b c and we try to
convert that into a different class
now when we talk about vectors it is
also good to know about attributes in
brief
so
all your r objects have attributes that
is metadata for object so when you talk
about our object attributes you could
have names you can have dimension names
you can have the dimensions that is
matrices and arrays you can look at the
classes such as integer numeric and so
on and you can also look at length which
is user defined attribute so if i say x
we are assigning a value to x now at
this point of time if i see my value to
x is 1 but then all objects need not
necessarily have attributes so in that
case whenever you try to use an
attributes function
that would return null so
at this point of time if i look at the
attributes of x
it shows me null value so these are some
of the basics which
help us in working with r
and using your vector function
or looking at the coercion which is
implicitly happening or explicitly can
be done by us by using a as dot sum
function
now let's learn about
lists
and how we can work
using r on list
when we talk about vector which we saw
in previous examples
vector is a one-dimensional array right
and it can hold elements only of same
type so we would say vector is more of
one-dimensional but when you talk about
list list is a generic vector that can
contain objects of different types
so when you talk about say for example
matrices matrices can also hold elements
of same type but
in matrices it is a two dimensional
array we will talk about matrices also
we will learn so when you talk about
lists they can contain all kind of r
objects
so you can have dates you can have data
frames you can have vectors and many
more so in list
there is no coercion which is required
that is changing of data type there is
no loss of functionality and lists do
not follow any predefined structure now
we can create lists using this list
function as it is shown here so you can
create a variable and then assign a list
to it where you can be
using either passing in a vector or what
you can do is you can simply create a
list by using this list function so
let's see some example here now for that
what we can do is i can bring up my r
studio
where we can see an example on list and
how it works so when you talk about list
what you can do here is
let me close this one
and this one yeah
so what we can do is we can basically
say for example test
and i can basically
give
something here so for example i can say
music tracks
and then i can say how many hundred of
them
and i can say
let's give 100 as number
and then we can say how many of them got
5 stars
and
i can do this so i can
check this and this shows me all the
objects or elements of this
list right
now
when we do this what we are doing is we
are creating a vector right and vector
basically
can have coefficient depending on what
are the elements which are passed
because whenever you use the c
and you create a vector
it will only accept
elements of the same type so for example
if i do a class on test
it shows me
here all the objects are of type
character right and you can also use
type off
to check
for
our test variable and
it is basically having all the objects
as character now how would you create a
list so what we can do is we can use a
list function so for example let's again
do a test here but this time i am
interested in creating a list
and list can have objects of different
types so let's say
music
tracks and then i can just give hundred
and i can say with rating 5
and now if i look at my test it shows me
all the elements
of your particular list here
we see each element or each object with
a double bracket and we can see each
element
now what we can also do is we can use is
list
function and then we can pass and test
here to check what is it and it is a
list right
so here we have created a list but if
for example we take the previous example
where we were creating a vector
and if i would do a is list it would
show me false right so we just created a
simple list
and we can also arrange labels
or
we can
use a name function to basically give
names so what i can do here is let me
create a list first
so i can do that like this
and now what i can do is i can do a name
and i can use a name function to this
test
and then basically what i can do is i
can pass labels
so here i can just
given some names here
so for example i can say
let's give it a name
product
so say we are talking about product of a
company
and then we can say
here i can give
count
and here i can give rating
and this is basically two given names so
let's just give
some error here let me just check this
so let's use this
name function here and what i'll do is
i will basically
use names
and now let's
do a test
so that shows me the names what we have
assigned
to
our
list objects
now
we can always access the elements of our
objects from a list
using indices or even using double
square so for example i have test here
and basically i can give something like
this
which gives me based on the indices
the position
where you are
accessing the elements of the list
so we can do this
what i can also do is
we can specify names when creating a
particular list so for example what i
can also do is
i can say
product
dot
category
and now i can just give
list function
so i would want to assign names while
creating a list
so i can say for example
product
and this would be
say
[Music]
music
tracks
then i can give say for example count
and count would be hundred
and then ratings
and i can say five
and
now we can basically access this
list which we have created
so what we have done here unlike
earlier when we created a list and then
basically
use names function to assign a name to
it or each object here while creating a
list itself
we passed in the names so we can also do
that
now
if you would want to basically
list display the list
or
a compactly display structure of a list
we can always use the string function
and here i can pass in the name
so let's choose this one
and this is
in a more compact way listing down the
elements of your list so list can be
containing other lists also and we can
also do that so for example i create one
more list for example i can say similar
product
and here i can give
a list again
and what i would want to do is
i would want to say
product
equals
and i can say film
and then i can basically give a count
and then i can give ratings
say 4
and here what i've done is i have just
created one more list
but my intention is not just to create a
list but i would want to add this
to
our existing list so what we can do here
is
we can take our previous list that is
product dot category
like what we did earlier
and now i intend to
say list
and here i would want to
say for example
let's copy this
or we can just
so this is what we were doing when we
were creating a list using product
giving the names while creating a list
and what i also want to do is here i
will just say
similar
and then pass in
similar dot product
so now if you look at
our list we have just added new elements
so this is one more way where we can
create a list and we can
basically add or our list can have other
list
so when we talk about subsetting or
extending list
so one of the main ways as i said to
access a specific element
or a subset we use double brackets and
we can always do that so for example we
take
our prod dot category and then i would
want to access a particular element so i
can always do this by giving the index
positions
and i can access the elements of my list
so this is one single way now here
if we use a single bracket instead of
double bracket
then in that case we will the output
would be a list
so if i look at this one then this would
be a list but if you use double brackets
then you are accessing
a particular object
if we were creating a vector we could
just be using a subset by using the c
function
now what we can also do is we can subset
by names or even logical
so what we can do here is we can take
this product category and if we have
defined names then in that case what i
can do is i can say i would be
interested in music tracks
and this is the name we had given
so we can close this one
and we can try accessing the elements
here so we what's the name we had given
so
[Music]
no it's not
music tracks that's the value the name
is product
so we do this and then we can access the
elements what we can also do is
we can be
subsetting based on logicals so what we
can do is we can basically just give
something like this
and here we can pass in values
and we missed a bracket
so
that's also a way of pulling out the
values so you can be doing a subsetting
using the names which you have assigned
to objects within your list
or you can say names which you have
assigned to the elements or by using
logicals now what we can also do is we
can use the dollar function now if you
see here we are looking at the name
and that is preceded by dollar
so we can always pull out the values
from our list
by giving the list name and then give it
dollar symbol
and then choose
the name for example if i choose product
i can list the values here i can be
looking at say
dollar and then choose a count and this
is also one way of accessing your
elements from the list using your dollar
symbol
now to add elements to a list as i said
you can add a vector
of names
and that can be passed to your list
so these are different ways in which you
can work with list and then you can
access the elements either using indices
or using names or even using dollar
symbol and pointing the right names so
this is one simple example of working
with your list now
one more and now i can just do a ctrl l
and i can clear that off so
your list always remember is a generic
vector that can contain objects of
different types
now when we talk about matrices now
matrix is a collection of data elements
arranged in two dimensional rectangular
layout so we can use matrix function to
create a matrix as shown here
so matrix is
two dimensional now we already know that
vector is one dimensional array of data
elements or a sequence of data elements
but when we talk about matrix it's a
collection of data elements that is two
dimensional arranged in fixed number of
rows and columns so here you see that we
are creating a matrix and we have
specified the number of rows is three
number of columns is three and we want
it to be arranged by row where we have
given the value as true
so always remember matrix is two
dimensional and matrix can have only one
atomic vector type unlike your list it's
a natural extension of vector going from
one dimension to two dimensions so
matrix actually needs a vector which
contains values that you place in a
matrix and at least one matrix dimension
so we can choose to specify the number
of rows or number of columns when we are
creating matrix so let's see a quick
example of working with matrix so for
example i could just say
matrix which will have values 1 2 6
and then i can basically give n
row
and you can give a value to this one and
that's my matrix similarly you could
also be giving
n columns
so i can just say end call
and i can choose this one and then pass
in the value so that's a matrix where r
fills values column by column now if you
intend to fill up matrix in a row wise
fashion so that your values 1 2 and 3
are in first row then we have to just
modify this in a little bit different
way so we have to say matrix
1 colon 6
and row is 2 and then i can give by
row
so you always have these helper
functions which allow you to
put out the values
so for example i do this
and then i can do a control enter so now
if you see
you have the values 1 2 and 3
in your first row
so when we pass a matrix function to a
vector
that is too short to fill up an entire
matrix then something different happens
we can have a look at this
so say you pass a vector containing
value 1 to 3 to the matrix function
and say explicitly you want a matrix
with 2 rows and 3 columns how do we do
that so for example i can say matrix
and here i can say 1 is to 3
now i can give n row
and then i can give the number of rows
which we want is 2 and then i say n
column
and this one i'll say 3
so i can do this and here what i have
done is i have given the values 1 to 3 i
have said number of rows is 2
and your number of columns is 3. so here
r fills the matrix column by column and
simply repeats the vector
now if you want to fill using a four
element vector in a six element matrix
in that case
obviously r will generate a warning
message now apart from the simple matrix
function which we are seeing
you also have
some functions such as r bind
and c bind
which are offers when you are working
with matrices so we can use those so for
example i could say c bind i could say 1
colon 3 and then i can say 1 colon 3
and that's
my c bind that is column bind where i am
passing the values 1 to 3 and which are
stacked in a in columns i can also do r
bind
and similarly we can be passing in the
values so i can say
r bind and that basically arranges the
values row wise
so be creating a variable for example
let's say n
and let me create
a matrix here
so i'll say matrix now that will contain
1 to 6
and i can say by row
and then you can give
value which is true
and then i can basically say the number
of rows
is going to be 2
and this is also fine so let's look at
the value of n here so you basically
created a matrix with 1 to 6
you arrange them row wise and the number
of rows what you have chosen is 2.
so what we can also do is we can use our
bind and we can add values to it so for
example if i want to add value 7 to 9
what i can simply do is i can do a r
bind i can say i would want to edit my n
and then pass in the values so i can
just do this and this has basically
appended or added values to existing
matrix so similarly you could have done
a column bind and you could have added
values
to your existing matrix so for example
if i
take this one
and look at my n and what i could do is
i could do a c bind
and then i can basically take my
n
and then pass in values to this one so
let's say 10 and 11
and basically i've added 10 11 as a
column to my existing matrix so this is
one simple way where you work with a
matrix and you are
appending the values either at a row
level or at a column level
so let's also look at some other
examples so basically if you would want
to work with matrix one of the useful
things would be naming the matrix that
is in case of matrices we can assign
names to either the columns or the rows
if you don't do it we see the default
values here which follows a numbering
but what we can also do is we can use
two functions here one is row
names
or you can use
column names so these are the two
functions which can be used so for
example let's do a control l
let's try to get our n
and this is what we are doing here but
what we would want to do is we would
want to give them some names so for
example i'll say row names
and then
i will basically
pass in a vector which has
row names or vector which has column
names so what i can do here is i can say
i would want to give row names to n
and then
i basically give some value so for
example let's say
row 1
and then let's say row 2
and
now i can look at my n which has the row
names assigned to my rows similarly i
could have also given column names
so all i need to do here is i need to
say
column one
and then i will say column two
and then i can be using column names
and
let's look at this one so what went
wrong here
so we have three columns here we forgot
that so we have to add one more column
name and then it should be 5. so now if
you look at this one we have just given
row names and column names so naming
the columns or rows in your matrices can
be very useful now as the previous error
says there is also a function called dim
names
and that's basically an argument
of matrix function which can be used so
we could also do something like this so
for example i have
dim names
so let's have r n
and then what you can do is you can do a
dim names
which you can then just create a list
and in this one you can pass in a vector
for row one
and then vector for row two
and what we can do here is once we have
given this
let's give a comma here
and then give c
and then give your column names
which is column one
column two
and then basically
column three
and now if you just look at dim names so
you can just see that you have given
some row names and column names and this
can be used basically to
assign to your list so if you try to
store different objects in a matrix what
would happen
coercion would take place right so for
example if i have x
and let's basically
try to create a matrix which will have 1
to 8
and let's say the number of columns
is going to be 2
so let's look at our x and this has the
values now what if i create
say l
and then basically
i will create a matrix which will be
a matrix of letters
so let's say letters
and then here with letters i'll
say one colon six
now i would want to give the number of
rows
and let's give it say 4
and let's say number of columns
and let's give it 3
and now let's look at the value of l so
it has letters
and x is having numbers and what if we
bind them together using
c bind which is for column wise binding
so for example if i do a c bind
and then pass in
my x comma l
so if you see here there is a coercion
which has happened where everything is
converted into character so you can
always do a class and you can check so
this is a simple example of working with
matrices there are much more you can do
subsetting like what we saw in list but
that we can learn later
now let's learn about data frames
and what is the data frame and how do
you use r to work with data frame now
data frame is used to store the data in
the form of a table and for this
we have a function data dot frame to
create a data frame
so what we know already is that data
sets are comprised of observations or
what we call as instances or variables
and we always have observations
to which
some variables are associated for
example we can talk about
data sets of say five people now let's
look at the information here
here we look at the body mass index bmi
where we are using a data dot frame
function and then we are passing in say
gender so we use the c function to pass
in the values and then you have height
and then you have weight
and h
and these things then become the columns
of your data frame so for example if we
would want to work
on creating a data frame for people
where
let's say each person is an instance
and properties about each person such as
name
age child
or if the person has a child would
become the variables so
if we have such kind of information we
cannot easily store that in matrix or
list now data frames can be used for
such cases
now it's a fundamental data structure to
store data sets pretty similar to matrix
as it has rows and columns and here
rows correspond to observations now here
we can talk about in every individual or
every person
columns correspond to variables that is
properties for each person
now difference
between your data frame and matrix is
that data frames can contain elements of
different data types
so for example we can have one column
being character
other being numeric and yet another
being logical or numeric
so restriction is that elements in one
column should be of the same data type
now how do we work with data frames
let's see some examples so what we can
do is we can bring up our r
so when we talk about data frames
usually we don't create data frames by
ourself we import data from data sources
such as csv file
or rdbms
or even your excel or spss and then we
create data frames of course r has ways
to manually create data frames using
data dot frame function
so we can create three vectors first and
then we can pass in those vectors to
create our data frame so let's do that
so let's say name
and here i will use the assignment
operator which we have learnt earlier
and then i'll use c and then i can give
some names here so let's say john
and let's say peter
let's say patrick
and let's say
julie
and let's also give one more name
so let's say
bob
so this is the vector which we are
creating and we can check
this is the vector which we have created
now obviously you can do a class
and you can check what is this
and that says it is a vector of
character
now similarly we can create one more
vector which is age and let's give some
numbers here so for example let's say 28
and 30 31
and these are the values for the age so
age is also created similarly we can say
if each person has children so we can
say
children and then i'll create one more
vector and here i'll give values which
are logicals
i'm not going to give any numerics or
character but i'm using logicals here so
if a particular person has children or
no
so let's have this
vector created
and now we have three vectors that is
name age and children and we can use
this to create our data frame so we can
just call our data frame as df
and what we can do is we can use data
dot frame function
and then what we can do is we can pass
our vectors within this such as name
age
children
and that should create my data frame
let's have a look at this and this shows
me
that the data frame is created now
column names are inferred from variables
which are passed to data dot frame
function so the variables which we have
passed to our data dot frame function is
name age and children and those become
the column headings for my data frame
now what we could have also done is we
could have created it in a different way
so i could have said df
and then i could have used my data dot
frame function and in data dot frame
function i could have said name is going
to be name
age
would be age
and then i could say
children
could be
and i could do this and this is also one
more way where i'm creating a data frame
and in this way
we can now have
rows of data frames
like in matrix so this is also one way
of creating a data frame to look into
the data frame structure we can always
use str and then we can pass our data
frame and this basically prints out
similar to that of list
so
we also need to know that under the hood
data frame is a list and in this case
this is a list with three elements
so each list element is a vector of
length phi corresponding to the number
of observations
if we create data frame with vectors not
of same length we would get an error
now here when we look at our data frame
we know that name is a column so name
column which is character
is actually a factor instead of
character
to suppress this behavior we can always
use a property that is strings as
factors equals false so what i can do is
i can do a data frame
like this
use my data dot frame function
and then basically we can pass in our
vectors that is name
age
and children
and then what i can do is i can say
strings
as factors and set this value to false
so if i do this and now if i look at my
data frame structure
sorry
here
now let's look at this one and this one
shows me that
unlike your earlier one now we are
creating a data frame where our name
would be containing characters
there also by default it was showing as
character usually if you because this
value by default is set to false
or it would have created characters or
factors as we say now how do we do a
subset and extend and sort data frames
in r
so as we have learned so far in brief
about your data frames
so
data frame is somewhere like an
intersection between matrices and lists
so if you would want to subset a data
frame we can always use the square
brackets and in that we can use the
single square brackets which are
from matrices or we can use
double square brackets
from list or we can also use the dollar
symbol
so that all these things can be used to
subset the data frame so let's use our
data frame which contains information
about people
so we can select single element from our
data frame
so here
what we can do is
we can just say df and then i can use a
single bracket and i can just do a three
comma two
so it would be good if we can first
print the data frame and that's my value
and now let's do a single bracket and
let's look at this one so this tells me
that we are
using the row index first which is
number three
which shows me that we would be going to
the row number three and then we point
or pass in our column index that is
number two
so we could have done it in a different
way also so we could have done df
and then give a row index and then give
the column name which you are interested
in looking at and that also gives me the
value so just like matrices we can
choose to omit one of two indices to end
up with entire row or entire column and
for example if we would be interested in
looking for information for patrick what
i could have done is i could have just
add
df3 comma and this is showing me the
entire row
now always remember whatever results we
see here that is
giving me a data frame with a single
observation because there has to be a
way to store different data types and
that's why the result
is also a data frame
what we can also do is to get entire age
column
we can just use our data frame
and then
we can pass in the column name here
like this and that gives me
just the column now here
the point to notice is result is a
vector because columns contain elements
of the same type
in previous example we were seeing a row
and in that row was
not a vector it was a data frame because
values were of different data types now
subsetting a data frame that results in
a data frame
and contains multiple observations can
also be done by doing something like
this for example i will do df
and then i will say
let me get
3 comma five
and
then i can just say
age and children for example
so let's say age
and
children
and i can be pulling out the values in
this way
so i could also be
just getting
the results in the age column if i'm
interested in by just saying df
and here i can just pass in the column
number and that also gives me the h
column
now we know data frame is a list
containing vectors of same length
this means we can use list syntax to
select elements also and
what we can do is we can use our dollar
symbol and then choose the column name
and this is also one way wherein you can
pull out the values or you can use
double brackets as i mentioned earlier
and pass in the column name
so that's also fine
or you can give a column number
and that also would work and in all
these cases the result is a vector
now with single brackets you can still
do it always remember if you use single
brackets then that will result in a data
frame
the result
can be a data frame here
but
what we are seeing here is
a list
which contains only age column having
the data elements
so these are different ways in which you
can do a subsetting of a data frame now
using single brackets or double brackets
can have serious consequences so we need
to always think about what we are
dealing with and how are we handling it
now what we can also do is we can extend
our data frames that is we can add
variables we can add
columns that is adding variables or we
can add rows which are nothing but
observations
so adding columns is like adding new
elements to the list and for which we
can obviously use dollar or double
brackets say for example now this is my
data frame and if we would want to add
height whose information is in a vector
so let's say height
let's create a vector here and this one
is what i would want to add for each
person so let me do this
and let me pass in some values here
and
the last one
something like this so this is a vector
created now what i can do is
so we are data frame is called df so we
can say df dollar
height
and then i will pass in this vector here
and now if i look at my data frame you
see
the fourth column has been added and
that's my height column
now what i can do is
i could have done it in a different way
basically
if i had my data frame i could have just
done df double brackets and then give it
a name
and then
i could have passed my vector in this
way however so this is also one way of
doing it we have already added the
column so we don't need to repeat the
step now what we can also do is we can
use
a
c bind function and if you remember c
bind that is for column binding so for
example let's create a weight vector now
and let's pass in some values here so
for example let's say 75
65 54 34
and these are my values of weight now
what i can do is i can just do a c bind
and then pass in my data frame
and then pass in this vector
and in this way i'm just adding columns
or i'm extending my data frames by
adding more columns to it now obviously
if we can use c bind then we can also
use r bind to add new rows
so
for r bind creating a new vector won't
work
because we need to create a new data
frame with one single observation
remember row will have values of
different data types so we cannot create
a vector we have to create a new data
frame and then we can add it using our
bind
so let me create a data frame here for
example let's call data frame in storm
and let's pass in some values here so i
will say data dot frame function
and then let's give name
what we can do is we can give age
then we can give the logical value
then we can give say height
and since we have added weight let's
also add weight
and this is my data frame now we can use
our bind function so i can say r bind
and then i can pass in my data frame and
this new data frame which we have
created
and
this tells me
that
the number of columns of arguments do
not match so we will have to check this
one
so we
have
our data frame which has just height so
it does not have the weight that was
only as the result of c bind so let's
create the storm again without weight
and now let's do a r bind
and let's again check what is the reason
here
so this is height
and let me just check this
so to look at this
this is the error we were getting
because i was creating a data frame with
four columns
and then i was trying to add that to a
data frame which had three columns now
yes we had done a c bind and c bind was
showing us the fourth or fifth column
but the original data frame only had
three columns
so what i did here was i did tom
and then basically
i
created a data frame with three columns
which matches with my original data
frame
which had three columns and then i could
use r bind to basically add one more row
so what we did was we used r bind and r
bind was used to add a new row to our
data frame
now when it comes to sorting or ordering
your data frame say for example we want
to sort data frame by h
now how do we do that so we could easily
do sort
df
and then select
our column and we could just do a
sorting now if we do this it is good but
not really what we need
now other clear way of doing that would
be using ranks so for example if i do a
ranks and instead of doing a sort i
would use order
and then basically pass in my column so
i would say df
and then i would use h
now in this case if i look at ranks it
shows me
a vector of ranks with rank position of
each element now if i do a df dollar age
it shows me
the values and if you look at the ranks
it will tell
21 or here the lowest value
is your 28
and that's the lowest value and that's
why we see as rank as one and so on we
can look at the ranks so what we can
also do is we can just do a df
and then basically use ranks and we can
just look at the result so this shows
data frame which is a ordered data frame
now based on ranks now if we would want
to do it in a descending order what we
could also do is we could do a df
and then use order
and within order i will basically pass
my data frame i will choose my column
and then i could say decreasing
equals true
and i could do this
and here this could show me the value so
it says undefined column names so what i
would have to check is what is my data
frame here so we have h
and then what we would have to do is we
would have to select
a particular column so let's do that
and here i have just selected the column
and then there is a comma missing that
was showing an error so now we can have
the data
ordered in a descending wave so there
are dozens of packages such as d plier
data table which can help you
manipulate filter merge and sort your
data frames so this is in brief about
the data frames
working with data frames subsetting them
and also sorting the data in your data
frames
now one more important
type of object in your r is vector and
that really helps us in
various ways so let's see how we work on
vectors here so to create a vector we
can use the c function and pass in the
values those will be the objects or
elements within the vector
and then you can look at the value of
the vector or also at the class of it
which tells me the values are numeric
now in case of vector all the values
have to be of the same type
or belong to the same class we can say
so here we are creating a vector looking
at the value of it and then looking at
the class which says the values passed
in here our character
similarly we can do it for numerics
that is true false and then look at the
value of this and this class is logical
now what we can also do is we can print
all the three vectors at once and here
we will use semicolon to separate two or
more variables and we can pull out the
values of all the vectors with c we see
here
now what happens if
we pass in the values which belong to
different classes or you can say
different data types so within a vector
if you do that there is something called
as coercion which takes place which will
convert all the values into one type and
in this case it has converted everything
into character
similarly
we can pass in values wherein we can
pass logical and numeric and in this
case it's not going to go for character
it is going to convert everything into
numeric
now if i had done this where i passed a
character and numeric and if you look at
this then it has converted everything
into character so character always takes
a precedence if it is one of the values
of vector
and you have other values which are not
characters then in that case coercion
will happen there is one more way of
creating a vector and that is by
providing a range to your c function so
we can do that here
wherein i said c
1 colon 20 and then basically look at
the value of vector 7 so it shows me all
the values starting from 1 till 20
however there is one more way you can
use the sequence function to do the same
thing
now
i could avoid the bracket i could avoid
the c function and i can straight away
pass a range and that is also fine to
create our vector starting from 1 ending
at 25
so what if i want to create a vector
with odd values between
1 to 20. now in this case
i am going to say how many values to
skip or to jump so i am creating a
variable called odd value i am using
sequence function
and then to that i'm passing the
beginning number the ending number and
then the skip or the jump
and now if you look at the values it
shows me only the odd values
well we could have done the same thing
to get even values and that's not very
complicated so you can start from 2
and then you can do skip wherein
after 2 it basically gives you
every second value so we are looking at
the even values and this is how you can
create a vector which is having odd or
even values
now what if you want to create a vector
with 10 odd values starting from 10 so
you are basically giving a length so
here you can say from where you would
want to start what is your skip and then
the length of the vector which tells me
it gives me 10
odd values
beginning from 20
or from 20 onwards that is we take it
from 21. now one of the
requirements is always to name the
values so that we can access the values
either by indexing or by their name
which have been passed to the value so
let's see that so let's create a vector
which is called temperature so variable
is temperature pass in the values to
this
look at the values of temperature now
what we would want to do is we would
want to assign these names to each value
which makes it more readable more
accessible
so i can use the names function
pass in my temperature as a vector to
names function and then assign the names
to
each value of temperature now if you
look at temperature it shows me the
names which have been assigned well we
could have done it in a different way we
could have created a vector of names
something like this
and then what i could have done is i
could have created one more vector such
as temperature and instead of assigning
values we could have assigned the vector
to our
existing
vector so if you do this so you are
assigning the names vector
to the temperature one and now look at
the values it still does the same thing
so this is where you are assigning names
to every value
of
your existing vector
now there is one more way and that is
using your sequence so here i am
creating a sequence which starts with
100 and set to 2020 with a skip of
20 values
or every jump would be 20 values so
let's do that
use your names function on price and
then what i'm going to do is i'm going
to use my paste 0 option
which takes p
and then
1 to 7 as the value so we know base 0
basically skips the space and we are
going to assign those values to
as names to price
and now let's look at our price so that
basically gives me the names as we
desire so these are some smarter ways of
assigning names to
every element or every object within
your vector
now how do we perform some basic
operations let's have a look
so let's create a vector passing in the
values
and then you can simply do
an addition on two vectors where each
element is getting added to other
element of the vector
you can
subtract two vectors that is element to
element subtraction element to element
multiplication or division
and you can basically perform operations
on the vectors now how do we use some
inbuilt basic math functions and that's
pretty easy
this is my vector now let's do a sum
which sums up all the elements
let's find out a standard deviation for
all the values let's find out the
variance for all the values here
let's do a product of vector values find
the maximum or find the minimum value so
these are some basic inbuilt math
functions which sometimes are useful in
our data science or data analysis kind
of activities
now one more requirement might be
comparing the vectors
using comparison operators
and this is where i create a vector 1
create a vector 2 and let's find out the
values in v1 which are smaller than v2
values and that gives me the logicals as
the response that is false true and
false similarly you can do v1 greater
than v2
or you can say where v1 values are not
equal to v2
or equal to v2 so these are some simple
comparison examples now i can create a
different vector and then i can find out
individually if the elements in the
vector are lesser than 3 by just doing a
v
lesser than 3 so it compares each
element with this so you are actually
using one scalar value to compare it
with all the elements and you can do
that it gives you the logicals so
you can
also
be doing slicing and indexing on vectors
and this is very much important when
you're storing your data in vectors how
do you access them so let's create a
vector
using sequence
let's give it some names as we have seen
in past
and let's look at our price one so that
tells me the name and the values now
you can access the elements using
indexing so let's get the third element
and it shows me 590. remember the
indexing here starts with one unlike
other programming languages like python
where indexing starts with zero now i
can also get the third and fourth value
by doing a three colon four i can also
specify the vector
and say one comma four and that shows me
the first and the fourth position or
second or sixth position so this is one
way where you are using indexing to
access the elements
similarly i can give the names now
that's where we see the benefit of
giving names to every element so i can
use c
function pass in the name and look at
the value
for that particular name or selectively
select different columns or different
names or we can also use this square
brackets
wherein we pass the names
so sometimes it can also be useful to
use logical positioning that is we would
want to
find out the logical position if the
value exists and we can do that
or using true and false and then look at
the values
so
there is one
useful
way where you can exclude a particular
position might be that is an n a value
might be a value which you are not
interested in and that's where you will
say minus 2
which will skip the p2 value or minus 2n
minus 5
where we are skipping a p 2 and p phi
and we can exclude particular values
from our vector
now how do we do a comparison operator
on the values of vector so you can just
say price 1 and i would want all the
values which are greater than 600
or you can assign this to a filter and
then basically
pass in the filter for your
vector
so these are some simple basic
operations which you can run
using your r programming where you would
want to manipulate where you would want
to store some data and extract that data
use your different logical operators or
other operators and perform your basic
easy computations
now that we have seen some basic
operations using r let's look at some
more
operations when you're working with
vectors such as one of the common issues
is handling the missing values now here
we are
assigning a vector to a
variable order detail
and this one has a missing value now
let's see how this is handled and you
see all the values in the vector are
assigned what you can also do is you can
assign names
as we have seen earlier by using the
names function
and then look at the value of order
detail so you see the names and these
are your missing values which are also
taken care now what we can also do is we
can perform an operation on a particular
vector which will be applied to all
values of the vector so for example here
i will just add a scalar value plus 5 to
the elements in the vector and that
shows me number 5 has been added to each
element or each object in the vector
now if you would want to work on two
vectors for example to add two vectors
let's create a vector called new order
and then
let's add it to order detail now in this
case what we are doing is we have a
vector which is from 5 to 10
and what we are doing is we are adding
values to order detail now our order
detail earlier was 10 20 30 na 50 and 60
and what i have done is i have passed in
a vector which is 5 and 10 and you are
adding it to the elements so 5 gets
added to 10
and then your value 10 gets added to 20
and then you have again 5 which is added
to 30 now you cannot add in anything to
a missing value so that remains as it is
then you add again 5 to 50 and then 10
is added to 60. so in this way you are
adding two vectors which are not of same
length but you are adding these values
now what i can also do is
i can update the order
by doing this
so i am creating an update order
and now let's look at the value of
update order what does it show
so you are basically doing the same
thing
so
if you would want to work on a subset of
vector how do you do that so here you
are using some indexes so i am saying
order detail
and this is my order detail so let's
take one colon two and assign it to
first two so if we look at the value
which is assigned to first two we have
just sliced and added a subset of vector
to this one and if i would want to take
the length of order detail it shows me
the length here which is six elements
here
including the missing value also
what we can also do is
we can do some more operations so for
example
from order detail what i am doing is i
am saying length minus 1
and then
up to the length so let's do this and
let's see the result of this so what we
have done is
we had our order detail which had
these values
and what we have done is we have said
length minus 1
colon length so you have taken these two
elements and you have assigned that to
your v1
similarly we can do length minus 1 and
two elements so i can do this and now
let's look at the value of v2 so this
shows me
the value where you are taking length
minus 1 and then you are taking it till
the second position of the index element
which is 20 so you are getting in the
values here so you get
your
na 30 and 20 because you started with
length minus 2 and up till the second
index position similarly we can use the
length and we can take it from
this element and let's look at the value
of v3 so that shows me that i am i'm
doing some slicing or i'm getting subset
of my vector so similarly you can also
do this one so v4
and let's do this and then let's look at
the value of v4
so it gives me the values based on our
subsetting or slicing now you can
extract all the values below 30 and this
is where you are doing a comparison so
you will take your vector and then
you would want to compare each value if
it is less than 30 and you would want to
take all the values here so it gives me
the logicals or the response for all the
values which are lesser than 30
what we can do is we can also
use the square brackets and do this this
will show me the actual values here we
were just getting the logicals but here
we are getting the values
now to omit any value from the vector we
can use na.omit
and this one will help me
in getting rid of the n a values plus
i'm also checking the values if they are
less than 30 and then
i am basically doing
using this n a dot omit
so you can do something like this you
can look at the values what you can also
do is you can find the order details
that are multiples of three and here we
would want to use modulus and we would
want to find out if the remainder is 0
then i am getting the numbers which are
divisible or multiples of 3 so let's do
this
and it gives me again the logical values
of all the values which are divisible by
3 giving us a remainder of 0
or if you would want to look at the
values then you can say order detail
open up a square bracket and then pass
in
your condition
now we can then omit
n a from this one and then we can look
at the values
so this is simple way where you are
subsetting a vector or extracting the
values which you are interested in which
might be one of the requirements of your
data wrangling or data manipulation or
just data extraction
now i can also use a sum function
now
if we do this it returns n a because
there is already a missing value and you
cannot do a sum on the values
now what i can do is i can do a n a dot
r m
to remove the n a values
so i can do a sum on order detail where
i intend to add up all the values but
what i also want to do is i want to
remove the n a value so i'm giving it a
value as true and then if i do it it
gives me the sum of all the values so
similarly you can do a mean you can do a
maximum you can find out the minimum
value standard deviation or even square
root now these are some simple
operations what we are doing on vector
where we are interested in extracting
some specific values now let's look at
matrix which we have also discussed and
matrix is also one way where you can use
the matrix function to create a matrix
which is multi-dimensional so for
example if i do this and if i look at
the value of v
i get a matrix which starts with the
value of 20 ends with 30 and at any
point of time you can convert this to
matrix so first we created a vector and
now i'll create a matrix out of it
wherein i am seeing the row numbers i am
seeing the column number and i am seeing
the values in that particular column
so
you have already done that now let's
take it to the next level so let's
create a matrix wherein we are using the
matrix function we will say 0 comma 3
comma 3 and now let's look what it has
done so you have created a matrix which
is of
three columns and three rows and by
default the row number and column
numbers have been assigned to them we
can also create a matrix by passing in
values so we can say 1 colon 9 and then
give the dimensions that is number of
columns is three number of rows is three
and if i look at the matrix now i have
passed in the values to my matrix
sometimes you may want to arrange the
data in a matrix for particular kind of
calculations
you can also use n row and
by row
so
you can say how many number of rows you
would want
and you would want to assign the data
row wise so when we are doing this now
if you notice the difference between the
previous one where we just gave the
values and we said three rows and three
columns so it was doing it column wise
so one two three four five six seven
eight nine but here we said by row is
true so it has arranged the values in a
row wise fashion so it goes one two
three four five six and seven eight nine
similarly i could have just done this by
giving
the dimension and selecting by row and
if i do this it is still doing the same
thing
now what we can also do is we can create
matrix using vectors
so here let's create a vector stock1
and then stock2 now
we would want to merge both the vectors
so you can always do a c function and
then create a new vector that is stocks
which is a merged result of stock one
and stock two and let's look at the
result so that's my stocks that's a
vector and now what i would want to do
is i would want to create a matrix
using the stocks so i'm giving it a name
that is stock.matrix i'm using the
matrix function wherein i will pass my
vector i will say by row so i want the
values to be arranged row wise and i'm
also selecting the number of rows
so if you look at this one so the values
which we had in our stock
which was all the values have now been
arranged row wise and in two rows so it
starts with 450 51 52 45 and 68 that's
my first row and the rest five values
are arranged in the second row so one of
the main requirements is instead of
going for default
column names and default row names
we can give specific names to our
columns and rows to make more sense to
the data how do we do that so we can
basically say days
so this is a vector which we are
creating
and then what we want to do is we want
to create a new variable which is stock
1 and stock 2.
now this is for my columns and this will
be for my rows now how do we assign that
so we can say column names and this is
where i will say on my stock dot matrix
i will assign days which has five values
and that will become my column names and
similarly using row names function
i can basically assign row names to my
matrix so if i look at my matrix now it
shows me the column names and row names
which we have assigned or which we have
passed
to our matrix
now there are different functions which
are associated with the matrix and let's
look at some examples so these are some
simple basic examples now if i say
let me find out the number of rows and
that gives me the number of rows or
number of columns or get a dimension
that is the number of rows and columns
of your matrix
now
we might be just interested in getting
their own names or column names or even
the dimension names which basically will
give me
returns the row and column names
so in this way you can use these symbol
functions which are associated with
matrix to extract information about your
matrix or data which has been
transformed into matrix to pull out some
information about that
one of the requirements
which data scientist or data analyst
might face is
carrying out
arithmetic operations on your matrix now
what we can do is we can create a matrix
which takes values 1 to 50 we want to
arrange it by rows and we will say
number of rows is five so that's my
values starting from one
now i can do a addition
here by just doing a five plus mat one
and if you notice number 5 as a scalar
value has been added to
every element of the matrix
similarly you can do a multiplication
you can do a division
you can basically return the quotient if
you would want to do that or go for
exponential values
so you can perform simple arithmetic
operations for every element of the
matrix
and what if if you want to have
arithmetic operations done on multiple
matrix so let's create
mat 1 plus mat 1
and we get a total where every element
is added to every element
you can do a subtraction
you can do a multiplication and you can
get the value so this might be also very
useful when you are working on
multi-dimensional data
you can also
do some more operations on matrix such
as
returns the sum for each column
say you are doing a summation or at a
row level or you want to do a mean for
every row you can do that by using these
simple functions
now
you can add rows and columns to a matrix
using r bind and c bind functions
so r bind is for row bind and c bind is
for column bind but for that we have to
first create a vector so
let me create a vector of same length
which will then be added to
every or added as a row to my existing
matrix now my matrix has five
columns so let's create a vector with
five elements
and then
i can basically add this as a row to my
existing matrix
by doing this and now if i look at my
values i will see the new values at this
as the third row
and if you also see
the variable name becomes the row name
and we have added a row to our matrix
now similarly
i can find out row means that is we have
seen earlier by calculating the mean or
average so i can do that
and i can find out the value of average
now what i can do is i have got the
average for every column and
what we can do is we can basically
do a column bind
by using a c bind function
and i will say
i am going to take the total stock which
has three rows
and then get the average
and now let's look at the total stock
which shows me the average value which
is the new column which has been added
to the matrix so these are some simple
very simple operations which you can do
but that gives you good insight in what
can be done at a matrix level where your
data is arranged in multi dimensions
now how do we do a selection and
indexing in matrix so in vectors we were
using either names or we were using
positions or we were using indexing now
here let's create a matrix called
student
and we are using the matrix function but
within the matrix function we are using
the c function to create a vector
which will pass in all the values which
also has n a values if you closely
notice
we will split these values into number
of rows is 4 so that means the values
the number of
values in this vector should be a
multiple of four i'm saying columns is
four and i would want to arrange this
data row wise so i've done that and if
you would want to get the dimensions out
of this so i can do a dim names
so
what i'm doing here is
on my student
i'm assigning a list
which will basically have these names
which are basically assigned and now if
you look at your student it basically
shows me
the values which were first
applied to the row names that is john
matthew sam and alice
and then you have one more vector which
goes as the column names for the values
so you have not only created a matrix
by using a vector by defining your
dimensions that is number of rows and
columns
you have arranged the data in a row
order and what you have also done is
using a list function you have passed in
the values which will be applied as row
names and column names to your matrix
now how do we extract particular columns
here so we can take our matrix and we
can just say comma 1 and that basically
gives me the values for
john matthew sam and alice
and what we are looking at is the first
column
now i can also say from first column
onwards i would want to look at how many
columns so i can do this and now here
i'm selecting first and second column i
can also be
using a vector function here and that
also does the same thing where i'm
saying one comma three and i'm getting
the values from first
and second column so third is not
included here now if you would want to
do row wise then you have to give the
row position first so if i do a student
1 that gives me the row values
and this is giving me values for
my student which we are seeing here
so for john we have 20 30 na and 70 and
that's what we get here when you do a
row wise operation you can also do a row
wise and how many rows do you want
you can use the vector function to do
that
you can also select or slice out a value
where you are getting an intersection of
row 2 and column 2 and then you can also
start from a particular position and
then onwards get your rows
so these are different ways in which you
are slicing the values from your matrix
by
columns or by rows so
at this point of time let me just type
in student here and let's look at the
value of student
and then here we are interested in three
column four
and then two column three so what does
that give me so you are looking at
third to fourth row so you're looking at
sam and alice
and then
you are looking at columns two and three
so that basically gives you your
26 32 24 and a
so first is you're giving your row
positions or how many rows you want and
then you're giving your column so
similarly you can do this you can say
from row number two to four and then
column wise you can say one two three
so if we do this so this tells me two
columns which is first and second
and it shows me rows which is
from second to
fourth so in this way we can extract
data based on rows and columns now
if we would be interested in finding out
a specific value so for example if i
again bring up student
this is my student and what i would be
interested in is getting the value of
john
and for specific subjects so might be we
are looking for
2 colon 3 now if i do this
it shows me for john and what we are
interested in
is two colon three so that gives me the
value for chemistry and biology so you
are giving the columns so row wise you
have already specified the name and that
basically selects the particular row i
could have given
a number and chosen which row or which
rows we would want to pull out the
values now if i would want to find out
the value for john and sam
now in that case i could use indexing or
positioning but that has to be
continuous but here you are talking
about john and sam which has matthew in
between so we will basically create
we will get the values for john and sam
and then we will look at the value 4
now
that is basically giving me the values
in the fourth column which is 70 and 75.
similarly
if you go further you can look at maths
and bioscore of sam and alice so you
will give your
row names that is sam and alice and then
you would want the values for maths and
bio so that is basically your
third and fourth column and we can do
that by looking at the values
how do you find out an average
well
that's pretty simple you can use the
mean function
on student
you
will select your row name that is john
you also want to get rid of n a values
otherwise that will give a problem so
you get rid of that by saying n a dot r
m
equals true and then you
get the average score of john now
how do i do further computation that is
if i want to find out the average and
total score of all students so in this
case
i can apply or i can use an apply
function
here i'm saying i'm working on student
and
we would want to give the row number
that is 1
and we want to also give the columns so
i want to find out mean
i want to remove or get rid of the n a
values
and now if i
look at help apply it tells me how does
the apply function works over the array
margins so i will do an apply function
on student
where i would want to select the first
row
i would say i want the sum
and i want to get rid of the na values
so this gives me the sum for each
student
and here we are getting a mean value
which was for
each student
so what we are doing here is for example
let's look at student again just so that
we avoid confusion so we have
student
and then we have physics chemistry bio
maths
and i have said
row one so basically what we want is
for john we want
the total
and what we can do here is
we can say 20
plus 30
avoiding n a and then 70 that gives me
120 then you look at matthew so this is
again doing a totaling there is no n a
value and you look at the value right so
when we have chosen apply function we
have worked on student
now here
we are interested in the values that is
sum of all the values for this
particular row
i am saying take care of any and then
give me a sum similarly you did a mean
and that was giving you a mean for each
student so these are some simple
operations now what we can also do is
we can
basically create a vector called passing
score
and what we would want to do is we want
to get the values or find in how many
subjects alice has passed how do we do
that we will have to compare
alice score
which should be greater than
or equal to the passing score so what we
can do is we can create a variable here
pass now i'm saying student i would be
interested in the values for alice so
i've mentioned that row name here i'm
then comparing it with passing score
which we have created here and that will
give me the values wherever
alice has passed in a particular subject
now i can obviously get rid of the n a
values and then look at this which
basically tells me
there was
one subject in which alice passed and
rest were either false or any
now same thing we can do for sam
so sam is here
and what we want to do is we want to
look at the values here so we will say
let's do the same thing for sam and find
out the comparison with passing score
and get rid of n a values so you are
basically extracting values so these are
some
easier operations and usage of functions
on your matrices
which are filled in with values at row
level and column level and then you can
apply one of these functions
or
multiple functions to basically extract
value which makes more meaning
so that's with your matrix now let's
also look at data frames now data frames
as we know is basically data which has
been ordered in rows and columns
wherein we can assign row names we can
assign column names we can do some
operations on data frames so let's look
at example so if i do a data
here so that gets me
some sample data sets or functions what
we have here
so let's do
once we have our data here
so it says use data package and then you
can get
list all the data sets in available
packages and you can basically look at
all the our data sets which we are
seeing here it has opened up so i would
be interested in getting the air
passengers data so i'm going to pass
that in the data function
and then if i do a head to see the
initial data from air passengers it
shows me the values what we have
similarly we can do that on iris data
set and look at the head values
i can
do a view to look at specific values in
a tabular format if that makes more
meaning and that makes it easy for
analysis
now
i can
do a view on state
x77 and that basically shows me
the population income and all this for
different u.s states so these are some
different data sets what we have
you can do a view on them
to basically understand the data or look
in a more readable format you can just
do a tail to get some end data so head
and tail functions just give you the top
six entries
or basically your entries from that
particular data set now the question is
how do we
work on this data so i can get a
statistical summary so i have the iris
data set which we had here
so if i do a head it shows me iris data
set this is a popular data set which
shows the petal lens sepal length of
particular flowers and the species what
is the length what is the width and what
species does that flower belongs to okay
now here we can get a summary that is
statistical summary of a data set which
gives me mean
first quartile median mean third
quartile and maximum values
it basically shows you the count of
the entries for each species what we
have under the species column now what i
can do is i can check the structure of
this data set using str
i can create a data frame now of this
data
using the data dot frame function so for
that we need to also have say for
example
if we would want to create a data frame
let's see how do we do that so first we
create a vector of days
we can create a vector of temperatures
and rain
and then we want to create a data frame
out of this so i use the data dot frame
option i pass in my days temp and rain
as the vectors
and now if you look at the data frame
you basically see
that i have my days my temp and rain so
those were the variables those were the
vector names and those have become the
column names row names are auto assigned
and basically we are seeing the values
which have been passed in my data frame
now i can do a summary on this to
basically look at what is the length or
how many values we have in data frame
what is the class of elements so that is
character
you are looking at
your
values or summary which gives you mean
first quartile median mean and so on and
then it also shows you the complete data
on rain
what is the mode here
what how many falls or how many true
values we have you can also look at the
structure of this data frame by doing a
sdr
which gives me
how many objects we have how many
variables we have
what are the different variables so that
is days temperature and rain and the
values for those
for days if you notice it is of the type
character temperature is numeric rain is
logical now how do we do data frame
indexing so like your matrix which
basically has rows and columns and in
multi-dimensions similarly in data
frames also you have indexing so you can
do a data frame so i could just extract
the first row by doing this and that
basically gives me the value so you can
always compare it by just typing df so
that's my data frame
and now let's look at the values extract
the first row and that shows me monday
25.6
rain value is true
now i can also do it column wise so
for example i could do it in this way so
here what i'm doing is i'm doing
extracting the second row from this one
so it tells me
25.6
30.1
40.0 37.3 so you have extracted the
values for the column right so i would
not say extract the second row you would
say extract the second column
okay so this one should be second column
yeah
now
selecting using column names so that's
the easiest way to extract the values
for a particular column so i can just do
this instead of giving the position of
the column or the column number i'll
give the column name and that gives me
all the values of temperature
and
if i do this where i'm saying 2 colon 4
and then i'm giving the columns so it
gets me the second
third and fourth rows for day and
temperature
and we are looking at the values so you
have given your row names and then you
have selected your columns you can also
do a dollar sign if you would want all
the values of a particular column so i
can just do a df dollar days or df
dollar rain and it shows me
the values from my data frame now one
more way of doing that is using your
bracket notation to return a data frame
format of same information so if you
want the resultant data in a data frame
format
you can just do a df rain or df
temperature and that is basically giving
a data frame so if i had assigned this
to a value and if i had look at the type
of this that would be data frame
now
one of the things which we also require
is filtering data frames using a subset
function
so that is subsetting the information
from a data frame so we know we have our
data frame let's look at our data frame
again
so that just reminds of what data values
we have and here let's get a subset out
of it using the subset function so i'm
passing in my data frame i am saying i
would be interested in the rain column
so i am giving subset rain column and
wherever the values are true so returns
all the columns where it has
rained
similarly i can
do a subsetting by giving a value for
temperature wherever the value is
greater than 25 and that shows me the
value so this is where you are filtering
the data in data frames using a
subset function to which you have to
provide a column name
and then giving a condition now
one more important thing which might be
required is sorting your data frame
using order function so
i can create a variable by name sorted
dot tem
i want to do a ordering of data frame
and here i'm doing a ordering based on
temp
and now if i look at the value
or i can create this
in an ascending order
so let's look at the values and now if i
look at my data frame it just gives me
the
order or the ranking for the particular
values
so we have discussed this in other
section also so what i can do is i can
return all the columns with temperature
sorted in a descending order so right
now what we were seeing was we were
seeing in an ascending order but what we
can do is we can do that in a descending
order so here am creating a variable
descending.temp i am doing a ordering
but when i am doing a ordering i am
using the minus symbol
and this one
if you would look at in the form of a
data frame it shows me the values which
are ordered
in a descending order based on the
temperature column
now another way of sorting is by using a
particular column
so what i can do is i can sort i can do
a order and then i can choose the column
based on which i would want to order it
and then
if you would want to get the values of
this so it tells me
the values have been ordered based on
temp
so this can be very useful when you
would want to sort the data or order it
in a particular way to basically
understand your data or to make more
meaning out of it right
similarly one more requirement might be
merging your data frames so here i'm
creating a data frame so i'm saying
authors and i'm using data.frame
function and what we are doing is
instead of creating three vectors i am
basically doing that within my data
frame function so let's do that
and now
what we can do is at this point of time
i can check what my authors look like so
this is my authors
now here if you see we have
the vector turkey venables tierney
ripley and mcneil so that becomes my
first column
which is surname
then you have your nationality and then
you have deceased
where you have also
repeated the values four times right so
that's something new which you might be
seeing so you are creating a vector
where you are passing in a value and for
other set of values you are basically
using a repetitive function now
similarly we can create a data frame
called books
and this one
is
where i am
having name column
title
and
then i have other dot author and you are
passing in the values so at this point
of time if you would want to look at
your books
it would look something like this so you
have given a name
now just closely look at the data frame
function so here you are using
the names
you have the titles whatever values you
are passed in
always remember when you have multiple
vectors they are ending with a comma
right so do not forget that and then you
have other dot author so that's the name
of the column and you are passing in the
values where you have also passed some n
a values
and at this point of time you can look
at authors
this is your books
and our intention will be to merge
these data frames so that's what we
would want to do
might be we are interested in getting
the data together so what i'm doing here
is i'm saying m1 now i want to use the
merge function i pass in my data frames
that is authors and books
so if we closely look at authors it has
three columns and five rows and here you
have three columns and we have seven
rows so we would want to do a merge so
we'll say authors books and we will say
by dot x so this is where i'm choosing
which is the column based on which
i would want to merge so i have y dot x
which is surname
and by dot y which is name
so we would want to merge the data where
we are giving a condition based on
values and surname and name so you see
there is turkey here there is turkey
here we have venables we have venables
we have tierney we have this one we have
ripley which we have here multiple
entries and then you have mcniel
now we don't have our core which is
there in
your author so let's see
what happens when we do emerging here
okay and now we see the result of this
merge where it has taken all the values
from
both the data frames so you have surname
nationality deceased you get the title
you get the other dot author which you
are getting in from your books
and the name column is avoided right
because we are
doing
the merging based on surname and but y
dot name is name so we don't see the
name column but what we are seeing here
is the values which have been merged and
then you can compare so for example
let's do a random check so if i look at
mcneil
that's the surname
or here it was name
so you have mcniel you have a
nationality which comes from the first
data frame deceased from the first data
frame then you have your interactive
data analysis
and then you look at title.author
what you don't look at in the merge is
this r core because this does not have
any value in your author's data frame so
you can do a merging of your data frames
using the merge function so please try
it out and you can create different data
frames and try to use this
similarly you can manipulate a data
frame so for example here we are
creating one more data frame called
sales report
which is data.frame you are giving an id
product has some values unit price
is where you are
getting the values as integer and
quantity as integer so now if i look at
my sales report this is the values which
i have let's spend a couple of seconds
to look at this value so id value is 1 0
2 1 0 10
product
is a b so that is automatically assigned
unit price
is starting
where you say 101
184 right so we are using a as dot
integer we are converting it into
integer and basically we are
assigning these values here
for your
unit price and similarly for quantity we
are assigning the values by doing a as
dot integer and then just doing a run if
now once we have done that we have
created a data frame now how do you
transpose what do you mean by transpose
so transpose is when you are changing
your accesses so if i do a transpose on
sales report
and if i want to do a view so you will
see
the positions which have changed so you
have all these values so my
row names or row whatever values become
the column headings
and basically your column headings
becomes your row names so that is what
you're achieving by doing a transpose
you can do a head to look at some
initial values
you can do a sorting of this data frame
by using the order function and you can
choose the column
and also the order if you would want to
have it in ascending or deciding or
basically increasing or decreasing
values
you can also choose a particular column
like we are choosing product as a column
and i would want to
take the values of sales report in a
descending order that is unit price and
we can just do ordering of data frames
or sorting the values and data frame so
this is pretty easy please spend some
time in practicing these things taking
these examples
and you will learn more about these
functions you can always try creating
an example at your end and you can try
to look into these
now
what about subsetting the data frame so
when you are saying subsetting the data
frame
let's do a subset function like what we
used earlier
i will say subset dot product a i'm
using the subset function and here i
will get the subset based on the product
value being a
let's look at this and this shows me
only the values where product value
matches a
now extract the rows
for which product is a and your price is
150 so you are still doing a subsetting
you are still passing your data frame
here you will give the product is a
which will tell basically the values for
product and unit price greater than 50
so you are giving some conditions and
look at the values
now if you are only interested in
particular columns so if i say
only the first and the fourth column
product is a
and unit price is 150 so you have to
still use your subset function
pass in your data frame
product will be given as a and unit
price should be greater than 150 but
what i am interested in is the values
from the first and the fourth column and
now if you see it shows me the values
for my fourth column
what we can also do is we can create two
subsets so set a from data frame where
we take the product as being a other one
is being b
and then we can look at the values so
this is just a this is just b and what
we can do is we can combine them or we
can merge them using column bind so when
i say column bind and i'm saying set a
set b so it is basically going to stack
the data frames column wise and if you
do r bind it is going to stack the data
frames row wise
so we can
either use
column or we can do a row wise
so this is in one way where you can
merge the previous example where we saw
merging was based on a particular
condition which is met
based on some columns which might have
similar values right and this is where
you are straight away merging the data
frame using columbine and c bind so if
you compare this
with the other merge operation what we
saw here this was where you are
comparing the values
of
first data frame
and second data frame and then merging
but here we have just used column mind
and row bind so we are not merging on a
particular condition we are just
stacking them either column wise or row
wise
now
what we can also look at is doing some
aggregate operations this is going
deeper into data frames so
when you use aggregate function you are
passing in your data frame you are
choosing the quantity column
and then you are basically
using the list function so list function
is going to work on your data frame
on the product column so product column
for your sales report so at this point
of time let's look at sales
report
and let's look at the value here so this
is my sales report
and what we want to do is we want to
aggregate the values
on quantity column
but for that i will say i will just take
the product columns
and i will get a sum
wherein i am ignoring the any values
let's look at this
and that gives me an aggregation value
so remember aggregate function
is doing a summing up
now here we are doing a summing up
on your
product
that is sales report product column is
what we have so you are kind of grouping
by based on product so we have two
products here a and b now what we also
want to do is we want to take the
quantity column so that's why we have
given that first
and what we are doing is we are doing a
summing up so we are summing up all the
values for a and all the values for b
and we are seeing that
here if there are any n a values we are
ignoring it so these are some basic
operations on data frames or matrices
subsetting them extracting useful
information
using some inbuilt functions to do
transformation or computation and
extracting some values
now similarly we can also work on lists
now that we have looked at data frames
matrices vectors let's also look at one
more structure and how we work
in r when we have to work on list
so list
is basically a structure here and what
we are doing is we are creating a list
by using the list function
and here
i am passing in three vectors you see
here
now c
function is being used now in vector we
know that all the elements are of the
same type now let's create a list
wherein we see three vectors which are
of three different
types or objects of three different
types so let's create this list
and now let's look at our list so it
basically has elements
wherein you have values of different
types
we can create a different
list which can also have
sequence elements that is one to ten a
matrix which is of three dimensions and
then also passing a list so this is also
one way of creating a list let's look at
list two and if we look at the values
here list two
basically has a vector which has values
1 to 10
it has a matrix of 3 into 3
it has a list which has values a
having 10 and b having 20.
so this is how you can create a list
which can have objects of different
types so we can also
use
recursive variable a variable that can
store value of its own type
so for that you have to use a recursive
function
something like this so i'm saying is
recursive and then do it on your list
and
we can check if the list basically has a
variable that can store values of its
own type now
one of the main requirements when you
are working with list
is
indexing so i have created a list and
here i can access this elements by using
a index so if i do this this shows me
the matrix what i could have also done
is using the dollar symbol and then
choosing
particular element of the list by doing
a mat which is the name given to our
matrix
or by choosing a name that is vector
so
you can access the elements using
indexing or dollar generation or giving
the name of a particular element now i
can also work on list and i can get the
third elements second value so we can do
that and that shows me 20 or you could
have done by giving the value 3
that is the third element and within
that you are looking for second element
so i can get the length of the list i
can get the class of the list which
shows me this type list
and
what i can also do is i can convert
vectors into list
so here we are creating a variable price
which is being assigned a vector which
has 10 20 and 30 and now what i want to
do is i would want to convert this
vector into list and for that i'm using
the list function so i am creating a
variable called price list
and then i am saying as dot list so
that's going to convert my vector into
list and now let's look at price list
which shows me
a list
or you can look at price which is a
vector
so that's when you are converting your
vector into list now how do you convert
your list into vector
and that also can be done by doing a
unlist function
so
i can basically work on price list
wherein we converted vector to list and
i can just do a unlist on that which
will convert my list into a vector
looking at the values of the vector
now sometimes we may want to get the
dimensions so we can use the dimension
function to convert the vectors to a
matrix so that it can have multiple
dimensions so here we create a vector
which has four values and then i am
going to give a dimension to this so
that it is converted from vector into
matrix by giving dimensions 2 comma 2
and now if you look at price 1 it has
basically changed into rows and columns
of 2 into 2 dimensions so these are some
simple examples of working with list now
when you talk about basic data type
functions
we have seen how you use the assignment
operator
how you get the data type of a
particular variable or the class to
which it belongs
i can assign different values
such as 10.5 so the previous one was
showing me the value numeric
and now
what we would want to do is we want to
assign a value 10.5 look at the class of
it it says numeric type of it shows
double so by default
it belongs to the double class now i can
check if
the values in n1 are numeric and that
shows me true and similarly for n2 and
that shows me 2. so you are using the
numeric function which returns true if
the given value is numeric
similarly we can
have
integer
assigned to a particular variable and
for that either i can do as dot integer
or i can assign a value with capital l
so i can do this and look at the value
of i1
similarly
i2 and look at the values and if i would
want to check if that is an integer
let's look at the values of
i2
which was an integer i1 which was an
integer ni 3
which is an integer so here we have
assigned integer values to a particular
variable now all integers are numeric
but all numerics are not integers so
let's check that so if i do a is numeric
on i 1 which was assigned as dot integer
10 that shows me true
if i say is dot integer on i1 so was
that an integer
and if i look at the value it shows me
true
now let's look at the character values
so if we say c1 c2 and look at the class
of this it shows me this of character
type
similarly on c2 and you can always
validate that by using the character
function
you can also use some inbuilt functions
such as converting to an upper case
or getting a substring from the starting
till the position what you would want
the elements
i can do a paste function
which basically will give me
the data
combined or you can say concatenated you
can also use a paste 0 which we know
will get rid of the space
and it just
concatenates them without a space i can
also use a specific separator which we
have seen examples and we can do that
and what we can also do is we can
replace set of characters
so here i am saying
substitute
and then if i look at the values it has
basically replaced rob with sena
and let's look at the length of it or
number of characters in this
so these are some basic operations what
you are doing on matrices on your data
frames on your list
and also on your variables where either
you are assigning them values of a
particular type or you are changing the
data types you can also go for coercion
in case of vectors we have seen that
where if you are passing in values of
different types that's coerced into
same types
so later we can learn more on functions
and flow control and how that is handled
in r
let's learn how r can be used to take
care of flow control that is if i would
want to have a if else condition
and if what i would want to compute or
if i would want to check some values how
r can be used
so here
if
statement consists of a boolean
expression which is followed by one or
more statements so we can just say if we
can pass in a boolean expression where
we would want to compare particular
value or we would want to check a
particular value and then whatever is
passed in the statement will get
executed so what we can do is here we
can use assignment operator i can pass a
value to x now we can always do a type
off
and that can tell me that x
is basically an integer and now i can
use my if where i can say
is
dot and then i can choose integer
and i would want to check the value of x
if that is an integer
then i will just use
brackets and i'll pass a statement here
so let me say print
and let's say x is
an integer
and we can execute this and this tells
me that the boolean value is true now if
for example we would have done something
else or
say for example
instead of integer if i had used let's
say character
for that matter
and we can check the value and we can do
this
so
here we will check the values and it
says
there is an error with the bracket and
let's check this one so if x because we
missed a bracket here
so let's do that one
and then try this and it doesn't show me
any result so how could we handle
something like this if
the boolean expression does not match to
true and in that case we can always go
for else statement so we can check for a
value so if the boolean expression is
true statement will be executed and if
it is false then next statement will be
executed so we could have done the same
thing here where i said print
x is an integer which we know is not
true
and what i could do is i can here after
this one
say else
and then i can open up one more bracket
and then i can say print
and i will say x
is not
a character
now we know that x is not a character so
this is a simple way where you can use
if else and you can control the flow
by passing in the conditions now that's
when you are using if else statements
now what about while loop so that also
can be useful when you are programming
in r
so
an else statement is executed when the
condition in the if statement results to
false so that basically means what we
can do here is
let's pass in a word or a set of words
like this for example let's say v
and then we use c function to create a
vector for example and then i can just
say hello
world
and
if you look at v
you can look at the class of v
it's of characters and if you look at
type
of v
it is having the objects or elements as
character now what we can do is we can
basically then say
count
and let's assign this a value to
now what we would want to check is is
the count of elements in
our v equals to two so what i can do is
while
my count
is less than
say five
now i'm saying
i would want to
do something while the count is less
than five
so we have already given a value to
count as 2
and now what i can do is here i can open
up a bracket
i can say print and then pass the value
of v and then what we do is not only
this we will also increment the value of
count and we will say count plus 1
and
here it gives me error probably because
we have missed a bracket so let's see
what we are missing out here
so
let's just check this one again
so here it is
we have created v
which has two elements
of the type character
and then what we do is we assign count a
value of 2 and we would want to check
while the count value is less than 5 we
would want to print the value of v so
what we are doing here is we are saying
while then you pass in an expression
which will check the value of count we
do a print and then we increment the
value of count now this is a simple
example where you are using while
to basically test an expression and
while that expression is true
you would be doing something whatever is
passed within your
brackets
now we could also be going for for loop
now for loop is basically used to
iterate over a list of elements or a
range of numbers
so for example if i have a vector like
fruit which has some values i could just
say for i in fruit i would want to print
something so let's try this also as an
example to test our for loop now we can
just say names
and we can basically
then assign values to this
so let's say
vj aj
dj
and let's say sj
and let's create this let's look at the
value of names now what i can do is i
can use a for loop and i can say for i
in my names so i will say for i in
names
now what do you want to do so open up
your brackets here
and then we would want to say print i
and then basically close the bracket so
you see for every element
in this vector it is basically going to
print the name one by one so you are
iterating through
a set of objects
by using a for loop now this is how we
can work on
for loop
so if else while and for loop can be
very useful when you would want to
iterate
or when you would want to check the
value of an expression or
when you would want to loop and do a
particular task
it's always good to
understand how you manage flow control
in r that is either when you're working
with your for loops your while loops
also understanding how you can use your
logical operators for working with your
data in are
so let's look at some examples and
understand
logical operations
so either you could be having and or you
could be doing here or where you are
evaluating one condition or you are
using not so these are your logical
operations now here i can assign a value
to x
and then i can check if my x value is
less than 10 and it shows me false
so
i have been
checking the value of x so let's see is
it greater than 10 and that's true now i
can use logical operations here so i can
say
and so i'm saying is my x value less
than 20
and is my x value greater than 10. now
both these conditions are not true so in
this case we get the result as false
but if i say x is greater than 20 which
is true
and
i am saying x is greater than 5 that's
also true and
x is equal to 25 now whenever we are
talking about and we have to look at all
the conditions have to
be right so let's look at this and we
get the value as true but if i say x is
greater than 10 or x is later than 5
then one of the condition has to be true
which is true in our case so we get the
result as true
we can take a different example we can
say is x less than 20 which is not true
but is x equals to 30 and that's also
not true so in this case we get result
as false
now we can straight away compare some
numbers and we can say is 12 equals 3
and that's false
and if i say not then that basically
will give me the result as true
so these are some simple logical
operations which help you when you are
working with your data in r
now we can create a data frame by using
an inbuilt data set empty cars
and let's look at our data frame so that
shows us the values with all the
different car models
and the different column names so car
models are the row names and then you
have other things like mileage and
cylinder and so on which are the
specification for the data now what i
can do is i can filter out values here
using indexing so i can say data frame
now in that data frame
i would want to compare the value of
mileage which is greater than or equal
to 30 and
then i can end it with comma so that
gives me the value wherever the mileage
is greater than 30.
i can also do a subset on data frame
where i can select a particular value
so
we can be doing this
or we can be using
square brackets we can also do a dollar
and compare the values now we will use
our logical operations knowledge here so
we will work on data frame where i'm
interested in the mileage which is
greater than 20 and
i am looking at
the column hp horsepower and that should
be greater than 100 remember when we are
doing a and both the conditions have to
be
met as true and that shows me the result
where you're looking at the mileage and
you're looking at the horsepower column
both of these are met and that's why we
get the result
so these are some simple examples of
using your logical operations either
when you're working on a data frame so
same thing can be done on a matrix same
thing can be done on a list or a vector
or individual values
now let's also learn about flow control
that is how if else or else if is
handled in r so you can do a single
condition check so for example i assign
a value to hot which is false
and i am saying temperature is 50 now
what i would want to check is if
the temperature value is greater than 60
which in our case will not be true
which will not be true because
temperature has been assigned 50 so is
it greater than 60 no so
if i do this
if condition
and i am saying if the condition is true
then i would want to assign the value of
hot to true
and now if you look at the value of hot
it is still false why because the
condition which we passed for our if
is not true
it has not been met
so whatever was passed within the
statement has not been done
now let's change the value of
temperature as 100 and now if we do the
same thing we say is my temperature
greater than 60 which is right so then
whatever has passed in the bracket will
be applied so hot will be assigned new
value and now if you see the hot value
is
set to true so this is a simple single
condition check what you are doing now
certain times there can be multiple
conditions to check and that's where we
use else
so in this case we go for
assigning a value to score which is 63
so let's do that
and now let's say is my score value
greater than 80 which is not true so
whatever is passed in here
which is print it's a good score will
not be done
but it will jump to else and then
whatever we have passed in else will be
done so it will say it's not a good
score so let's do this if and it says
it's not a good score so this is a
simple way of using if else where you
are checking two conditions or you are
checking the condition but what if the
condition is not met
then your control is passed to your next
statement
now i can also do a else if so i can say
score is 63 and i can say is my score
greater than 80 that's my first
condition so it would pretend good score
but might be i would want to check
something else so i'll say else if
and i'll say is my score greater than 60
yeah
and is it less than 80 remember the and
which has to
evaluate
and true for both the conditions so i'll
say print decent score
i can still keep on giving conditions
here in elsif is scored less than 60
and score is greater than 33 that would
not meet so that will be ignored
and then you have else which says print
poor so
first it checks or evaluates for the
condition which you have passed for if
if that doesn't work then it goes to
else if and if anything in else if is
met then it's going to take that
into consideration and it will not go
for else if if and else if conditions
are not met then it goes to else
and we see decent score already printed
here now that's a simple example of if
else
and if else if
wherein we are evaluating a condition
but probably we have multiple other
things to check now how do you work with
while loops in r that's very simple so
what we can do is we can assign a value
to x
and now i will say while
my x is less than 10. so i'm going to
create a loop so i have said my x has
been assigned a value of 0 and that's
fine so this is going to be less than 10
but
if we are going to just do this then
it will keep running and it will get
into an infinite loop so we'll see how
we do that so we'll say while x is less
than 10 i would want to
basically have the value of x i would
want to print x is still less than 10
adding 1 to x and what we are doing is
we are incrementing the value of x now
if you do not do this step
then it will get into an infinite loop
because x will be always less than 10
so we are incrementing the value of x by
and then we are giving a condition so if
at any point of time x is equals to 10 i
would want to say x is equal to 10
terminating the loop
and then basically my while loop ends so
we can do this so let's say x is 0 and
then do this while loop and now you see
it is at every step it is basically
printing out the value of x it is still
less than 10 adding 1 to x
and it also gives you
the value of x
so when we do a x is currently and i
print out the value of x so it shows me
next time you increment it it becomes 1
and 2 and so on so this is where you are
using a while loop where you are looping
where based on a particular condition
and then you basically have
once the condition is met you are able
to
complete the loop
now let's look at
let me take this one here we'll look
into functions in a later stage so let
me take this function
and let's get rid of this one i would
also want to talk on break statements
and while loop and once we are done with
the flow control and while loops
then we can look at the functions aspect
either we can look at how we control our
functions or how we create built-in
functions so let's look at this one
and let's continue with our while loop
so
we just saw a simple while loop here
and what we also want to see is when you
are working with your while loop
how do you break if a particular
condition is met
so we saw a simple example of
while loop
and that's fine
wherein we were printing out something
we were auto incrementing the value of x
we were also checking at one point of
time within our while loop
if the value of x was met
we would say we are terminating the loop
and it comes out of that
now if that does not happen then we
continue doing it
how about a break statement so break
statement is when you would want to end
the while loop
if a particular condition is met so for
example here i assign a value to x which
is 0 now i want to evaluate this lesser
than 5 so that means i will be auto
incrementing the value of x so i'll
create my while loop i'll given a
condition that x is less than 5 now what
i want to do is i want to use the cat
function which will print the value so
i'm saying x is currently
and i am
printing out the value of x
then i say print x is less than 5
because we have not yet incremented the
value of x we are adding 1 to x like
what we saw in previous example i am
saying x is
then
incremented by 1
and here i am saying if x reaches 5 so
while we keep incrementing the values
within the file loop we'll see if x's
value is 5 we will print it is equal to
5 and we can just do a break
now
if you do not use a break
you can still end the while loop but
break is basically 2 end this loop here
based on condition which is met and we
can do this and then run this while loop
so you see here x was met as 5 and we
just broke out of the loop
so that's your simple while loops what
we are seeing
similarly we can work on for loops
so for loops can also be useful
so your conditionals what we saw is if
else or else if your while loop is while
a condition is
not yet met you keep looping
and keep doing some actions now what you
can do is you can also work on for loops
so here i am creating a vector
and then
i am going to loop
that is i am going to i trade through
every element so i will say 4
and when you are using for loops you
will say 4
and then you can given anything you can
given any value i can say i i can say x
so i am just giving temporary variable
invector and then i am printing it out
so this basically prints all the values
one by one so there is one more way to
do it you can say for and you can say i
in
and i would want to take
length of the vector
so 1 2 the length of vector that is till
the last element is reached i would want
to print
the vector elements using the value of i
so what is i here it's the index
position and i can do it in this way
so if you are looping over a list
so i'm creating a list and it's very
simple so you can just do a for loop
where you can say for i in list i want
to print the i and that gives me the
list elements or you say for i in and
you give from starting position that is
one till the length of list and you
would want to print every element so
here we can also use double brackets
so
if you would want to loop through a
matrix so sometimes that might be
required so let's create a matrix which
has 1 to 25 values around by row and you
look at your matrix and now what you
want to do is you want to iterate
through a matrix
so you want to do a looping so i'll say
for i in matrix i would want
to print out the values and that prints
out all the values in matrix
now
what if i want to print the square and
square roots of numbers between 1 to 25
so
i can say for i
wherein the value starts with 1 ends
with 25
and then within my for loop i can
basically
give this condition where i am saying
get me the square root that is i into i
or get me a square root of i
and
just print it out so i am saying message
i is this one square root is this and
my square is this and square root is
this so if i look at these values
here
now i am looking at all the values from
1 is to 25 i am looking at the square of
the values and i am looking at the
square root so what we did was we did a
we passed in the elements by saying i in
1 to 25 and within the bracket i have
said what do i want to do for every
element
so either i have calculated a square i
have calculated square root and then i
am printing out when i am using the
message function
which takes the value which you are
passing in
comma the value of i
similarly square and similarly square
root so these are some simple examples
of understanding flow control in r that
is using your for loops your while loops
and also your if else
later we will spend time in learning
about functions
which could be either created by the
user or built-in functions and also
factors in r hi everyone
welcome to this section of our
programming where we will learn about
functions whether that is about inbuilt
function or creating your own functions
and working on
your different data structures
so what are functions
function
is basically a set of statements to
perform a specific task
now
r
has a large number of inbuilt functions
so you can say packages which you can
import and start using
or users can create their own functions
so when it comes to functions the syntax
is very simple
you give a function name
you can assign
your function to a variable and a
function can take no arguments one
argument
or any number of arguments so let's see
some example on functions so for example
here we are creating a variable called
squares and we are assigning a function
to it now this function would take one
argument which is a
and then we use a for loop so we say for
i in
from 1 to the number a
we would basically be doing a
exponential computation so what we would
do is we would
square the value
in this particular range and assign that
to b and print it now when we do this
we can
call in this function and pass in a
value to look at the
square
of that particular value now this is a
simple example of function so this is
how it would look depending on what
value you have passed to the function so
for example we say squares and we pass
in a value of 4 so that becomes 4 i in 1
to 4
so you would start with 1
the value of
1 square would be 1 and then you have
your value for 2 so 2 square would be 4
then we have
3 3 square would be 9 and then we have 4
square which is 16. this is a simple
example of function and this is how you
can create your own function to
calculate or carry out some computations
now let's look at some other examples
before we get into built-in functions
which basically allows you to work with
different data structures
so there are different mathematical
functions which can be used for your
data science or
computations
you have your regular expressions which
can be used for pattern matching
or you can also use functions for data
manipulation now before we get into data
manipulation
let's look at how you work with
functions taking some examples
so let me bring up my r studio
wherein we will try out some examples
and see how functions work
now here are some examples and we can
see how this work let me just clean up
the console and we can start here
now here we are creating a symbol
function which does not take any
argument
we call it as hello world and this will
start with the word function
and parenthesis now that could have
arguments passed in however this
function we are not passing in any
argument
and what we are doing here is we are
printing out whatever value is passed
within the bracket so let me just do a
control enter my function is created and
you can straight away call this
by
just doing this
now however if you would have tried this
function without the bracket
for example something like this then it
would have printed out the complete
function it would have printed out the
complete function
and whatever you passed in to hello
world but if you would want to call the
function then basically you would just
do hello world and then use the brackets
so that's how you call the function and
that's how it shows the result
now your function can be with a single
argument so for example here we are
passing in an argument called name and
we can then use this to pass a value to
this so here i'm saying hello name
i have my function but this one takes a
single argument and we are going to use
paste which basically can concatenate or
just adds up whatever you are passing in
to paste
so we will say paste hello and then the
name
notice that i have given a space here
after hello so that i can have it in the
right format and i can just do this so
the function is created and now let's
pass a name here and just try to call
the function so name is one argument or
a single argument which is passed to
this function
so let's look at the result and that
shows me the name whichever was passed
to this one
now what we can also have is function
created which takes two arguments and
this is a simple example so here we are
creating a function add num
i'm saying function it takes to argument
i'm not providing any value or default
values for this we'll see some other
examples for those now here this
particular function takes two arguments
and whatever you pass in here a
addition of that will be seen
so let's create this function and let's
call it and test it and that shows me
the result as 70.
now what we can also do is we can add a
vector to a number so vector is list of
elements or list of objects you can say
and here we would want to
perform add num or we would have to call
addnum function by passing in vector
which becomes the first argument and the
second value is the next argument so
let's run this one
and that shows me the result wherein 5
as a value has been added to every
element of this particular vector
now when it comes to function you can
also have default argument values which
can be passed so here let's look at as
an example so we have hello name again
but this time instead of passing in just
an argument we will also provide it a
value or you could say that could be
considered as a default value now when
we create this function we are doing the
same thing as previous examples but we
are passing in an argument and that
argument has a value now once i do this
i can surely call this function without
passing in a value and that shows me the
name which we had assigned to the
argument
or we can even pass in a new name which
will be assigned to name so if we do
this it works in both the ways fine so
this is in one way you are passing in a
default value
and then basically
you can either call the argument or
you can assign it a new value
so if we would do something like this
hello name
and then for example i would say name
equals
say
jerry
and if i would do this so that also
works fine however since we are passing
in an argument we are assigning a value
so either we can let it go for the
default or we can just pass in the value
or we can be very specific in mentioning
the argument and then the value for it
now how do we return value from a
function let's look at this so here we
are creating a function we are calling
it full name
and this one takes name
wherein we are giving sachin and title
is say tendulkar
and what we would do is we would use a
return statement here so return would
basically
use the paste function it will take the
values of name and title and then glue
them together however we are using also
a space
so that
there is a space between these two
values to the arguments which are passed
now if i run this argument sorry this
function my function is created now we
have already passed named arguments or
we have already passed value to those so
we can straight away say just call the
function and that does
whatever you have mentioned in the
function body
i could have also said that i could
create a new one
wherein i will pass new set of values
which we saw in a previous example
and then if we call this it takes up the
new values so
either you can let it go for default
like what we did here
we can also pass in new values
or if you would want to keep it specific
you could basically say
full
underscore name
that's my function i could say name
equals and i can say john
and then i will say title
smith
and that's also fine
so we can do this and that works in the
same way as it would have worked with
just passing in the names
so this is fine and if you would want to
test it out say for example if i would
just take off name here and just do this
that also works perfectly fine wherein
we are
still using these arguments in the
particular order now if
i would have changed this one to name
wherein i am already passing in a value
for name and if i tried this
so in this case what happens is name is
smith
and
basically your title becomes john
right so we have to remember how we are
what arguments we are passing and if we
are basically
assigning values to the arguments or
letting it pick up the default ones
so let's do this and that looks okay now
when you talk about scope of a variable
okay now before we understand scope of a
variable let me show you some more
examples on function now say for example
if you were using built-in functions we
have lots and lots of
built-in functions which are available
for programmers
which
uh they can use in their data science
activities or data processing or
computation now here we are using a
function called r norm
to generate thousand random values from
a normal distribution of mean zero and 1
so i would use the r norm
that's an inbuilt function
and i will call this say normal
distribution
so that is already done now we can find
out the mean
on these random values which would have
been generated using the inbuilt mean
function and that works perfectly fine
you can also
create a histogram out of this and if i
do this it shows me
the histogram so let's see
the histogram here
let's bring it out and that shows me the
histogram of normal distribution if you
would be interested in knowing about a
particular inbuilt function you can just
do a question mark and use the function
and that basically shows you the
documentation of the function so this is
a generic function which computes a
histogram of a given data value
and here it takes arguments so this is
basically your data
this could be the number of arguments
which you are passing in
for
your histogram to be created
now we can look at some more examples
here so i can say two histogram with
large number of interval breaks and this
is where i am also specifying breaks and
passing in a value
so this
allows me to provide arguments to
functions by position
now the same example which we have given
here
we can do it without breaks argument but
as a good practice we should
actually give name to the arguments
which we are defining so if i would do
this
when i'm passing in my data that is
normal distribution and then for breaks
i'm just giving the value 50 and that is
also fine it works perfectly fine here
now
we can create our own function
which as we saw in some basic examples
functions which can be without arguments
say this is a simple example or with
arguments
so this one we have already seen how you
can create a function without giving any
argument or by giving an argument and
then basically calling in the function
now when it comes to optional arguments
so we can look at this function
wherein i would want to say find out the
exponential value of a particular number
so i call it expo value
i use my function i say this will take
the value x now that's an argument which
we are passing in we could have given it
a value or we will just let the user
provide the value when this function is
being called i will also give a default
argument which is power equals to
and here we would want to get a
histogram of the values
with a particular power so if i create
this particular function
that's done and now i will just pass in
my value i don't need to mention power
that has been given a default value yeah
if we would want to change it then we
can pass in that so let's run this one
and that gives me
exponential value a histogram based on
the normal distribution data and by
default
it is using power s2
now what we could have also done is we
could have specifically mentioned a
different value for power
and that works perfectly fine i could
have just passed in the value as power
and that also works fine
so here you are using named arguments
and
basically
passing in any other arguments
now what we can also do is we can use
these named arguments and then we can
also do
or we can pass these arguments
that is what we call as passing any
other arguments now if you look at the
explanation of this
hist function histogram function
if you look at this
it shows me these three dots and this is
what we can use to pass in
any other arguments so let's look at an
example for this one
so say for example
i would want
to
create a function where i am passing
named arguments
i am passing in the data but then i
would also want to pass any other
arguments which can be passed
dynamically now for that we can create a
function here
wherein i am calling it expo value again
i am passing in my x which will be the
data which we will pass in
you are mentioning power which is 2
which is a named argument which can also
be considered as a default or you can
change the value
or you can provide a new value and then
i am also giving these three dots which
are also passed in within this
particular function
so let me create this function here
now once that is done
then i can call this function by passing
in my data which is normal distribution
power is 2 and then i'm also using these
breaks for getting my histogram with
intervals
of 50. so let's call this function
and that gives me the histogram now what
we can also do is sometimes it might be
useful to pass logical arguments so for
logical arguments what we can do is we
can create a function which will take
the data
here i am using a named argument exp
that is for exponential i am saying if
the value of
histogram is false
and then i am also giving any other
arguments so what we will do here is in
this function we will say if
the value of hist is true then this
block of code will get executed where
you will get a histogram
based on the exponential
which has been assigned in the function
passed as an argument
and if that doesn't hold true which is
by default false as we have given in our
function then this piece of code will
get executed so let's create this
function and that's done and now we can
straight away just pass in our data
exponential value is given as 2
histogram has been given in false that
means the else part of the code will get
executed and we can look at the values
here
i can also say
histogram
is true and that's where we will be
calling in the hist function and i can
do this that shows me the histogram so
in this way we can pass in named
arguments we can pass logicals
and then we can also pass any other
arguments for our use case
now looking further in functions let's
also understand the scope of a variable
in a function
so here i am saying v
and then i am saying
i am global variable let's create this
and then i am saying stuff so i am
global stuff so this is basically we
have assigned some values to variables v
and stuff now let's create a function
where i'll say fun
i'll use the function and i will say
this will take my variable stuff i'm
saying print v
and then for stuff i'm assigning in a
new value
and then i'll print stuff
so let me create this function and let's
see how it works so if for example i
would just say print v
that shows me
the global variable which we had created
earlier and since i'm using that within
my function
it basically has the value now i also
have a global stuff so i am saying print
stuff
and that shows me whatever was assigned
to the variable and now we will
basically call the function
by giving in
the argument as stuff
the variable which we had created
now
if we do this then it says
reassigning stuff inside the function
and that's because within the function
we are basically assigning a new value
to this stuff
now i can also just do a print stuff now
if and if you see it still goes back and
prints the
global variable so only within the
function
reassignment happened and that's what we
understand when we talk about global
variable or local variable now
to create a function to find the final
output amount to be paid by a customer
after adding 20 percent tax to the
purchase amount how do we do that
so
i'm here creating a function
which will take x as hundred
and what does that function do
we would want to basically
find out
the amount which is paid by customer
after adding 20 percent of tax now how
do we calculate that so we take x
plus
20 percent of x and that would be the
final amount which will be paid so we do
a return t
and this is my function so let's create
this function and then let's pass in a
value to see what is the
amount which customer would pay
with an addition of 20 tax so this is a
simple function where we are
passing in one argument we are giving it
a value and then we are doing
computation within the
function body
what we can also do is we can create a
function where i am passing in an
argument and i can then
check the value of that so if the
argument
passed was greater than 0 then we would
find out the final amount which is
amount plus 20 percent of the amount if
the amount is less than or equal to
amount then
equal to zero then our final amount is
equal to amount
and we return f amount so here we will
be evaluating these conditions and based
on that my function will return the
value so let's create this function and
pass in a value
and that shows me 100. so you can just
test this by saying amount 1
and say for example i would have passed
in zero now in this case my final amount
is zero because there is no amount which
needs to be paid by the customer
now
checking the argument and the body of a
function so
we can always use this inbuilt function
args which will tell me
for this particular function what are
the arguments and what is the body of
the argument which basically tells me
whatever we have coded within the
function body
now to understand the scope we can
create a function here which is taking
an argument x and what does this do so
we assign a value to y
then
we basically say g1 and here
i am
using function of x now what does that
function of x do
so this one will take the value of y
plus
multiply x by itself
so this is a function which we are
creating
and then i am saying g1 of x
so what you are doing is whatever value
was passed in as x
for that function x will be applied so
let's create this function and then pass
in a value 10
and that gives me the result as 110.
similarly we can create another function
where we want to do some computation
and then i am creating one more variable
which has basically the function
pass in a value for y and then basically
what you do is
you are calling in your g2 function
and then
let's call in this function
so let's do this
and
let's also create f2
and then finally we will call in f2
which is internally calling g2
so these are some simple examples where
you are doing some computations
and creating some simple functions let's
also create a function which is taking
two arguments so here i have g2
function takes two arguments x and y
what does that function do
here we are saying y plus x into x
that's my g2
and similarly i'll create f2 which is
going to have a value assigned to y
and this one
is going to call in my g2 function
which will take
x and y
x which we are passing in here
and y which we have assigned
so let's create this
and then let's call our f2
and what does that f2 do it basically
has the value of y assigned and then it
does
whatever is mentioned in g2
with our x and y values so i'm passing
in 10 here
so it is
basically y which is 10 plus
you have
the x value which has been passed here
so let's look at the calculation which
is 10
so that gives me 110. so 10 into
10 into 10 plus the value of y
so this is how we can create functions
which have been assigned some values and
then pass in some other values to those
look at some more examples here when it
when we work with functions
and see how we can use functions to
carry out our basic operations or
calculations so for example here i am
creating a function
and this will take an argument wherein
we are saying it would be marks
now let's do this and the function body
would say result is not defined
now if the marks are greater than 50
then result will be
pass
and you will have the message which is
your result is
and then you are passing the value of
result
so let's look at this one so
let's create this function pretty simple
function
and then
let's pass in a value here so i'll say
status as 60
which will be checked for the value
greater than marks or lesser than marks
and that tells me your result is pass
and if we give this one then it says
your result is not defined however we
can
have additional statements here which
can say if the result was
lesser than 50 then what should have
been printed this is a simple example
let's look at one more example and here
my argument
is h now just notice that we are not
passing any default values or we are not
passing any values to the arguments we
are just passing in an argument
which will be assigned a value when you
call the function now here we say age
group is not defined
we say vote is not defined and then we
start using some condition checks
so i say if the age passed is greater
than 18 then
the age group would be adult and the
person can vote
and
message your age group is and voting
status is will be printed out
so
we can use this or from our previous
learning we can do a if else and modify
the function
so let's create this function and then
pass in a simple value to this and that
tells me what is your age group and what
is your status to vote
so
now if we would want to create a
function to convert a name into
uppercase
let's see how we can do that so we are
creating a function here which takes the
value name now then we also find out the
length
of
this particular argument and for that we
are using a inbuilt function called n
character
which will be
for your name and you would want to find
out the length of this particular name
and we would say if the length is
greater than 5
then we are again using a inbuilt
function called two upper which will
convert the argument or the name passed
to uppercase
we will say message
user given name is and then you print
out your name
so let's
call in this function
so let me first create this
and then
i can call in this function and we
clearly see that the number of
characters in this word is
more than 5
and that's why it is converted to upper
case however if you would call the
function with a name which has less than
five characters
it says
as it is
now this is again a simple function
which we created let's see how you can
create a function to calculate bonus
now here we are passing in two arguments
so this function takes two arguments one
is salary
and one is experience
and then we say if the experience is
greater than five
then bonus percentage will be
and else
bonus percentage will be 5
and here we will calculate the bonus so
first it will find out
how many years of experience a
particular employee has and based on
that a value of bonus will be assigned
or bonus percentage will be assigned and
then you say what will be the bonus that
is salary into the bonus percentage
and return the bonus amount so this is a
simple function let's basically
select this
and let's create this function and then
let's calculate the function if the
salary is 25 000
and experience is six years
and that basically will tell me the
value so let's look at the value it
tells me
2500 which is 10 percent of the salary
similarly if we go for this one which
will
basically go for the execution of else
part of the code
we can do this and that gives me bonuses
half of it
now
how do we handle multiple conditions and
multiple actions so let's look at that
so let's create a function which takes
one argument which is h
we would check if the age is greater
than zero then
we would want a nested if within this
condition
so if age is greater than zero then
whatever we have given here will get
executed
and
this will be
this part of your code
and here
i am again checking if age is less than
18 then
age group would be kids else
if
now else if is to check the second
condition so if the age was passed if it
is greater than 0 then we get into this
block of the code now it was greater
than 0 but then is it less than 18 then
i would categorize the person as kids
if edge is less than 60
then we will say
age group adult
else we will say age group senior
now we can
basically say that we could have given
more conditions to this because here we
are saying if age group is less than 18
then
the individual would be within the age
group of kids
if that is not true that is not less
than 18 so probably it is 18 or
greater than 18 then we are checking the
second condition if the age is less than
60 age group is adult and if
these two conditions are not met
then it jumps to else where age group is
senior
and if this whole block
was ignored because age was less than 0
then
we would have just printed out age group
is not defined which is messages wrong h
and your age is such and such so this is
our whole function so let's go ahead and
run this
now let's check the age group when the
age is 10
when the age is 40 when the age is 65 or
when the age is minus 10 which is not
defined
now there are some inbuilt functions
which can be used in r
such as your switch function so looking
at this
function that is switch function
we can see
or we can use this for our different
kind of operations so here your switch
function returns values
match with the first argument and first
argument should be a character let's
have a look at the example
so say for example you want to return
the
house rent allowance or hra amount based
on cities
so we create a function called hra
now that takes an argument which is city
name and here
we will say what does this function do
so here i am saying hra amount and i am
going to use the switch function
now switch function i am saying i would
want to convert the city name to
uppercase so that we can maintain some
consistency
and here i'm saying if
the city is bangalore it would be 7500
if it is mumbai
thousand if it is delhi 8 000 chennai
and you have 5000 value and you are
returning the hra amount now what do we
do with that
so let's
create this function
it's done and now we will pass in the
value so we will see
whatever value has been passed to this
and that gives me the value here right
so switch is basically taking me
directly to this value now however if i
try to provide a city name which is not
given in the list
so when i'm saying say for example
pune now what is happening is it is just
taking a value which has not been
assigned to any of these conditions
if i go for again something else which
is
in a lower case
now this is where your two upper
function will come into use and if we do
this it basically converts this into
uppercase mangalore and then basically
it gives you the value
so this is the usage of a switch
function
let's look at one more example so for
example here we are creating a salary
range which will take an argument which
will be banned and i will say these are
my bands or you can say these are my
options so i can say l one is basically
ten thousand to fifteen thousand
l two
is so and so
and l three is so and so and you return
the range
now
let's create this function
sometimes you have to
do it this way
so our function is created and now we
can just do a salary range given a value
and that gives me the range of the
values however if you pass something
which is not mentioned then it basically
prints out null
so in r you can also use repeat which
can be useful
and
what does repeat do so here i am
assigning a value to a variable called
time
let's do that
and then i'm giving a piece of code with
repeat now what does repeat do so you
are passing in a message which is
hello welcome to our tutorial
and then you are saying if time is
greater than or equal to 20 you would
want to break out from this loop
and
then you also
increment the times value and this will
keep repeating till
this if condition is met
wherein we have said time value starts
from 15 so let's do this
and this basically will print out
the message wherein first my time was 15
which was
less than 20 so you increment it it
becomes 16 you print it again 17 print
it again 18 print it again 19 and 20 and
as soon as you reach the times value
which is 20 it breaks out of this and it
stops printing this particular message
okay now let's look at
some more examples so if you say r
we will use say a function to find the
square of any given user number okay if
the square value is less than 100 then
increment user value by 1 and find
square again and repeat this till square
exceeds
pretty simple so you create a function
which takes n as an argument and you
would want to repeat it
so you would want to repeat this by
squaring the numbers
until the square
exceeds 100
and once it reaches 100
you will break out
so this is what we are doing and we are
auto incrementing or incrementing the
value of n by one every time
we calculate a square
and then you return the value of n
so let's create this function
and now let's calculate it for square 6
and that tells me what is the square now
as soon as your square value touches 100
it basically breaks out of the loop
now if you would want to find balance in
a bank account after n years
if
a person has deposited x amount in the
beginning and bank gives a interest of 8
percent per annum right this is a simple
calculation so it needs the amount which
was deposited you need the year and you
need the
rate
now year which is n ears can be given by
the user rate we have already given
eight percent
however functions main functionality is
that you can even assign new values to
it say
later one month down the line the bank
rate changes might be it increases might
be decreases then
function should not be
modified it can just take up the new
values and start calculating from there
on
now here
we will say
get the final balance
function takes amount
the amount which would be deposited year
and that could be say four years or five
years or ten years for which you would
want to calculate the rate of interest
and add it to the amount so i will say
for i in 1 to year so that depends on
how many times you would want to
run this loop
i would say interest would be
using the round function i am saying
amount into rate
whatever is the rate of interest
and then you are giving two years
now
final amount
will be calculated
so you are basically saying amount plus
interest and you will pass in a message
where we'll say year
is the value of i that's first year or
second year
amount what is the amount what is the
interest you are calculating based on
the round function
and final amount will be amount plus the
interest
and then
you basically say
amount will be given
our final amount will be assigned to
amount now if this is a function
you would want to return the final
amount so let's select this
and then basically create a function
and let's say i would want
the final balance if the amount
deposited was five thousand
it was kept in the bank for five years
and rate of interest was eight
now
that should basically give me
my final amount
and if we
double that so we say amount is 10 000
number of years is 10 but the rate of
interest is less
so let's calculate this and that gives
me the interest however if you notice
based on my message it is basically
telling me what was the first amount
what was the interest what was the final
amount and it does that
for all these number of years
so these are some simple examples for
your functions right now we can also
look at on the similar lines we can
create some interesting functions so you
can find the total number of years
required to raise
thousand dollars if the user deposits
750 per month so here you are not
actually calculating the final amount
but
you would want
to find out how many years
are required to basically have the
amount as 8000 so
your function we are saying the amount
is say
550 or say 750
per month
now i would say let the final amount be
0 as of now month is 0 and i will say
while my final amount is less than or
equal to eight thousand i would want to
do something
and that is you are
incrementing the value of month by one
because that's your first time your
amount is less than eight thousand
whatever deposit was made say seven
fifty dollars per month
and then you have final amount which is
your
initial amount which has been assigned
to f amount that is 0 plus the amount
you print out the message
and then you basically say year
is
whatever value was passed for month
so you may want to have it for number of
years or years with particular amount of
month so we will calculate the year
value now here what we are doing is
we are calling in this required years
function without an argument which takes
the default argument
or you can pass it with 750.
we can run this so let's create this
function pretty simple
done
and if we do not pass an argument then
the amount is 750
and it tells me
what would be
or how much time it would take
for us to reach from say 750 or 550 to
final amount
similarly if i would have done this
it tells me
again a new value so we are finding out
the total number of years required to
raise
thousand or raise the amount to 1800
dollars so these are some simple
examples of functions which you can use
for your operations your calculations
and also creating functions which can be
repeatedly used with
either one either no or either multiple
arguments
now so far we were learning on creating
our own functions
and we also looked at using some inbuilt
functions
either
creating a plot or basically doing some
basic operations
or
passing in multiple arguments
so let's look at some more examples and
when we talk about
built-in functions there are lots and
lots of built-in functions which are
available in r
which can be used so let's look at these
so for example here are some built-in
functions
which can allow you to work with
different data structures for example
you have a sequence function
which allows you to create sequences so
for example i could just say test nums
and i can just say sequence
and here i can say where does it start
from so might be i can say 0
goes all the way to 50 and then i can
also say if i would want a jump or how
many numbers should be used so for
example let's do this
and now if i look at test
nums
so that shows me the value however not
to confuse we could have also done this
using assignment operator like this
and then look at your test nums so it
tells me
it has created a list of numbers from 0
to 50 which are even numbers now you can
always do a class off
and let's look at this
and that tells me
the objects here are numeric
and say for example
i would use type off
to see what is this test nums which we
just created there was a typing mistake
let's check this and it has the values
with double
right so we have created a sequence here
where we are creating a list of numbers
which have a space of 2 or you are
saying about even numbers now you can
also use a sort function so i can do a
sorting here and i can give it an
increasing or a decreasing order so if
for example i have created this sequence
and i could just create a simple
variable like this
pass in a vector into this
which could be say for example i'll try
out test nums
and then look at your v
so those are my numbers and you can
straight away do a sort on your test
nums so i could just do a sort on v
and that basically shows me the number
however i could also do a sort v
and then i could say
here
let's check this v comma
and then you can say decreasing
true
and let's do this it just reverse or
puts the data in a reverse order or it
sorts based on decreasing value and
having the greater value in the
beginning and the lowest value at the
end
so you can use a inbuilt sort function
similarly you can use a reverse
now reverse
need not actually sort the values it
will just reverse the elements in your
sequence for example
let's say v2 and i will again use
this one
as c and then just past your test nums
that's an easier way or i could have
created a new vector so i'll say test
nums
that's my v2 and you can do a reverse
on
v2
and that basically
shows me the values but here we see
let's see so we are looking at
okay so this was wrong i should have
given a capitals
and do it yeah this is fine
and we get the values however if i had
created something like this v3
and let's say c
and then let's say 99
and 2 and 3 and 4 and 5 and 78 100
so that's
a vector i'm creating and now what i can
do is i can use the reverse
on
v3
and you see
it has just reversed the elements in the
list
now we could have done this without
giving these brackets here
and it shows me the result
so this is good to understand what your
sorting does so sorting is basically
going to look at the objects and it's
going to sort them in ascending or
descending order reverse is just going
to
reverse the elements in your list now
similarly you can also use append which
is basically to combine objects so let's
say v4
and that will basically have
append
and let's say let's take v2
and let's take v3
and this is what we would want to append
and now look at your value of v4
which basically has everything added
into one so this is your append
similarly you have other functions like
finding out the absolute value
of a number you would want to find out
the square root you would want to find
the sum of all the elements in a vector
you would want to find out the floor
value exponential value
of something
and you basically finding out the mean
value so these are some built-in
mathematical functions so you have
built-in symbol functions you have
mathematical functions you have regular
expressions in r which can also be used
for pattern matching now what we can
simply do is we can
create a variable let's say text
sorry for caps
let's say text and here i will pass in
something r is a
programming
language for
data science
let's do this and now i would want to
use grep function so i can say grep
and this one needs what i am searching
for so let's say
language and where am i searching for so
i'm searching it in text
and let's do that and that tells me
where is this found so when i do a grep
i'm trying to find out if this was found
in my element so here i'm saying text
and grep language similarly i can also
use one more function which is
finding out
index positions so i can also find out
index positions by basically giving the
vector and here
i can do a grep pass in my vector a b c
d
you are searching for b and in your
vector
and that tells you your b is at the
index position 2 d is at the index
position 4. so here we are using some
regular expressions
now there are also other
ways in which r can be used for data
manipulation so let's learn about
factors in r and
how do you work with factors and what
are they for
so when you talk about
factors
so here let's clean this up
and let's see what is this
so when you say
factors
here we are talking about categorical
variables
so categorical variables can take only
limited number of different values now
don't be confused with this
histogram example here
might be we can just look at packages so
that that doesn't get confused
so when we talk about categorical
variables
we are talking about
variables which can belong to only
categories for example in r there is a
data structure to work with these kind
of variables and that is called your
factor so with factors we can be sure
that all statistical modeling techniques
will handle such data correctly
so for example you can talk about a
person's blood group and you can say
the blood group could be a or b or a b
or o
so say we collected information about
eight people
and we
recorded this information as a vector
and we can call it blood group so let's
do that so let me
[Music]
try that here
so if i say
blood
group
and then i would like to create a vector
here so that
we can look at information about eight
people and their blood group and this
can be
in the form of a vector which can then
be created or converted into factor
by using the factor function
so how do we do that let's say i have
blood group and here i will basically
given some values
so i will use c function and here let's
give some values so for example
let's say
b
let's say a b
and let's say
o
and let's say a again
let's again say oh
might be one more o
let's say a
and let's say b
so here we have eight entries and let's
consider we have recorded the blood
group of eight people
and this is in the form of a vector so
for example let me create this now this
is a vector which we have created and
you can always look at the value of this
one
so let's say blurred group
and that basically
okay there was a spelling mistake let's
do blood group
and that basically shows me the values
and here you see all the values that are
in double quotes now we have basically
created a vector
now to convert this vector into factor
we can use the factor function
and how we can do that is basically we
can say for example
[Music]
let's go here and let's say blurred
group
underscore factor
and for to convert this vector into
factor i will use the factor function
and then basically pass my
blood group here
and now i have created a factor and we
can look at this factor by just doing in
blurred group factor
and now if you see
it basically shows us a factor
it does not have any double quotes
and
you can also see the factor levels for
categorical variables which get printed
out here
now what what actually r is doing here
is first r scans through vector to see
the different categories in there
then our sorts levels alphabetically
and then it converts
the character vector
to a vector of integer values
so these integers correspond to set of
character values
to use when factor is displayed now we
can always do a structure
to find out more details of this
and here i will
pass in blood group factor and let's
look at this one and this one shows me
this factor is with four levels
so inspecting the structure will reveal
that it has four levels
it shows me what are the categorical
variables and it shows me some integers
so here we are dealing with a factor of
four levels
now a's are recorded and a
would have
say
recorded as one so that would be a first
level
you have a bs
which which are recorded here
and that is basically your second level
b is the third level and o is the fourth
level so when this
uh when we are looking at this factor we
may think why this conversion so
categories could be
very long character strings and each
time repeating a string or an
observation can take up lot of memory so
using factors and having these levels
can reduce the memory space
now factors are actually
integer vectors
and each integer corresponds to a
category or a level
now to specify a different order of
levels
we can specify levels inside the factor
function
how do we do that so let's say i will
say blurred underscore factor 2
and here
i will basically
give the same so i will say factor
and this factor will have blood group
which we had created earlier but this
time also i am going to specify
levels
and then i can basically pass in a
vector here
so within this levels i will specify the
values what are the levels
so here i will say o
then i'll say a
then let's say
b
and then let's say
a b
so this is what we are doing here
to specify different order of levels and
we are specifying the levels here now if
i do this
that would have got created and let's
look at
blood
factor 2 and that shows me the value
here
below where you have specifically
assigned the levels now if you look at
the previous one where we had blood
group factor where levels were
automatically
understood by r
so we were looking at the categorical
variables we were seeing what are the
levels here
and here what we have done is
we have just created again a factor but
then we have specified levels in a
different order
and you can obviously do a structure on
this to compare so for example i will
say structure
and then i will say blood factor 2
and that basically shows me the
structure with 4 levels so this was the
initial one where we said a a b b and
zero
and then there were some integer values
which were responding to these
categorical variables here we have given
a different level and we have a
different set of numbers which we see
here
so if we compare structure of blood
factor and blood factor 2 we will see
encoding is different
right now that is done we can also
specify the level names
so what we can do is
as we use names function for name of
vectors we can pass vectors to levels
here
and there is
basically
a function what you can use
so let's say i will
say levels
and then within this i'll pass blood
underscore
factor or blood group underscore factor
here
so
once this is done
let's say
blood group
so in this one we created blood group
underscore factor
and this one was blood factor two so
that's okay i mean it's just a naming
convention and here let's pass in levels
to my blood factor
and then what i can do is i can pass in
the values here
so this is
when you would want to give specific
names
and let's create a vector
and let's call it say bt underscore a
and might be you would want to give bt
underscore a b
and then you will give
bt underscore b
and
the final one is bt underscore o
so what i'm doing is i'm doing the
naming for these particular categorical
variables
by using levels
now let's do this
and
it says blood factor not found so
we have to look which one did we have so
we have
blood group factor so this is what we
should have given so let's say blood
group
factor
blood group factor
and now we have given some names here so
let's look at
the
blood group factor now
blood group
underscore factor
and now if you see we have some levels
or we have given the name to the
categorical variable so if you compare
this one so here we were creating a
blood group where we had these variables
and these variables were the categorical
variables
which was just creating a vector
then we created a factor out of it
and then we looked at our factor we
looked at the structure of it and
similarly what we did was we created a
different factor so let me also change
the name here
and let me call it blood group factor 2
but here we were specifying levels in a
different order
let's look at this one so which is blood
group factor two
and then you can look at the structure
of this one
blood group factor two and here
in this example what we did was
the initial blood group factor what we
had created we have just given
some names to that like what we would do
in case of vector by using the names
function here you are using the levels
function
so we basically
created some levels and let's group at
the blood group factor now which
basically has some
different names
so what we are doing here is we are just
using naming now we can also specify the
categorical variable names
or levels by specifying label arguments
so inside the factor function
so that is basically to
give some names or levels
so let's look at this one and how do we
do that
so we can specify by using
factor
which basically creates your factor
and then here i'll say blood
i am going to specify labels for my
naming so
in
previous examples we saw how we were
using the levels right and this was
by specifying levels for a different
ordering
and then
we could have also done this by saying
levels and given some different names
or we can just do labels
and then
within this i will say labels equals
and then i can say
c
and then let's give these values which
we have bt underscore a bt underscore a
b bt underscore b and o so let me just
copy this one again
and let's put it here
and then we can basically do a control
enter
so i would have created a factor here
and then
we should remember one thing here that
it is important to follow in
the same order as the order of factor
levels that is a
a b
b or o now these are the levels what we
are seeing so if you look at any one of
these in the beginning which we had
created
it was showing me
what levels it has a a b b and o
and a a b b and o so we are following
the same order but we are using the
labels
within
my factor creation
now sometimes there might be issues
because of wrong ordering
so we can actually use a combination of
manually specifying the levels and label
arguments when creating a factor
now what we can do there is we can say
factor
and in this case let's say
blood group
which i'm creating
then i will basically say
levels
to give
the right ordering
and here in levels
let's say o
let's say
a
let's say b
and then let's say a b
so this is for my
levels which i'm creating
and then what i can also do is i can go
for
labels
so levels will take care of my ordering
and labels will take care of by naming
the categories so let's say labels
and then we can create a vector
and we can give some names so we can say
bt underscore o
what else we have we have bt underscore
a
we can then say bt underscore
b
and finally we can say bt
underscore
a b
and
then let's create this one
so now what we have done is we have
created a blood group which has levels
which is following your ordering which
is following the naming
as we have passed so if you look at the
levels it tells you the names what you
have created
it also tells you all the categorical
variables
which were used
for my blood group and basically these
will have some labels
so
we can anytime
look at our
blood
group
which we had created in the beginning
and let's look at the values of those
so when we talk about categorical
variables there are
two kinds in categorical variables so
you have nominal or you have ordinal
now in nominal you don't have any
implied order for example
blood group o
is not necessarily greater than a that
is o is no or not more worth than a
that we can think of now trying such
comparisons with factors will generate a
warning so
say for example we would want to
look into our blood
factor and let's look at
what blood group factor contains now
that's the new blood group factor let's
say blood group
factor
and here i will try to pull out a value
here and let's compare this with
blood
factor
and let's look at some other value now
in this case
we see
not meaningful for factors so it cannot
really compare the categorical variables
and see if one variable is greater than
other or has more worth
now
there can be many examples where such
ordering does exist and in r we can
impose such ordering in factors thus
making it ordered factor so inside
factor
we can set the argument ordered is true
and we can do that now for example you
would look at
the size of address
so let's say
address size
and here i will say for example let's
create a vector
and let's say medium
let's say large
let's say
small
let's say again small
and then let's say large
let's say medium
again an entry of large
and then let's say
medium
so here i'm creating a vector
and let's see if we missed out any
quotes or comma
so it says unexpected symbol
and where is that so let's look at this
one so we have dress size
and we are looking at c so i'm saying m
l
s
and here is a quote missing
and that was the reason so
and this one also has a quote missing
and now it should resolve yeah
so let's look at this one and now we
have created a vector called dress size
now obviously you can create a factor of
this so i'll say address size underscore
factor
where i would want to look at the
ordering of this so let's create a
factor
and in factor we will pass our vector
on which we we want to convert or we
want to create a factor
we will say ordered
equals true
so i am specifying a particular ordering
and then i can also specify levels as we
saw earlier
so in levels we will give the category
so what categories we have so we have
small
we have medium
and we have large so these are the three
levels which we have
and let's create this as a factor now
that's done
and what you can do is you can look at
the
factor and we can also do a comparison
so let's for example look at our factor
what does it contain it has some levels
and if you closely notice
there are these levels which also have a
comparison of which one is worth or
more worth than other variable so you
can look at
dress size factor which has some
ordering which we have
implemented and now let's do a
comparison between address size
and
compare it with some other variable and
see what is the result so now it says if
it is true or if it is false earlier we
were not able to do that because we did
not have any ordering and if we were
looking at the variables we were not
really clear if one variable has more
worth than others so these are some
simple examples what we have seen now we
can also look at some more examples so
say for example i do a type here
now that basically is creating a vector
if i would want to compare the element
that is type 3
is it greater than type 4 it shows me
false right now here what we are seeing
is
that
if you are looking at a particular value
okay
we can basically see
that there is some comparison happening
here if i compare this with 1
and 2 which tells me true or false and
if i look at this it also does some
comparison so i can always
convert this into factor by using the
factor function so i can do this
if i'm checking
if for example i would want to
create a nominal factor i can do a type
dot factor and it tells me it is true
you can also do a type dot factor 2 and
then use the factor function pass in
your type which is a vector and here you
are saying ordered as true which we just
now saw
and now you look at type dot factor 2
which is creating an ordinal type of
variables
now here we can again create type dot
factor 3. so what we are doing here
in this case
we had a vector
we basically
said type dot factor
we said factor is of true
and then we looked at the nominal factor
we also did a factor 2
and then we created factor but we
specify ordered as true
so we get ordinal
and now if you look at type dot factor 3
here you are saying ordered and you are
also specifying levels like what we did
in the previous example and now
you would look at ordered factor with
user given order which also has the
levels which clearly show us a
comparison between those now we can take
a different example we can say type dot
factor 4
we are using the factor function i am
specifying type which is a vector i am
saying ordered is t
i am using
level which is giving me
some levels
and then we also have labels which are
basically going to have the naming
convention so let's look at this one and
look at type dot factor 4 so it tells me
what are the categorical variables
which are small medium large small large
medium these are for my
type values which we created a vector
here
these are my type
values
for which we created a vector
we said ordered is true the levels is
small medium large and we gave some
names so we are looking at the values of
this so this basically helps you to work
on your categorical variables when you
can then compare the values
and you can see what does it show
now here what we are doing is we are
creating a different vector we say small
tall tallest medium small and so on
let us look at this one which is
basically
type and it has the value so what we
would want to do is we would want to
compare height type of first value with
the fourth value
so for that
let's create a vector
on this type ordered is true level is we
are saying
small medium tall and tallest
these are the levels
and now when you look at your type dot
factor phi
it basically shows me
what are the levels which you have
specified so small is the smallest then
you have medium which is bigger than
small tall is bigger than medium tallest
is bigger than tall we have assigned
some levels and based on these levels
now you can compare your values in this
factor type dot factor five
take the first value which is small
and compare it with the fourth value
which is medium and you will know if
small is greater than medium so the
result would be false
now i can also convert this into integer
and i can continue working on this
now here you have
basically
a
sequence
so let's use the sequence function where
i'm starting from 0 ending to 20 and
there is a jump of 2 so that basically
creates a vector
let's look at the vector value here
and if you would want to sort the vector
so we are using a inbuilt function
wherein let's create this
vector with these numbers i can do a
sorting i can also do a sorting with
decreasing is true
you can do a reversing of vector so
these are some examples of inbuilt
functions which we have already
discussed so here you are doing a
reverse you are finding out the
structure you want to append two vectors
you want to check the class of an object
you want to convert a vector into a list
using as dot list
converting the vector into a matrix
you are having a sample
with with two random values between 10
and 20 so these are some inbuilt
functions which we have already
discussed such as your absolute
such as your
vector and getting an absolute value or
getting a sum of it or a mean of it
around
or basically rounding into two decimal
places getting the ceiling value getting
the floor value truncating it get
returning the log getting the
exponential value and so on
now we have also looked at regular
expressions earlier so regular
expressions let's just revisit that
so here you are basically creating a
variable called text and then you can
just do a grip
you can say what you would want to
search and where you would want to
search it and that would give you the
logical value indicating if the pattern
was found
you can try to search something else
which might not be found you can also
search for independent values like this
and that basically can give you the
position of that particular object
within the vector
and here is one more example of working
with timestamps so for example
if i would just to assist or date it
returns the current system date
if i would want to
set that as a variable and then call
that variable it shows me
our current time
i can also use as date
and then let's look at this one so as
date and this
would be converted into date and then
you can obviously use formatting
techniques like
getting the month getting the day
getting the year
so here we are passing in the date and
then we are saying what format we would
be interested in
and that basically gives us
the data in a particular format so
that's also useful when you have your
time series data or when you would want
to convert the data types and so on now
there are different ways in which you
can do formatting so for example in this
one we were saying month day and year
i can also say
for getting the full month name or
getting the full year name i can do this
caps
so i can look at this one and that
basically shows me
my
date in a particular format
so these are some inbuilt functions
which we are seeing and before this we
were seeing factors which is mainly to
work with categorical variables either
they have levels auto assigned and they
might not have labels
so you can give labels you can give
levels you can control the ordering you
can give levels in a different way so
that you can have a different ordering
so this is how you use factors and work
on categorical variables maybe that is
nominal or ordinal and easily you can
do your statistical computations on such
data
let's learn about data manipulation in r
and here we will learn about
d player package
and when we talk about this d player
package it is much faster and much
easier to read than base r so d player
package is used to transform and
summarize tabular data with rows and
columns you might be working on a data
frame or you might be getting in a
inbuilt our data set which can then be
converted into a data frame so we can
get this package the plier by just
calling in library function
and this can be used for grouping by
data summarizing the data adding new
variables selecting different set of
columns filtering our data sets sorting
it selecting it arranging it or even
mutating that is basically creating new
columns using functions
on existing variables so let's see how
we work with dplyer now here
i can basically get the package here so
i can just say
install.packagesd plier now we already
see the the package here which is
showing up so i will just select this
one i can do a control enter and that
will basically set up the package
package d player successfully unpacked
so that is done now you can start using
this package by just doing a library d
plier and this was built it shows me my
version of r
so let's also use a inbuilt data set
that is new york flights 13 so we can do
install dot packages and that will
search and get that relevant data set
i can again call it by using library
function now once that is done we can
look at some sample data here by just
doing view flights and that shows me the
data in a neat and a tabular format
which shows me year month day
departure time schedule departure time
and so on
now we can also do a head to look at
some initial data
which can help us in understanding the
data better
so what is this data about how many
columns we have what are the data types
or object types here it shows me how
many variables we have
so this is fine now we can start using
deployer and in that we can use
say filter function if we would want
to look in for specific value now here
we have the column as month so i will do
a filter now i'm creating a variable f1
i'm using the filter function
on flights
which we already have
and then what we can do is we can
basically
look at the month where the month value
is 0 7
so let's look at that
and this one
you can do a view on f1 which shows me
the data wherein you have filtered out
all the data based on month being seven
so this is a simple usage of filter we
can take some other example we may want
to include multiple columns so we can
say f2 filter
flights and here we will say month
is equal to 7 day is 3
and then look at the value of f2 if you
are interested in seeing this
and that tells you the month is seven
and days three you could also look into
a more readable format by using view on
f2 and that gives me my selected result
so we are just extracting in some
specific value we can keep extending
this so here we can say flights
is what we would want to work on i'm
using the filter function so i can
straight away
instead of creating a variable then then
doing a view i can also do a view in
this way i can just pass in my filter
within the view and within this i am
saying filter
i would want to look at the flights
month being 0 9 day being 2 and origin
being lga
and then that shows me the value here
and obviously you can scroll and look at
all the columns and if you see the
origin column it shows the selected
value so now we have filtered out our
data based on values
in three different columns
now
what we can also do is we can use and or
we can use or operators so i could have
done this
in a a little different way so i could
have said head which shows me
initial result i will do a flight so
within my head function i am passing in
this
and what does that contain so you are
saying flights and in this flights data
set you would want to pick up the month
being the column so we use the dollar
symbol here we given a value and i'll
say and and i'll again say flights
wherein i will select the day being two
and and and remember when you talk about
and it is going to
check if all the values are met true so
then you say flights origin
lge a and you look at the value
so in this way i can
filter out specifically multiple values
by specifying columns now we could have
done it in this way we could have
created a view or we could have assigned
this to a variable and then done a view
on that where we could have selected
month being day and origin or you can be
more
specific
in specifying all the columns it makes
the code more readable so let's look at
the values and here you are looking at
head which shows me based on month
day and then you can look for further
columns for other variables that is
origin being lga
now what we can also do is we can do
some slicing here to select rows by
particular position
so i can say slice and i would want to
look at
rows one two five and i can do this so
you can always assign or look at the
view of this
i can just do
here so when i did a slide 1 is to 5 it
shows me
my entries
for one to five
now similarly we can do is slice 5 to 10
and now you are looking at
5 to 10 values
so you can always look at the complete
data and then you can slice out
particular data now mutate is usually a
function which is used when you would
want to apply some variable on a
particular data set
and then you would want to add it to
your
existing data frame or you would want to
add a new column so this is where you
use
mutate which is mainly used to add new
variables so let's see how you work on
mutate
so it's pretty simple so you create a
variable over delay now i would want to
do a mutate so that it adds a new column
so i'm selecting my data which is flight
i will call the new column as overall
delay
and then basically
i can look at
overall delay being arrival delay minus
departure delay so let's create this and
let's look at view of this which shows
me
or which should show me my new column
which is overall delay which was not in
my original data set so you can anytime
do a head on this one to compare the
value so this one shows me arrival delay
and then there are many other variables
what you can also do is you can do a
view
and you could have just look at flights
if you would want to compare
so you can look at the flights and this
one would not have any
overall delay column so it basically
shows me 19 columns only
what we see here
and if you
do a view on
overall delay then that basically shows
me 20 columns so we know that the new
column has been added
to
this overall delay so if you would want
to work with 20 columns you will use
overall delay if you would want to work
with your original data set you will use
flights now you can also use a transmute
function which is used to show only the
new column so we can do an overall delay
and at this time we will say transmute
we will say flights overall delay
the computation remains same but at this
time if i look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute result
based on two variables or two columns
and just look at the new value
and then we can decide if we would want
to add it to our existing structure
now you can also use summarize
and summarize basically helps us in
getting a summary
based on certain criteria so we can
always do a
summarize
and
what we can do is we can look at our
data and we can say on what basis we
would want to summarize this particular
data so we can do a summarize function
now summarize on flights i will say
average a time and i would want to
calculate an average so for that i'm
using inbuilt function called mean
i will do that on airtime column
so
let's look at flights once again and
here we can see there is
arrival time not a time sorry arrival
time and we would want to do some
average on this particular data we would
want to summarize this so what i'll do
is i will use the summarize function
i will say average airtime and this one
i will look at mean of a time so let's
see if there is a a time column i might
be
let's look at this one and i will delay
and yes we have an airtime so we were
actually looking at
summarizing based on air time not the
arrival time
so air time is how much time it takes in
air for this particular flight and we
will want to use the trans summarize
function not the transmute so summarize
flights average a time and this one we
will calculate the mean of average a
time
and
i will also do a any removal which is i
am saying true so let's do this and that
basically shows me the average a time is
i can also do a total a time where i'm
doing a summation of values or i can get
the standard deviation
or i can basically
get multiple values such as mean
i can say total airtime where i'm doing
a summation
and then i can look at other values
which is if you would want to put in
standard deviation here you could do
that so let's look at the result of this
summarize and this basically allows me
to get some useful information which is
summarized based on a particular
function such as mean sum standard
deviation
or
all three of them
now
let's look at grouping by so sometimes
we may be interested in summarizing the
data by groups and that's where we use
the group by function
so we can always
use
the group by clause
now
here we are taking a different data set
so we will say for example let's look at
head of mt cars
and that is basically my data set on
empty cars now that shows me the model
of the car
it shows me my lathe cylinder power this
and your horsepower and various other
characteristics or variables in this
particular data set
so here
we can say let's do a grouping by gear
so there is a column called gear so i
will call it by gear i will look at my
data set and then what i am using here
which you see with these percentage and
greater symbol
is called
piping
so that basically
feeds your previous data frame into next
one so this is sometimes useful and you
can get this by just saying control
shift and m and you can then use this so
we are going to
have
piping so i am saying empty cars now
this is my original data set
where i did a head
or i could have done a view on this one
if you would want to see it in a more
readable format and that basically shows
me the data so we are using a different
data set so i want to group it by the
gear column so i'm going to call it by
gear
and
this one takes my data that is empty
cars i'm using the piping and then i'm
saying group the data based on gear
column that's done now let's look at the
value of by gear
or
you can always do a view so remember
whenever you're doing a group by it is
giving you a
internal object where your data is
grouped based on a particular column
so we can look at the values here you
can do a view that shows you
your data grouped based on a particular
column
now i can again use the summarize
function
where i would want to now work on the
new one where it was grouped based on
gear so i am doing a summarize and here
i am going to say gear1 which will be
having the value of summation on the
gear column
and then i'm saying gear 2 which is mean
well you could give some meaningful
names to this
and let's look at the value of this one
where we are basically now looking at
the values which is some and mean values
based on the gear
similarly we can use look at different
example so we can say by gear
and i'm again using piping
but earlier we had taken gear
we had grouped the data
and we called it by gear so we took our
original data set empty cars but now
within this particular data which was
grouped by gear i will take this data
set i will use the piping and i will
summarize it where i am saying
within this particular data set i would
want to get the sum or i would want to
get the mean and then you can look at
the values
so what you're doing is
you are
either looking at your original data set
or you're looking at the data which was
already grouped and then you can look at
the values
now here what we can do is we can group
by cylinder say might be you are
interested in looking at data which is
summarized based on the cylinder column
you can do that and then for this by
cylinder i'm doing a piping where i'm
using the summarize function and
summarizing will then be done based on
the mean values of the gear column or
the horsepower
so let's do this
and then you can basically look at the
value at any point you may want to look
at the data set again so just go ahead
and you can look at what does the value
contain
and
by cylinder or by gear and do a head and
it gives you the value
so you can always do some summarizing or
grouping in these ways now here we are
going to use sample underscore n
function and sample underscore
fraction for creating samples
so for this
let's take the flights data set again
and we would want to
get 15 random values now that is done
and it shows me 15 rows with some random
values from the data what you can also
do is you can do a portion of data by
using sample underscore
fraction and here i'll say flights i'll
say 0.4 which will return 40 percent of
the total data so this can be useful
when you are building your machine
learning where you would want to split
your data into training and test might
be you are interested in some portion of
the data so you can do this
which is very useful function
and then you can look at the value of
that now
what we can also do is we can use a
range function so like we were doing a
grouping by or we were trying to pull
out a particular column so in the same
way we can use a range which is a
convenient way of sorting than your base
r sorting so for a range function
let's do a view
based on a range so we will work on the
flights data set which we have
and here what we would want to do is we
would want to arrange the flights data
set
which is based on year and departure
time and we are doing a view out of it
so that basically
gives me the data
which is arranged based on
your year and departure time now i can
do a head to give me
some highlighting of that data
now
the piping operator what we are using
can be used in these ways also so here i
will say df i will just assign the data
set empty cars to it let's look at the
df which has basically your different
models you can obviously
look at the head or view of it to look
at useful information we can also go for
nesting options which can be useful
so we are
creating a variable called result here
now that has the arrange function
so what does this arrange function do so
when we would want to use arrange to
sort the data so i would want to sort
the data but what data would i sort so i
will use sample n
which will give me some portion of the
data or some sample data now what is
that sample data so here we are using
nesting that is
earlier when we did a sample we just
said data and how many random samples we
want but instead of giving that what we
are going to do is we are going to use
filter here
now this filter will work on df
so filtering will happen based on the
mileage which is greater than 20
i will say size is 5 and i would want to
basically arrange this in a descending
order so i'm using the des
on this particular mileage column by
default it is always ascending
so let's get the result out of this
which will basically show me the mileage
details in a descending order so this is
my data frame and now
we can look at the result what we have
created
so just do a view or do a head
and look at the view so here you see
mileage
where the highest value is on the top
and we were only interested in five
values in a random sample so that's why
when you did a view it shows your five
values and it shows in a descending
order based on mileage so we have
not only used an inbuilt function we
have not only arranged the data that is
we have sorted the data but we have
sorted the data based on a descending
order on a particular column we have
said the value should be greater than 20
and we have also said we just need five
random samples
now let's look at some other examples so
you can always do a multi assignment
so i can say filter
wherein i am going to use
df which was assigned empty cars i am
going to say mileage should be greater
than 20
then i say b which is going to get a
sample out of a
and i just want 5 random values
so let's look at that so we have b which
is
going to get a
set of five values from a
now i will create a result variable
which will arrange b which is sample
data in a descending order now let's
look at the result of this and that
basically shows me what we were seeing
earlier so you can do a multi-assignment
where you can create a variable
get a sample out of it and then
basically whatever is that result you
can arrange that or sort that in a
descending order by default descending
order
so same thing we can do it using pipe
operator
so piping so here i will say result
i am passing in my df that's the data
set i'm using piping and which basically
tells what you need to do on this
particular data set so i'm going to
filter out the data based on mileage 50
sorry minus 20 then i'm going to push
that
or forward it to
get the random sample and whatever is
this random sample is going to be pushed
so you are arranging this in a
descending order so this is one more way
of doing it and then basically you can
look at the result so these are some
simple examples where you can use your
dplyer with multiple assignments or
using your nesting to filter out the
data
you can also do a
arrange which is to sort the data you
can get some random samples out of it
you can summarize the data
you can also
summarize the data based on one or two
or multiple columns and you can use some
inbuilt functions to summarize the data
based on some
functions which are applied on the
variables or on the columns
you can transmute it
where you would be interested in only
looking at one column
you can mutate it where you want to add
a new column
you can slice it
and you can give the conditions where
you can say and on or
to filter out the data
so what we can also do is on this
particular data set which we have say
for example df
where i have my data let's look at this
one
and if i just do a df at this point it
shows me my data set
and if you would be interested only in
particular column
then your d player also allows you to
either we can do a filter or we can
simply do a select
now for selecting we can choose
our data so for example i'll say df
underscore
i'm interested in mileage i'm interested
in horsepower
might be i'm interested in
your cylinders in this
and for this one what i can do is when i
would want to do a select
i can basically say
selected df
let's call it some name
i can say
control shift m
which is for piping
and then basically what you can do is
you can do a select
and you can choose your columns so i was
interested in mileage i was interested
in
horsepower
i was interested in cylinder and here
what i'm doing is i'm using a select
where i can look at the new data frame
so let's do this
and
i'm sorry here we will have to give it
df
this is where
you are passing in your data
yeah now this one is done and we can
look at the value of this one by just
doing a df
or
head
on df
underscore
mileage horsepower cylinder and look at
the selected result so you can be
looking at selective columns i could
have done this filter but filter will
always look for
a condition say your mileage is greater
than 20 or might be your cylinders are
more than four
or something else but when you do a
select you are selecting specific
columns
so view always gives you all the columns
head gives you highlight but then select
can be useful when we are interested in
looking at only specific data so this is
how you can use the player for
manipulation
for your data transformation for
basically filtering out the data
by selecting particular data and then
working on it so similarly there is one
more package called tidr and we'll see
how we can use data manipulation
done using your tidr package
let's
learn about that idr package it makes it
easy to tidy your data
and this basically helps you creating a
more cleaner data
so
which is easy to visualize and model now
this comes with mainly four functions so
you have gather which makes
your data wide or it makes white data
longer so that is basically used to
stack up multiple columns
you have spread function which makes
long data wider that is stacking the
data together or stack
if you would want to unstack the data to
data
and you are talking about data which has
same attributes
and then your spread can spread the data
across multiple columns
you have separate which is function
which splits single column into multiple
columns
and to complement that you have one more
function which is unite and that
combines multiple columns into single
columns so these are four main functions
which are used in your idr package so
let's look how we work with this
so let me bring up my r studio here now
for this first is let me just clean up
my screen here doing a control l
so i will install the package it is
already installed but we can just do a
control enter
and then
i can say do you want to restart r prior
to reinstall store install i'll say ok
and it is basically going to get the
package
now it says packaged id ti dyr that is
idr's has been successfully unpacked
let's use that package with using our
library function
and that was built under our version 3.6
now i can basically
start using these functions so for
example here we are creating a data
frame so let's say n is 10
and then we basically would say
we will call it white
now that's the variable name i'm using
the data.frame function
i'm saying id which will be
1 to n so that will take the values from
1 to 10 and then these are the values
which have
10 entries so this is a vector phase 1
phase 2 phase 3 let's create a data
frame out of it now that's done we can
have a look at our data frame by just
doing a view wide and that shows me the
id column and it has face dot one faced
or two and face dot three now we can use
our function so for example we can work
with gather that is reshaping the data
from wide format to long format and
basically you can say stacking up
multiple columns
so let's see how we do that here i'll
call it long i'm working on white i'm
using the piping functionality and then
i'm using gather so this one i will say
what will be the data which i will use
so we are using wide as a data frame
then i am saying response time so that
will be basically
one more column and then you have your
columns which you would want to
basically stack so i'm saying from phase
one to phase three so let's do this
and once this is done let's have a look
at our variable long so this one shows
me that i have an id column
i have the response time column and i
have the face column which we mentioned
and that basically has all the values
stacked in so you have face dot one
phase dot two and face dot three so if
all the columns are being stacked here
so all my data so now i have totally 30
entries in this one so this is basically
using your gather function now sometimes
we may want to use
a separate function now separate
function is basically splitting a single
column
into multiple columns so which we
would want to use when multiple
variables are captured in a single
variable column okay so let's look at an
example of this one so let's say long
separate that's what we will call we
will work on this long which has all the
data stacked in
as the columns we selected then i'm
saying separate i want the face column
and then i would say when i separate the
columns what are my column names now i
could also give a separator by giving a
comma and then mentioning the separator
if that is required so let's do this
now once this is done let's have a look
at our long separate so what we see here
is the
column which we used so we were doing a
face column and that was to be
split and we wanted to split it into
target and number so that's what we see
here so you have face being split into
target and number and then you have the
response time so this is how you use the
separate function now there is also
something called as unite function which
is basically a complementing of separate
function so it takes multiple columns
and combines the elements to a single
column so for example here
we will
call it long unite
and we will take long separate which was
separating the data we want to unite so
we will take phase target
number
and we want to have a separator between
them so let's basically do this
and now let's look at the result of this
unite
so you see you have the face and target
merged together so you have face dot one
the separator is dot as we have
mentioned and we have united multiple
columns
so
this is one more function of your tie dr
which helps you
basically
tidy up your data or put it in a
particular way
now then you have your spread function
and this is basically for unstacking so
that is
if you have if you would want to convert
a stack to data or if you want to
unstack the data which is of same
attributes spread can be used so that
you can spread the data across multiple
columns so it will take two columns say
key and value and spread it into
multiple columns so it makes long data
wider so we can look at this one we will
say long unite
i'm using the piping i will use the
spread function i'll work on the face
column and response time and let's do
this and then let's do a view on this
so it tells me our data is back in the
shape as it was in the beginning so
these are four functions
which are very helpful when we work with
tidr package
so let's learn about visualization
and here we will learn about
r
which can be used for your visualization
now one thing which we need to
understand is because of our ability to
see patterns which is highly developed
we
can understand
the data better if we can visualize it
so the efficient way or effective way to
understand what is in our data or what
we have understood in our data we should
or we can use graphical displays that is
your data visualization so there are
actually two types of data
visualizations so you have exploratory
data visualization which helps us to
understand the data and then you have
explanatory visualization which helps us
to share our understanding with others
so when you talk about r
r provides various tools and packages to
create data visualizations
and which can be used for both kind of
data analysis or both kind of
visualizations
so when you talk about exploratory data
and visualization the key is to keep all
the potentially relevant details
together
now the objective when we talk about
exploratory data analysis is to
help you see what is in your data
and the main question is how much
details can
we interpret
now when you talk about different
functions which we see here such as plot
which is more for a generic
plotting you have bar plot which is used
to plot data using rectangular bars so
you can say creating bar charts you have
histogram or hist function to create
histograms where you look at the
frequency
of
the data or basically used to look at
the central tendency of the data you
have box plot which is used to represent
data in the form of quartiles you have
gg plot which is a package which enables
the user to create sophisticated
visualizations with the little code
using the grammar of graphics
and then you have plot lee or plot l y
it creates interactive
web-based graphs via the open source
javascript graphing library now before
we see some examples here let's also
talk about when you talk about plotting
let's also try to understand what kind
of
plots you can have and what kind of
techniques you have so let me open up my
r studio here
now for example i can pull out a
particular data set
and let's look at this one so
here i can look at
all the panes and that shows me the
information now what i can do is i can
install
and get the inbuilt data sets and then i
can simply do a plot
wherein i am doing a plot on jquery data
set so let's see what does that show it
summarizes the relationship between four
variables in chick-weight data frame
which is
in our's built-in data set package
now from these plots we can see for
example weight
varies systematically over time
you can also see that chicks were
assigned to four different diets
now when we talk about explanatory data
analysis
or visualization that shows others what
we found in the data this means we need
to make some editorial decisions
what features we would want to highlight
for emphasis
what features are distracting or
confusing and you want them to be
eliminated
right so there are different ways of
doing it now when you talk about your
graphics or visualizations you have
i would say
three different types or you can say
four so you have the base graphics which
is easiest to learn now here we are
having an example of base graphics
where i can use the base graphics
i can get a
data set using library
then i can simply create using plot
function to
a generate a simple scatter plot of
calories with sugar from u.s serial data
frame in the mass package
and then i can give it a title so this
is basically a simple example of base
graphics now you also have what we call
as grid graphics which is powerful set
of modules for building other tools
now you also have latest graphics which
is general purpose system based on grid
graphics and then you have your gg plot
2 which implements grammar of graphics
and is based on grid graphics so you
have different ways now here since i
already have used library and i have the
data set i can just do a x so i can
assign the
sugar related values to x and calories
related value to y
then i can use one more which is
library function and calling in grid now
i can basically use functions such as
push view port if i would want to create
a plot using your grid graphics to
create the similar kind of plot which we
created using base graphics but this
will give you much more
power than base graphics
it will have a steep learning curve but
it is usually useful so i can do this
where i'm saying push view port
then i can basically say i would want to
have a data viewport
i would say different functions of your
grid package so i'm saying rectangle you
have x axis y axis given some points
here
and then basically you can add details
to the graph by giving the names to the
columns and you can
basically create a simple grid graphics
based plot here
now
there are different other options which
we can use to create plots now before we
go into understanding how you create
plots let me just give you a brief on
what are the different kind of plots and
how they can be used so here we will
look at these different plots now for
example
we have a bar chart which is a graph
which shows comparisons across
discrete categories
so you have x axis which will show the
categories being compared and y-axis
which represents a measured value and
height of the bars are proportional to
measured values
now
to create different kind of charts you
can use ggplot which is a package for
creating graphs in r
it is basically a method of thinking
about and decomposing complex graphs
into logical subunits
and that is a part of tidy words echo
system so it takes each component of
graph accesses you can give scales you
can give colors you can give the objects
and you can build graphs on particular
data you can modify each of those
components in a way that's more flexible
and user friendly you can if you are not
providing details for the components
then ggplot will use sensible defaults
and this basically makes it a powerful
and flexible tool now here are
different options when you use your gg
plot such as you can use geom or what we
call as geometric objects to form the
basis of different type of graphs for
bar charts you have for line graphs you
have scatter plots that is underscore
point you have underscore box plot for
box plots you have quartile for
continuous x violin for richer display
of distribution and jitter for small
data so here is some simple example
where i would not go into too many
details here but you can just have a
look at this one where we are
using library function to get the
ggplot2 package
then basically we would want to look
into the mileage data we would want to
look at the structure of it
and then we can basically get the tidy
words package finally we can create a
bar chart
using geo underscore bar and we can
basically also mention what would be in
x-axis now you can also give different
colors to basically add more meaning to
your data
you could also go for stacked bar charts
so here we are actually
telling ggplot to map the data in the
drive column to fill the aesthetic so
here i am giving
aesthetic access class
and i am saying what is the data we need
to have and then we are using geom
underscore bar
so you can also have dodged bar
in your gg plot that is not bar charts
which are stacked but next to each other
and you can create that by using
your position as position underscore
dodge
okay now you can obviously use your
different packages which are inbuilt and
you can create your bar charts
and you have other kind of graphs such
as line graph which is basically a type
of graph that displays information as a
series of data points connected by
straight line segments such as this one
and for this one we are using if you see
geom underscore line
now you can also create a scatter plot
which is a two dimensional
data visualization that uses points
to graph the values of two different
variables one in an x axis one on y axis
like what we saw in base graphics
example
and they are mainly used if you would
want to assess the relationship or lack
of relationship between two variables
and you also have histogram which i
mentioned is mainly to look at the
distribution of a data to look at the
central tendency of the data
basically looking at
your
large amount of data or for a single
variable
you would be interested in saying where
is
more data found in terms of frequency
where is lesser data found in the graph
how close the data is towards its
mid point or what we call as mean median
mode
so
you can use histogram where you can
categorize the data in what we call as
bins so these are some basics on
different kind of graphs now we can look
at some examples and see how that works
so what we were seeing is some quick
examples of base graphics or grid
graphics now here
let's do
an example of pie chart for different
products and units sold so you want to
create a graph for this first let's
create a vector and pass in the value
here
now i can also create labels which i
would want to assign to these values
and then basically i can plot the chart
by saying pi so that's the kind of chart
which i would want to create
and i would say the data would be x
and labels
so let's do this and that shows me a
simple pie chart now i can also give
main details here so instead of just
doing a pi x comma labels i can say what
is the main and then
what kind of coloring it should follow
so this is the way you can create a
simple
plot now i can also find out what is the
percentage
and then basically
i would be interested in plotting the
pie chart which takes x
which takes the labels which will be the
percentage which we are calculating here
by doing a round function
and then you can basically give details
to your
graph you can say what color it follows
you can basically look at the legend
where it needs to be
in your chart
what are the values
and then basically fill up the colors so
let's run this one and that shows me the
percentage which was calculated and it
gives me the details
and we can always have a look at our
plot now if you would want to go for a
3d pie chart then
you can get the package which is plotrix
let's use that by calling in the library
function let's pass in some data to x
and let's give some values or labels
which will make more meaning to the data
and then let's plot the 3d graph so i'm
saying pi 3d here where i'm using x and
labels
then i'm basically doing an explode
which will basically control how your
graph looks like
and basically give the values so it also
takes the title when you say main and by
chart of countries
now let's create
data for graph so again we are having a
variable here we are create using the c
function creating a vector
and then let's create a histogram for
this one
where i would say x-lab what would be
your data around x-axis what is the
color what is the border and here i am
creating a simple histogram
which as i discussed earlier will always
show your values on the x-axis and
y-axis is more of frequency
and then you can look at the set of
values and what is their frequency
and we can basically use this histogram
for exploratory data analysis look at
the data try to understand what is the
central tendency of your data values
now we can also give some limits by
using the x limb and y limb and then i
can also specify what is the limit so we
have given some values here
wherein we have said your x limit is 0
to 40
and y limit is 0 to 5. now if you
compare this with the previous one which
we had created this one based on the
frequency had taken the limits but we
can assign limits
explicitly by giving this and then
create a histogram which makes more
meaning
now let's take another data set that is
air quality let's view this to see what
does that data contain so you have
ozone solar wind temperature month and
the day so this is the kind of
information we have in the air quality
now let's use the plot function to draw
a scatter plot where as i mentioned you
would be interested in analyzing
variables
and see
what is the relationship between them so
to plot a graph between ozone and wind
values
so we will say plot we will say the data
which is air quality from that i would
be interested in the ozone column or
ozone field and the wind field i can
create a plot based on this
now i can also be saying what should be
the color what is the type of the data
which you would want to create and you
can look at the info information so you
can create a histogram you can create a
scatter plot to basically understand the
data better and then infer some
information from that data so let's take
the air quality data set itself without
specifying any particular column and you
can create a plot which shows me
all the different values which you have
in the data
and it basically shows you the
difference this is more of an example
like what we did for chickweight where
we did a base graphics now you can
assign labels to the plot so that is
when you are creating a plot you can say
air quality you will say ozone
and then that's your ozone concentration
you have your y lab which is the number
of instances
you have what is the title ozone levels
in new york city what is the color so
these are the details what we have given
with our plot function and let's look at
the data so it just tells me that this
is the ozone concentration
uh the number of instances what you have
and you are looking at the data now we
could also create a histogram by picking
up a particular column that is such as
solar
from your air quality and that basically
shows me the frequency
of solar values and we can then try to
find out what is the mid
what is the mean what is the standard
deviation and so on you can also look at
your histogram and try to understand if
it is left skewed and right skewed
so we can do that
now here let's get the temperature out
from this particular data set
let's create a histogram on temperature
and that basically shows me the
frequency of the temperature values
and
what values have the most frequency or
most occurrence
now you can create a histogram
with
labels
so let's do that with the limit
and then let's also use text to
basically given the values which also
takes the values and for each set of
frequency or each set of values it gives
me the labels now you can have a
histogram with non-uniform width so you
could do that by doing a hist function
and then
passing in your temperature you can say
what will be the main what is the title
what will be your x lab
it will tell you a limit around x axis
what is the color what is the border
what are the breaks you would want to
have
for your bars and you can simply create
a histogram using this so this basically
takes the breaks which we have given
such as 55 to 60
60 to 70 70 to 75 and so on so this is
basically creating a histogram with
non-uniform width
and it purely depends on the kind of
values what you have
now you can also create a box plot which
sometimes helps us in understanding the
the data quartiles also understanding
our outliers so you can create multiple
box plots based on the data from air
quality so we'll select all the data and
then we'll do some slicing on the data
so let's create a box plot which tells
me the values and if you look at these
points here
like single dots these are basically
your outliers
we can learn about that more
in later sections
so you can use
your gg plot 2 library to analyze
a particular data set so for that we
will first
use the install dot packages and get
ggplot2
so it says do you want to restart r and
i can say yes so let it get the package
i think the package was already there
and now
let's look at
using ggplot2 so for that i have the
library function
and let's do a attach where i'm getting
a data set which is empty cars
now
then i will create a variable p1 i will
use ggplot i will pass in my data i'll
give the aesthetics
what is the columns which you would be
interested in
and then you are using geom underscore
box plot to basically create a plot
which gives me the box plot for the
values here and this is based on
the cylinders which is there in your
data
so we can always look at what does our
data contain
and what kind of values or features are
available in the data now let's create a
box plot we will also use the coordinate
function and that basically gives me
based on the data so i've changed the
coordinates now if you look at the
previous one where we created a plot we
had mileage on the y-axis and cylinders
on the x-axis
now i did a coordinate flip and that's
like your transpose function so you have
created the box plot but you have just
flipped the coordinates you can create a
box plot and then say fill
which is the factor of cylinder
so that can be used to fill up the
values in your box plot
now what we can also do is we can create
factors so we have learnt about factors
earlier which is usually used to work on
categorical variables
so here let's create a factor
which is empty cars gear you have am you
have cylinder and if you look at the
factors which we have created we have
passed our data
what is the field or the column we are
interested in what is the level of
values there and what are the labels for
those values right so we have learnt
about factors
you can always look into the previous
section and learn more about factors
now let's create
a scatter plot by using the ggplot
function again we will use the data as
empty cars i will go for mapping option
and then i will give my aesthetics that
is what would be x what would be your y
and you also would want to use what kind
of
function you are using so let's go for
geom pawn point and that basically helps
me in creating a scatter plot now you
can create a scatter plot by factors
so here we will say gg plot so notice in
all of these cases depending on the kind
of data you have
depending on the kind of plot you are
interested in you will use the gg plot
and then basically a function with that
or the inbuilt package so here i'm
saying data is empty cars i am going for
mapping which basically will take the
values for your x and y
what is the color and the coloring will
be done based on the factor values now
if you remember factors will obviously
have some levels and
those levels will basically help you in
differentiating between your categorical
variables so i am saying as dot factor
on cylinder and then i am using geom
point to basically create this scatter
plot so let's do this
and
i can
look at the values of this one so it
says
must be there is an error which says
must at least one color from the hue
palette so let's look at that one so the
error which we were facing when we gave
color as the factor values was because
when you look at these factors which
were created with some labels if we look
at the values of these it tells me there
are any values in that particular column
similarly your gear or similarly you can
completely look at the complete data set
it tells me cylinder you have am you
have care now these have some
we have created some labels but these
have n a values
so what we can do is we can create a
scatter plot as we did earlier by giving
the aesthetics and that's a simple
scatter plot
wherein i'm also using geom point so
that i can have these points by defaults
or with defaults
you can also
give a color specific basically if you
would want to have different kind of
data in the same plot or i can create
scatter plots by different sizes by
giving a size or i can give a color and
size and that's again one way in which
you can create your scatter plots now
let's also see how you can visualize
one more data set which is mpg
so i can also do it in this way where i
said ggplot2
and then pass and look at the data set
what we have here
you can just do a view on this to see
what my data contains if the fields have
any any values if that's going to affect
your plotting so now what we can do is
we can create a bar plot or a bar chart
so i'm saying gg plot the data would be
as we have given in previous lines that
is ggplot2 mpg then i will
say what should be in my aesthetics and
what kind of
chart are you going to create so i'm
saying gm underscore bar so that's my
bar chart and that has basically your
class and count now you can create a
stacked bar chart where your information
is stacked
in the same bars
and we are still using the same data
we are going for aesthetics which is
class
and then when you say geom bar which
creates your stack bar we will use fill
which is drive
and we can always go back and look at
our data for example
you can always look into this so you
have the drive column here
and you are also working on this
complete data set
so let's go ahead and create a stacked
bar chart and that basically gives me
the information where you have the drive
information which is stacked
here now you can do a dodge by giving
the position as dodge
so we are still going to go for a stack
chart but this time the bars will be
next to each other and that can also be
done which is very useful
you can use this by using geom point
where you are mapping and you are
specifying what are your aesthetics so
we were creating a scatter plot
now you can also use
or give more details where you can say
color can be based on the class
and we have different classes and based
on that my points have been colored
now you can also use a plot
ly or plotly library so let's install
this one
i will say yes for example let it
basically restart so that all my
packages are updated
then i can access that package using
library function
and then
create a variable to which you are
assigning your plot underscore ly plot
so data is empty cars what will be your
x-axis what will be your y-axis and
details on your marker which we have
given
wherein i will give a list which is size
color which is a combination
and then you have your line
what kind of color it will have and what
will be the width so this is where i'm
going to use plot ly
and let's look at this plot
so it basically gives me some
information now we see some warnings
which are getting generated but there is
you don't need to worry about that so
you can look at the packages what you
have
and what options you are using so
similarly we can create one more plot
using plot ly and look at the values of
those so that's a plot with a trend
which explains me about my data
so this is a simple small tutorial on
understanding or
how you can have your graphics or
visualization
used to understand your data obviously
there are much more examples
much more ways in which you can pass
into your plot functions
or your gg plot
and the inbuilt
packages which are available in r for
your visualization now that could be for
exploratory data analysis or explanatory
data analysis so try these graphs and
see if
you can change these options and try or
create new visualizations linear
regression in r my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
that's
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead what's in it for you we'll start
with covering why linear regression what
is linear regression how linear
regression works and then finally we'll
dive into the use case predicting the
revenue using linear regression and
we'll be in the r platform for this
today let's dive into why linear
regression now that we have come this
far i'm planning to take a closer look
at our cells so that we can estimate
cells in the future how about we hire a
data scientist you can see our two uh
corporate individuals looks more like
they should be agents or secret agents
some place discussing how to better
forward their company and so they're
going to come in and ask the data
scientist to come in good idea this will
help us to keep a constant track of our
cells so why do we need linear
regression let's assume that we need to
predict the number of skiers based on
snowfall so this happens to be we've
kind of jumped one business to the next
so we're looking at the skiing business
very popular in a lot of areas and it's
based on snowfall a lot of times you
figure you don't have snow you don't
have skiers but can we actually use
something more specific instead of look
at snowing and instead of saying hey
look it's snowing we can actually start
drawing graphs and the graph shows that
with an increase in snowfall the
frequency of skiers also increases so
and there's a pretty direct correlation
if you've ever been up to ski areas when
there's a lot of snowfalls the skiers
all show up because they know it's going
to be better skiing right afterwards so
it's kind of easy to see why skiers and
snowfall would go together and usually
draws a nice straight line and you can
easily predict how many skiers and that
way you can also predict how many people
you need to service them how many lifts
they have up and running and all the
stuff that goes with running a ski area
thus we see that the number of skiers
are directly proportional to the amount
of snowfall regression models a relation
between a dependent y and an independent
x variable this is real important to
understand regression because when we
talk about linear regression it's the
basis of almost all our machine learning
algorithms out there and it's usually an
underlying part of the math in our deep
learning so it all starts here with
linear regression and we talk about a
dependent y and an independent x
variable these are numbers we're usually
talking about floats so we want to have
an actual number value coming out and
that's different than something that's
categorical or we want to know yes or no
true false so regression means we're
looking for a number the independent
variable is known as predictor variable
and dependent variable is known as the
response variable so we have one
predictor variable the amount of
snowfall and one response variable how
many skewers are going to show up and
then we can take this relationship and
it can be expressed as y equals beta
we're going to use the greek
letter beta and we have beta naught plus
beta 1 x 1 and if you continue out it'd
be plus beta 2 x 2 and so on till the
nth degree in this case snowfall is an
independent variable and skiers is a
dependent variable so we kind of have a
little quick overview let's go ahead and
talk a little bit more about what is
linear regression so we're going to go
from y predicting a number of skiers for
snowfall and we've looked at the formula
a little bit but let's look closer at
what exactly is going on with linear
regression and the question is going to
come up in an interview what is linear
regression linear regression is a type
of statistical analysis that attempts to
show the relationship between two
variables linear regression creates a
predictive model on any data showing
trends in data the model is found by
using the least square method there are
other methods the least square method
happens to be the most commonly used out
there and we usually start with the
least square method since it's the most
common and usually works the best on
most models and we're already looking at
how linear regression works but let's
dig deeper into it and let's take a
closer look how linear regression works
i will provide you with a data set which
has rent area other information in it
looks like our secret agents have uh put
on their casual wear for this one you
need to predict rent accordingly we are
given area and rent here so you can do
linear regression with more variables
but we're just going to look at the area
and then from that try to figure out
what the rent should be we plot the
graph and if you look at it here you can
see that the graph kind of a linear
pattern with a little dip in it so the
area seems the rent seems to be based on
the area in most of our work as data
scientists we usually try to start with
a physical graph if we can so we can
actually look at and say hey does what
i'm fitting to this graph look right you
can solve a lot of problems that arise
by looking at the graph and saying no
that doesn't look right at all or oh i
should be looking over here for this
then we find the mean of area and rent
so the mean just means average and if
you take one two three four five and add
them all together and divide by in this
case there's five areas you get three
and the rent is two four six five and
eight if you add them all together and
divide by five you get five and we plot
the mean on the graph so you can see
right here here's the mean of the rent
and the area it's kind of a very central
point which is what we're looking for
the average of everything in there the
best fit line passes through the mean
this is real important when you're
eyeballing it as humans we can do this
fairly easy if it's a straight line
through a bunch of data it gets more
complicated mathematically when you
start adding multiple variables and
instead of a line you have a curve but
for basic linear regression we're going
to draw a line through the data and the
lines should go through the means that's
going to be part of the best fit for
that line but we see there are multiple
lines that can pass through the means so
depending on how you look at it you can
kind of wiggle the line around back and
forth so we keep moving the line to
ensure that the best fit line has the
least square distance from the data
points and this is you can see right
here residual we have our data point and
then we look at this distance between
them and we square that distance and
that's what they mean by the least
squared distance we want all those
distances to add up to the smallest
amount we can when we talk about that
distance we call it the residual it
equals the y actual minus the y
predicted very straightforward we're
just looking at the distance you can
accidentally switch these and it'll come
out the same because we're going to
square it but when you're working with
other sets of linear regression you want
to make sure you do the y actual minus
the y predicted the value of m and c for
the best fit line
y equals mx plus c can be calculated
using the mentioned formula and you can
see here we have m equals the number of
points that's what n stands for then we
have the sigma the greek symbol is there
which is a summation of x times y minus
the summation of x times the summation
of y over the number of the summation of
x squared minus the summation of x
squared of x all of it squared
that can be a little confusing trying to
say that and then of course your c value
is going to be the summation of y times
the summation of x squared minus the
summation of x times the summation of x
times y over the total count of the
summation x squared minus the summation
of x squared that's a mouthful normally
we don't worry too much about these
formulas other than to know they're
there now if you're a mathematician you
might go back in there and work on those
and those people who originally started
to put together the different models in
r of course had to know all this math to
build them and had to test it out that's
one of the nice things about r what is
important is that you know about these
formulas so that you know where it's
coming from so if you're using one
linear regression model this is how this
one works there's other linear
regression models based on different
math and so you'd have to be aware when
that math changes and how that changes
the model we find the corresponding
values so in this case if you're going
to break this up and you're building
your own model instead of using the one
in r you would have your rent you would
have your area you would find your rent
squared your area squared and your rent
times area and if we go back one we can
see that that's all the different little
pieces in this model we have x times y
we have x squared we have the sum of x
which is going to be squared we have the
sum of x the sum of y this is the same
these are all the little pieces in here
that we see for m equals and c equals
and so once we compute all these we have
15 25 55 145 88 very easy to do on a
computer thankfully you could have
millions of these points and it would do
it in a very short period we can then
plug in those values very easily into
this formula and get a final answer and
we'll see that m equals 1.3 and c equals
1.1 and then when we take this for the y
predicted equals m of i x of i plus c we
can take these and actually run the data
we have so we're going to see how it
predicts so now we find the y the value
of y predicted so we have our x in and
we want to know what y what we think y
will be based on our formula we
generated the linear regression formula
and so we come in here we have our x we
have our actual y then we have our y
predict what we think it's going to be
and then we have we take y minus y
predict and we get those values minus
0.4 it's off by 0.3 this one's off by
one this one's on off by minus 1.3 by
0.4 and we go ahead and square that and
then we can sum that square and average
it out and we'll get a value this is
just a summation down here of y minus y
predicted square is 3.1 and we call that
the least square value for this line is
3.1 and we go ahead and divide that by
5. so when we plot the y predict and
this is the best fit line and you can
see that it does a pretty good job going
right through the middle of lines and
it's something like rent versus area if
you're trying to figure out how much
rent to charge or how many people are
allowed to be in the area that's going
to work but if you're looking for the
rent value compared to the area this
gives you a good idea based on the area
of what you should rent the place for
it's close enough that in the business
world this would work you're not
computing something down to the
millimeters or micrometers or nuclear
physics we're just charging people and
so if you're off by a couple dollars
it's not a big deal you'll be pretty
close to what you think it's worth and
get the right value for your property
use case predicting the revenue using
linear regression now that you have a
good idea of how linear regression works
and we're kicking back on our lounging
sofa today let's work on a real life
scenario where you have to predict the
revenue so we're going to take a data
set and we'll pull this up in just a
minute we'll have paid organic social
and revenue there are three attributes
we'll be working on the first one is our
paid traffic so all the traffic through
the advertisement that comes in the
non-paid traffic from search engines so
these are people coming to the website
and are doing so because they did a
search for something specific so it's
pulling it from your website all the
traffic coming from social networking
sites so we want to know what's coming
from twitter and facebook and somehow
they've linked into your website and
coming into your marketing area to buy
something and we'll use this to predict
the revenue so we want to know how all
this traffic comes together and how it's
going to affect our cells if the
traffic's coming in we're going to make
use of the multiple linear regression
model so you'll see that this is very
similar that we had before where we had
y equals m times x plus c but instead we
have y equals m1 x1 plus m2 x2 plus m3
x3 plus c m is the slope so you have m1
m2 m3 the three different slopes of
three different lines y is the revenue
so we're only looking for one variable
and remember this is regression so we're
looking for a number x1 is going to be
the pay traffic and of course m1 the
corresponding slope x2 the organic
traffic and x3 the social traffic we
will follow these steps to create the
regression model we'll start by
generating inputs using the csv files
we'll then import the libraries
splitting the data into train and test
very important whenever you're doing any
kind of data science applying regression
on paid traffic organic traffic social
traffic so we're going to apply a
regression model on them and then we're
going to validate the model that's the
whole reason we split it to a training
and testing is so we can now validate to
see just how good our model is now
before we open up r i always like to
just take a quick look at the data
itself and we're using the rev.csv file
and this is a dot cs file or comma
separated variable file we'll just open
that with wordpad any kind of text
editor would be nice to show you what's
going on and you can see we have paid
organic social and revenue across the
top says your titles for your columns
and the values going down and this is
the same as what we saw on the slide
just a minute ago paid organic social
and then revenue from them they probably
have it in more of a spreadsheet than
just a word pad and i'm using the newer
version of rstudio which already has a
nice layout automatically opens up with
your console terminal window down and
left you have your script and we'll run
it in script and then when i run it line
by line in script you'll see it show up
on the console bottom left i could type
it straight into the console and it
would do the same thing and then on the
right we have our environment and under
the environment we'll see plots if
you're in an older version the plots
will pop up and you usually are running
just in the console and then you have to
open up a different window to run the
script and you can run the script from
there this opens up everything at the
same time when you use the new rstudio
setup and the first thing we want to do
is we want to go ahead and generate a
variable we'll call it cells and we want
to load this with our data set and so
in r we use the less than minus sign
that's the same as assigned to it's like
an arrow pointing at cells it says
whatever it goes past here is going to
be assigned to cells and we want to read
in our csv file and then i went ahead
and fixed the csv file up a little bit
when i say the csv file i mean the path
to it
and we'll go ahead and just paste that
in there and this is my edited version
and you'll see i took wherever we had
the
backward slash i switched it for a
forward slash because a backward slash
is an escape character and whenever
you're programming in just about any
scripting language you want to do the
forward slash instead so like a good
chef i prepped this and copied it into
my clipboard and we can see the full
path here and the full path ends in our
rev.csv files that's the path on my
machine and then i'm going to run that
and now we have down here you see it
appear right here oh must have an error
in my path it says object rev not found
let me fix that real quick
and run it again and this time it does
assign the cells the data set and then
we'll just type in cells and this is the
same as printing it so if you work in
other languages you'll do like print and
then sales or maybe print sales dot head
if you're in pandas in python or
something like that but in r you just
type in the variable we'll run this and
you can see it printed out all those
columns so that's the same thing we just
looked at and it says max print so it
emitted 750 rows so it has a total of a
thousand rows and we can scroll up here
on our console where the answer came in
and if i scroll to the top
way up to the top there we go you'll see
paid organic social and revenue so
everything looks good on this and
there's a lot of cool things we can do
with it one of the things we can do is i
can summary it so let's do a summary of
cells and we'll run that and the summary
of cells comes in it tells you your min
first quarter median mean third quarter
max for paid organic social breaks it up
and you can actually get kind of a quick
view as to what the data is doing you
can take more time to study this a lot
of people look at this and you can see
from the median the mean that tells you
a lot and is divided into quarters so
you have your first quarter value and
your third quarter set up on there and
max it just gives you a quick idea
what's going on in the data summary is a
really wonderful tool one of the reasons
i like to jump into
r before i might do a major project in
something else or you can run everything
enough and let's take a look at the head
head of cells and let me run this and
you can see it shows the head of our
data the first six rows in this case and
it starts with one important to know
other different systems start with zero
and go up r is one that starts with the
first is one and then if we want to do a
plot i'll go ahead and do a plot cells
another really powerful tool that you
can just jump right into with r once you
have your data in here and you'll see
that the plot comes over on the right
hand side and what it does is it
compares them so if i look at my paid
and my organic and you cross the two
you'll see there's a nice line down the
middle big black line where it plots the
two together let me just widen this a
little bit so we can see more of it
there we go same thing with paid and
social paid and revenue so each one of
these has a clear connection to each
other so that's a good sign we have a
nice correlation between the data and
you can just eyeball that that's a good
way to jump in and explore your data
rather quickly and see what's going on
so we'll go ahead and i'll put a pound
sign there
hashtag and uh splitting the data into
training and test data and we want to
split it so that we have something to
work with to train our data set and when
we do our data set you do this with any
data set because you want to make sure
you have a good model and then once
we've trained it we're going to take the
other set of data we pulled off to the
side and we'll test it to see how good
it is if you test it with the training
data that's already got that memorized
and should give you a really good answer
in fact when you get into more advanced
machine learning tools you watch those
very closely you watch your training set
and how it does versus your testing set
and if your training set starts doing
better than your testing set then you're
starting to over train it now that's
more with deep learning and some other
packages that are beyond what we're
working with today but yeah this is
important it's very important to
understand that that test and that
training correlate with each other gives
you an idea what's going on and make
sure that you're set up correctly and
we'll go ahead and set a seed of two and
that's for our random generators so that
when we run them you can see them with
just a rat there's ways to randomize a
number you could do like date and stuff
like that but that way we always use the
same random numbers so we'll seat it
with two and then we're gonna need a
library in this case we're gonna import
the library and we want to import ca
tools and ca tools has our split
function so we're going to be able to
split our data along with many other
tools we're going to need for this
example so they're all built into the ca
tools that's why we need to import that
a lot of times they call them library or
sometimes you can refer to as packages
so let's go ahead and run that line and
that brings the library in so now we can
use all those different tools that are
in there and then i'm going to do a
split and we're going to assign to the
split that's going to be our variable
sample split okay so that's one of the
tools we just brought in is to sample as
the actual keyword or the function word
sample.split and we're going to take our
cells and we're going to go ahead and
split ratio equals to 0.7 and let's do
0.7 so we make sure it knows it's a
decimal point or float and what this is
saying is that we're going to take our
cells data the variable we created
called cells that has the data in there
and i want to split it and i'm going to
split it so that 70 of it goes in one
side we'll use that for training and 30
will go into the other side which we'll
use then for testing out our model let
me go ahead and run that and let's hold
on one second got an error there spit is
definitely very different than split i
don't think we want to spit our data out
we which is actually kind of what we're
doing is spitting it out but we want to
split we want to split the data let me
get that spelled correctly and then when
i type in split we can just run that
because that's now a variable you'll see
that it has true false false true so it
generates a number of interesting
different statistics going across there
as far as the way it splits the data and
right here if you have not used r in a
while or if you're new to r completely
that line one that's what the little one
means down there and then true false
false true that means that's how we're
looking at the data we're splitting all
those different pieces of data in line
one different directions and so we now
want to create our train set and we're
going to assign that and when we take it
and we assign to the train set a subset
of cells and then the subset of cells
that's going to be based on split equal
and put this in brackets true so you can
see the values down here is capital t
capital r capital u capital e so i just
want to reflect that on the train and
this is going to take everything where
our split variable is equal to true and
it's going to set cells equal to that
and we'll go ahead and run that and then
we're going to set our test variable as
a subset of cells and if we assign the
true to the train set then we want to
assign the false
to our test set so now we'll have this
will have 30 of the variables in it and
train will have 70 percent we'll go
ahead and run that so we've now created
both our training set and our test set
and we can just real quickly type in
train hit the run on there and you can
see our train set if we scroll way up to
the top we'll have the column names on
there which should match what we had
before paid organic social and revenue
and then we'll type in test when i hit
run on there that's going to do the same
thing it'll spread out all the test
variables going out so now that we have
the test and train variables we want to
go ahead and create the model and you'll
see this in any of the machine learning
tutorials they always refer to them as
models we're modeling a function of some
kind on the data to fit the data and
then we're going to put the test data
through there to see how well it does
and so we're going to create the
variable called models and i'm going to
assign that
lm that is our linear regression model i
love how simplified r makes it just lm
linear regression and then model m
um i guess it dates back because the
linear regression model is like one of
the first major models used so they kept
it easy on there and revenue happens to
be the main variable that we want to
track
so if you remember correctly from our
formula y is the revenue and then we
have x is our paid traffic x2 organic
traffic and x3 are social traffic so y
is what we want to predict in here and
then you'll see this notation where we
have our squiggle and the period which
means we're going to match up the
revenue lines with the lines of the data
we're putting in here and then i'll put
comma and then our data equals
train and of course that's the training
data that we created so when i hit the
run remember we did all the discussion
about all those different functions and
formulas to compute our model and how
that's set up when it comes down to it
we spend all our time setting up our
data and then we hit the run button on
the single line and our model's been
trained so we now have a trained model
here and we can do a summary of the
model summary is such a wonderful
command because you can do that on r
that works on all kinds of different
things on there oops and of course it
does help if i remember that my model
has a capital n when i run it and you'll
see right here it tells you a little bit
about the model use a summary on there
comes down here has our residuals this
is all the information on there as far
as like the minimum the median the max
has all our coefficients in there if you
remember correctly from our formula
let's just go ahead and switch back over
to that we have m1 x1 m2 x2 m3 x3 plus c
well that's right here here's our
intercept and then we have our different
values for each of these so we have our
intercept our paid organic and social
and then it also shows us error and
information on the error and one of the
really nice things about when you're
working with r you can come down here
and you see
where we have our stars down here and it
says uh three stars really good two
stars maybe one star probably no
correlation and we can see with all of
these it has three stars on them so out
of three stars we get three stars on all
these there's no four stars four stars
would mean that you have the exact same
data going in is coming out and then if
we're going to do this we want to
actually run a prediction on here and
that's what we saved our test data for
so let's come down here we'll do our
prediction we'll take this variable and
we'll assign it predict
model remember the predict comes from
when we imported that package the ca
tools that's all part of the ca tools in
there so we're going to predict we're
going to use the model and then we're
going to use our test data pretty
straightforward quick and easy we'll run
this and then if we go ahead and type in
the predict it'll print out what's in
that variable and you'll see down here
the predicted values expects to come out
it's going to say our revenue is and it
goes through and it gives it both the
line number and the actual revenue value
so that's quick and easy boy we got a
prediction really fast and this is also
how you would do it if you had new data
coming in after this you could predict
the revenue based on these other factors
so now that we have a training model
which or we train the data with our
training data or we trained the model
with our training data and we've done a
prediction on our model with our test
data we want to look this up and we took
a quick glance from our training thing
our training said it trained really well
but that's not the final word on it the
final word is going to be comparing it
so we want to go ahead and do comparing
predicted versus actual values what i'm
going to do is i'm going to do a plot
and i'm going to do our test and we're
going to do test
revenue dot type equals and we can put
this in as a type
type one and then or l and then we have
lty equals 1.8 and we're going to set up
for column blue that's a lot of stuff in
there let's go ahead and just run that
so you can see what that looks like and
what's that's doing it's going to
generate this nice graph we see on the
right there's our graph you can see the
data comes up and down
we're plotting the prediction on there
so this is the values we predicted and
then let's go ahead and do
lines and i actually did this backwards
so let me try that again and we'll start
with the red one we're going to do the
first one in red and i want to start
with the actual test revenue so here's
our test revenue and we'll go ahead and
run this and so we have a red plot over
here in red go ahead and take a look at
that and pull that over you can see how
that looks goes up and down hard to
track there and then we're going to do a
couple things here we'll plot our test
revenue
and then we'll make it a little prettier
it's kind of hard to say see the way i
was crunched up here on the right as far
as size and sizing and everything but
we'll go ahead and have our columns in
blue and run our prediction on there too
you see they overlap the two graphs so
we have our test revenue and our
prediction and then finally what i
started with is we'll go ahead and plot
the prediction fully on the bottom and
run that and if you look over here on
the graph we put the blue lines over the
red lines and so you'll see a couple
spots where there's red underneath there
but for the most part our prediction is
pretty right on so it looks really tight
looks like a good set of predictions for
what we're working on and this is what
we were looking at the slide right
before we started diving into the r
studio we can see in the slide here
here's the red that's a little bit
better spread out than what i have on my
screen from my r studio and the graph
shows a predicted revenue we see that
the two lines are very close so again
they're tight it's right on this is what
we're looking for in our prediction
model but it's not good enough just
having a graph and you always do both
and the reason we do both is you want to
have a visual of it because sometimes
you look at these you get to the graph
you're like oh my gosh what is that and
then sometimes you look at the graph you
go that's right on how come my accuracy
doesn't look right and you realize that
your accuracy might be off or you're
plotting it incorrectly so let's go
ahead and look up the accuracy and we'll
use rmse that's going to be the variable
name we're going to give it and sqrt the
square root of the mean and mean just
means average and then we want
prediction minus
cells revenue and then we're going to
take this whole thing and we're going to
square it so what we've got here is
we're going to go through let's just
explain this formula we're using is i'm
going to look at the what i predicted
for to be and what the actual sales
what's our prediction versus our sales
comparison to the revenue and when we
compare those two we're going to find
the average and then i'm going or we're
going to square each one of those values
and then we're going to average the
square and then find the square root of
that and that's quite a mouthful the
reason we do it this way the reason we
square the value and then we find the
means is to generate an answer based on
doesn't matter whether it's plus or
minus there's a lot of other formulas
you can use there to check your accuracy
and all kinds of other things you can do
but a quick straightforward way of doing
is just like this and then let's go
ahead and run this
and then we type in the rmse and they'll
give us an actual printed value out
let's just see what that looks like and
so we have
866.6338 for our accuracy and so we look
at the
866.63 and we compare that to say
50 000 that's pretty close that's that's
actually a pretty good accuracy given
this model takes a little bit more when
you're playing with accuracies and start
dividing out other different aspects of
it to get something you can communicate
better with but you always start with
the square root means that's always a
good place to start hello and welcome to
logistic regression in r my name is pete
ferrari and i am with the simply learn
team and today we're going to cover
logistic regression in the r programming
language logistic regression is kind of
a misnomer in that when most people
think of regression they think of linear
regression which is a machine learning
algorithm for continuous variables
however logistic regression is a
classification algorithm not a
continuous variable prediction algorithm
logistic regression is also sometimes
called logit regression in this video we
are going to learn why we would use
regression as a predictive algorithm
what is regression the different types
of regression as i've already mentioned
some regression algorithms are
classification algorithms and some are
continuous variable algorithms why use
logistic regression what is logistic
regression and then we'll look at a use
case a college admission uh using
logistic regression so why would we use
regression well let's say we had a
website and our revenue was based on the
traffic that we could drive to that
website whether through r d or marketing
and we wanted to predict the revenue
based on site traffic and the website
traffic would be related to the revenue
we could generate the more traffic
driven to our website than the higher
our revenue or at least that's what we
would intuitively assume and so we need
to predict the revenue based on our
website traffic here we have the plot of
revenue versus website traffic traffic
would be considered the independent
variable and revenue would be the
dependent variable often the independent
variable or variables if we had more
than one could be called the explanatory
variables and the dependent variable
would be called the response variable
however we typically refer to them as
independent and dependent variables so
our intuition tells us that the
independent variable drives the
dependent variable and if there is some
relationship between the two variables
then we would say that there is a
correlation between the two variables
and then we may be able to use the
independent variable to make predictions
about the dependent variable if you look
at the chart on the right you'll see
there is a clear trend between website
traffic and revenue as website traffic
increases the revenue increases and we
could draw a line to show that
relationship and then we could use that
line as a predictor line so for example
what will revenue be if our traffic is
4.5 k we see that when the traffic is
around 4 500 the revenue is around 13
000 and if we could draw a perpendicular
line from 4.5 k on the axis on the
x-axis the traffic axis up to the orange
regression line sometimes called the
line of best fit then we could draw
another line over to the y-axis the
revenue axis and we could see where it
lands and that would be the prediction
so in this example when the traffic is
around 45
000 hits the predicted revenue is around
13 000. normally we wouldn't actually
draw those lines we would generate an
equation and we would call that equation
a model and we could plug the
independent variable into the equation
to generate the dependent variable
output which we would call our
prediction so what is regression
regression is a statistical relationship
between two or more variables where a
change in the independent variable is
associated with a change in the
dependent variable it's important to
note that all variables are related to
each other for example a person's
favorite color may not be related to
revenue from a website here the change
in one variable height is closely
associated with the change in the other
variable age this makes intuitive sense
as you get older from when you're born
you get taller and it seems to make
sense if we plot that data we would see
those green points on the graph up to
some certain age where growth would
taper off in the plot in the middle of
the screen we see the clear linear
relationship between age and height
which is indicated by the solid red line
we sometimes call that line a trend line
or a regression line or the line of best
fit and we see that the height is the
dependent variable and age is the
independent variable of course you might
ask doesn't height depend on other
factors of course it does but here we're
looking at the relationship between two
variables one independent and one
dependent age and height there are
various types of regression linear
regression logistic regression multiple
linear regression polynomial regression
and there are others decision tree
regression random forest regression but
linear regression is probably the most
well known by definition when there is a
linear relationship between a dependent
variable which is continuous and an
independent variable which is continuous
or discrete we would use linear
regression when the y value in the graph
is categorical such as yes or no two or
false they voted they did not vote they
purchased something they did not
purchase something it depends on the x
variable logistic regression is when the
y value in the graph is categorical in
nature for example yes no purchased
don't purchase voted did not vote and it
depends on the x variable notice the
trend line for linear regression and the
line for logistic regression they're
different more on that later and there's
polynomial regression as well when the
relation between the dependent variable
y and the independent variable x is in
the nth degree of x sometimes we say an
nth degree polynomial of x in this
picture you can see that the
relationship is not linear there's a
curve to that best fit trend line so why
would we use logistic regression and we
need to understand why we would use
logistic regression and that linear
regression picking the machine learning
algorithm for
your problem is no small task and it
really behooves us to understand the
difference between these machine
learning algorithms
linear regression answers the question
how much so in our earlier example if
website traffic grows then how much
would revenue grow whereas logistic
regression would answer what will happen
or not happen linear regression in
general is used to predict a continuous
variable like height and weight logistic
regression is used when a response
variable only has two outcomes yes or no
two or faults often we refer to logistic
regression as a binary classifier since
there are only two outcomes so let's try
to understand this with an example let's
say we have a startup company and we are
trying to figure out whether the startup
will be profitable or not that's binary
with two possible outcomes profitable or
not profitable and let's use initial
funding to be the independent variable
here we have a graph that shows funding
versus profit and it appears linear once
again our intuition tells us that the
more funding a startup has the more
profitable it will be but of course data
science doesn't depend on intuition it
depends on data but this graph does not
tell whether the startup will be
profitable yes or no it only states that
with an increase in funding the profit
also increases that's not binary if we
wanted to predict how much profit then
linear regression would be useful but
that's not what we are being asked hence
we need to make use of logistic
regression which has two outcomes in our
case profitable and not profitable so
let's draw a graph again the x-axis will
be our independent variable funding and
the y-axis will no longer be the
dependent variable profit but it will be
the probability of profit for example if
you look at a company with a funding of
say 40 then the probability that that
company will be profitable is around
point eight or eighty percent based on
the best fit line called a sigmoid curve
in the example we plotted several
companies some with 10 15 20 some with
50 60 or 70 or 65 and we indicated
whether they were zero not profitable or
a one profitable on the graph and this
is how we should think of logistic
regression in this example given the
amount of funding we calculate the
probability that a company will be
profitable or not profitable and if we
use the threshold line of 50 then we
have our classifier if the probability
is 50 or higher the company is
profitable if the probability is lower
than 50 it's not profitable so what is
logistic regression this is a linear
regression graph so let's compare linear
regression to logistic regression and
take a look at the trendline that
describes the model it's a straight line
which is why we call it linear
regression but using linear regression
we can't really divide the output into
two distinct categories yes or no to
divide our results into two categories
we would have to clip the line between
zero and one if you recall probabilities
can only be between zero and one and if
we're going to use probability on the y
axis then we can't have anything that is
below zero or above one thus we would
have to clip the line and once we clip
the line we see that the resulting curve
cannot be represented in a linear
equation so for logistic regression we
will make use of a sigmoid function and
the sigmoid curve is the line of best
fit notice that it's not linear but it
does satisfy our requirement of using a
single line that does not need to be
clipped for linear regression we would
use an equation of a straight line y
equals b sub 0 plus b sub 1 times x x
being the independent variable y being
the dependent variable but as we've said
we cannot use a linear equation for
binary predictions so we need to use the
sigmoid function which is represented by
the equation p equals 1 divided by the
quantity 1 plus e to the minus y e being
the base of the natural logs then taking
the log of both sides and solving we get
our sigmoid function and graphing it we
get our logistic regression line of best
fit the applications for logistic
regression are endless here we might
have a couple of gardeners or farmers
and one farmer says i am planning to
grow plants in my backyard and i want to
know whether my trees will get infested
with bugs which i'm sure is a huge
problem and these days the fewer
pesticides we use the better off we are
for health reasons the young lady says i
can use logistic regression in a model
to predict it for you and the other
farmer says well how is logistic
regression going to help but we know
that healthy versus not healthy is a
binary classification and we can use a
binary classifier like logistic
regression to solve this problem which
is what the young lady has in mind if we
have the data we can model the data and
generate a sigmoid function that best
fits our data and then use the
probability of a healthy tree versus a
not healthy tree or an infested tree
once again we see our sigmoid line of
best fit and some points that represent
healthy trees and not healthy trees once
again we plot our sigmoid curve scratch
that and once again once our sigmoid
curve is plotted and our threshold is
set almost always at 50
we can use the sigmoid curve and
calculate the probabilities and hear the
independent variable of width which i
assume is an application of pesticides
or no pesticides to determine whether or
not the probability of healthy is
greater than 50 percent the threshold or
less than 50 percent the threshold and
now let's take a use case of a college
admission problem of course we can't
solve anything using data science if we
don't know what the problem is so we
need a problem statement and here the
problem statement is simple we are given
a data set and we need to predict
whether a candidate will get admission
in a desired college or not based on
their gpa and college rank so the very
first thing we need to do is import the
data set and if it's a small enough data
set and it can fit into our computer
memory then we are golden otherwise we
have some work to do the data set that
we were given is in csv format comma
separated values csv files are easily
imported into our environment once we
import the data we next need to select
and import the libraries that we will
need although r is a great programming
language with a lot of built-in
functions it is easily and powerfully
extended by the use of libraries and
packages then we need to split the data
set into a training set and a test set
it's important to note that the data set
that we've imported that we were given
has the gpas and college ranks for
several students but it also has a
column that indicates whether those
students were admitted or not so what
we're saying is that the data set has
the answers and if you think about it it
must how could we possibly train a model
have a model learn if we didn't know the
answers already that's why it's called
machine learning so we train the model
and then we test the model once we split
the data into training and test sets we
will apply our regression on the two
independent variables gpa and rank
generate the model and then run the test
set through the model once that is
complete we will validate the model to
see how well it performed so now it's
demo time so here we have our studio my
favorite ide or integrated development
environment and i have a script already
composed to run our logistic regression
on the problem at hand which is our
college admissions problem so let's just
walk down the script before i run it and
talk about the various points in the
script so first define the problem while
the problem was defined and you really
can't do anything in data science
without a clear problem definition once
the problem is defined you can load your
libraries acquire your data set the
working directory in my case i'm on
windows explore the data munch the data
if necessary and then prepare the data
scale the data if necessary split the
data into train and test data sets then
train the model using the training data
and run the test data through the model
and then validate the model for accuracy
and precision etc so here we are going
to load our libraries i'm going to use a
package called ca tools and now that the
library is loaded i'm going to set my
working directory and if i come over
here to the files tab you'll see that
there is my working directory in that
working directory there's a file called
binary.csv and that's the csv the comma
separated value file that the college
gave me i'm going to ingest and then
look at that data and as you can see it
has four columns gre gpa rank and then
the answer column admit whether or not
someone was admitted which would be a
one or not admitted which would be a
zero and if we come over to the right
and we can look and see some of the
first few values of each of those four
columns now let's split the data we're
going to take this my data frame and
split it into two a training set and a
test set and the ratio we're going to
use is 80 20. so 80 of the data will go
into the training set and 20 will go
into the test set now that ratio could
be 60 40 it could be 70 30. typically it
really depends on the size of your data
how much data you have but this is for
our example and for our purposes 80 20
is perfect next we'll do a little data
munching in general you munch the data
early on after ingestion and you really
have to be careful in this case we don't
have any missing values we don't have
any real outliers our data was pretty
clean when we got it and ingested it but
in general that's not the case and a lot
of work and a lot of attention needs to
be paid to the munging process here
we're just going to take our data the
admission column and the rank column and
convert them to categorical variables
right now they're integers as you can
see on the right hand side and once i
run these two lines they will be
converted to factors and all the fun
stuff we're going to use the glm
function the general linear model
function to train our logistic
regression model and the dependent
variable is admit and the independent
variables are gpa and rank and the
little tilde sign here says the
dependent variable will be a function of
gpa and rank the two independent
variables the data will be the training
set and the family will be binomial and
binomial indicates that it's a binary
classifier it's a logistic regression
problem there it is we ran our model and
there's a summary of our model you can
see that there is some statistical
significance in gpa and in rank by the
coefficients and output of the model so
next let's run the test data through the
model
and once we have done all that we can
now set up a confusion matrix and look
at our predictions versus the actual
values again this is important we had
the answers and now we took and we
predicted some answers so hopefully our
predicted answers match up with the
actual answers we'll run a confusion
matrix as you can see the predicted
values versus the actual values and it's
important here to note that if it was
predicted false and it was actually
false and we see 189 or if it was
predicted true and it was actually true
which is 27 we did well on those but
there are a few that were predicted
incorrectly some were predicted true but
were actually false some were predicted
false that were actually true and now
we'll confirm what our percentage
accuracy is 72 not bad but we could
probably do better how we'll leave that
to another video and we'll be doing part
one of a two-part series decision tree
followed by random forest because
decision tree is part of the random
forest
what's in it for you first we'll cover
what is a decision tree what problems
can be solved using decision trees how
does a decision tree work and then we'll
dive into a use case survival prediction
in r so we'll be using the r platform on
this one so what is a decision tree and
here we have kind of a new looking front
panel of a car driving down the street
and we have uh left or right so you're
coming to an intersection you've got to
decide which way to go are you going to
go left or you're going to go right wait
or go so do you go right away we have a
green light so probably want to go right
away after you check for cross traffic
make sure no one is asleep at the wheel
or talking on their cell phone decision
tree is a tree shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action each branch
of the tree represents a possible
decision occurrence or reaction so
another example is we have a shopkeeper
very non-descript shopkeeper
kind of a little spooky without the eyes
so we have a shopkeeper and he wants to
organize his stall so i must organize my
stall and he's looking around trying to
figure out what the best way to stack
all his goods are and he has some
broccoli some oranges and some carrots
this is kind of a nice example because
we can see where some of the colors and
shapes overlap where others don't and so
you can create a tree out of this very
easily and say is it colored orange if
it's not well it goes into one stack
well that happens to be all their
broccoli and if it is colored orange
then it goes into another stack and
you're like well that's still kind of
chaotic you know people are looking at
carrots and oranges a very strange
combination to put in a box so the next
question might be is it round and if it
is then yes you put the oranges into one
box and no that means it's carrots we
put in the other box and you can see
that a lot of stuff we do in life easily
can fall into like a decision tree how
do you decide something you know does it
go left does it go right yes or no and
even with this we even have a number of
different end choices broccoli carrots
and oranges so what kind of problems
does this solve what problems can be
solved by using a decision tree
classification we're dealing with a
classification identifying to which set
an object belongs and from our example
we just looked at a carrot is orange
while broccoli is green i guess it's
nondescript day
without the faces i love it because a
lot of times you're looking at data you
really don't want to know what exactly
the data is but you're sorting it so you
know like this kind of represents data
that you really don't know exactly where
it's coming from just kind of a fun
thing regression regression is another
problem the biggest can be solved
regression problems have continuous or
numerical valued output variables
example predicting the profits of a
company so we have two different primary
problems we solve for we solve for
classification is it green or is it
orange and we solve for regression which
is a continual number so you know if
you're doing stocks this would be a
dollar value that ranges anywhere from
zero to thousands of dollars
how does a decision tree work terms you
must know first so before we dive into
the decision tree let's look at some of
the terminology for the decision tree we
have notes each internal node in a
decision tree is a test which splits the
objects into different categories and
continuing with our vegetable stand
example we have broccoli no it's not
orange and
oranges and carrots are and so on so you
can see right there where it splits
that's a note where the orange is split
in the carrot split into each of their
own groups and each one of the splits is
a node the very top node of the decision
tree is called the root node so the very
first one we started off where we split
it is a colored orange and you can see
that pointed out nice and neatly there
this is a root note at the top
each external node in a decision tree is
called the leaf node the leaf node is
the output and you can see down here we
have our broccoli and we have our
carrots and our oranges each one of
those is a leaf node so to quickly
rehash our terms we have anywhere there
is a split that's a node and if it's at
the very top of the tree that's the root
node and if you're at the very bottom of
the tree where you have a final answer
that is the leaf node so you have a root
node a leaf node and then everything
else is just a generic node so one of
the most important terms or concepts
that powers a decision tree is entropy
entropy is a measure of the messiness of
your data collection the messier or more
random your data higher will be the
entropy so we can see here we have
broccoli oranges and carrots are all
mixed together and it's very chaotic and
you could say this collection has high
entropy
and if we sort out the carrots out of
here in i guess just one of the broccoli
i don't know where the other broccoli
went you could say if you have just the
oranges and the broccoli this is a lower
entropy they say this collection has low
entropy but really it's higher and lower
one is higher or lower than the other
one and from entropy we get information
gain information is the decrease
obtained in entropy by splitting the
data set u based on some conditioning so
we have our information one which we can
actually there's actual computations and
so we have our e1 which is put in there
for our entropy value at the base node
or root node and we have 2 a2 which is a
leaf node and so we can actually
calculate just calculations for entropy
and we actually look at those two values
the entropy and we take that we have e1
is greater than e2 therefore the
information gain equals e1 minus e2 so
here we have another example and we're
actually going to attach some values to
this one in just a moment so we're going
to move away from the fruit and we're
going to go to everybody's favorite
thing organizing a child's closet and
here we have a young lady waving at us
hi my cupboard is a mess i must organize
my stuff and we're going to classify the
objects based on their attribute set
using a decision tree we can look at it
we have a shape a size and a label and a
number and i'm going to go ahead and
look at the labels because that's really
what's key on this one is we have a
couple balls in here some books cards
and blocks and if you look at that when
you have something that's a ball it's
round so it's a very different shape the
book card and blocks are all rectangular
but the books are a different size so
the books have like a size six i guess
they think of them as very large cards a
size four so they're not quite as big
and the blocks are little lego blocks it
looks like kind of fun to stack on there
and then we can actually quantify this
and we can actually say hey we got we
have different numbers we have two balls
two books one card four blocks and we
split at each level based on certain
conditions on the attributes so
splitting aims at reducing the entropy
and we have a formula our first actual
formula that you'll see happens in the
background when we're running these
different modules in r it looks a little
complicated but we can break that up and
simplify that for you so we see this
formula the negative sum of i of x
equals the probability of 1
value of x times the log of 2
probability value of x the term
probability value of x it's probably
easiest to understand if we go ahead and
put the numbers in there so you can
actually see what we're looking at and
so we plug the numbers in there we look
at the probability of the value of x
well if we do the number of balls
there's two balls and the total number
of items is nine so we have a
probability of any one object being two
out of nine so it's pretty
straightforward math when you look at
the numbers you can actually see that
very easily and so we can calculate our
entropy of 2 over 9 times the squared
log of two over nine plus
one ninth the log squared of one over
nine plus four over nine times the log
squared of four over nine so our whole
group is the sum of all the entropies
and so when we look at that we have the
entropy of the balls which is the two
over nine rectangles two over nine i
mean books two over nine cards one over
nine and the blocks four over nine and
we just plug those numbers in there and
we get an actual value of
1.8282 so what the heck does a module do
with that number well now we must find
the conditions for our split every split
must give us the maximum achievable
information gain and so we have our
first entropy value 1.8282
and it turns out when you compare all
the different individual entropy values
for the balls for the books for the
cards for the blocks rectangles you find
out that the biggest split is going to
be in the shape and it's going to be our
first split will be on the shape that
will directly segregate the balls out so
they'll split up a huge group from one
from the other and so we compute that we
end up with e2 which is all of our
rectangles and then we have a leaf node
which is the balls and so with our e2 we
see that
1.3784 is much less than the
1.8282 and so our second split will be
on the size as that will directly
segregate the books and so we do that we
can see that if the size is greater than
5 all the books go to one side while the
cards in the blocks go to the other and
again we have our e3 which equals 0.716
which is considerably less than 1.3784
so our entropy is dropping each time we
do a split and of course our third split
we look at and we'll see that we're left
with size again and we'd split it with
four and two in this case if it's
greater than three it's going to be a
block if it's less than three it's going
to be a card and at this point each of
our objects is looped into similarities
so they all look the same and we end up
with an entropy of zero and so you can
see as we go down the entropy continues
to get less
and because it hits zero we can say all
our objects are now classified with a
hundred percent accuracy if it was only
that easy to clean the kids closets and
you can see we have a nice drawing that
shows you where all the leaf nodes are
on this in which case we have the balls
the books the blocks and the cards are
part of the leaf note and the root node
is our first split and we have all the
object and we're splitting them by
rectangle by shape so we're going to
dive into the use case and in this case
we're going to get a little morbid there
i am behind my desk that's definitely
not me i don't have that big of a chin
but
i do usually have a cup of coffee and it
looks kind of like that it's sitting
next to me on my desk so the use case is
going to be survival prediction in r and
let's implement a classification of data
set based on information gain
this is going to use the id3 algorithm
don't let that scare you that's the most
common algorithm they use to calculate
the decision tree there's a couple
different ways they can calculate the
entropy but the formula is all the same
behind it so id3 is most common in r and
then we'll be using the rstudio for our
interface for our ide so rstudio is free
to download there's the free version of
course there's an enterprise version and
there's all kinds of different choices
in there but one of the wonderful things
about r is that it's been an open source
for a very long time and is very well
developed it's also very quick and easy
to use on a lot of things so this is
going to be in the rstudio ide there's
some other interfaces but this is i
would suggest using the r studio it's
the most common one and if you remember
i said this is going to be a little
morbid because we're talking about how
many people survived and died on these
ships so in this case we have a nice
vacation cruise ship going on there or
i'm not sure what that is with the
tugboat so we have a ship and it had 20
lifeboats the lifeboats were distributed
based on the class gender and age of the
passengers we will develop a model that
recognizes the relationship between
these factors and predicts the survival
of a passenger accordingly so we want to
predict whether the person is going to
survive or die in a shipwreck and we'll
be using a data set which specifies if a
passenger on a ship survived its wreck
or not so we're going to look at this
data and if you open it up into a
spreadsheet and don't forget you can
always put a note on the youtube video
down below and we will be monitoring
that you can request the data set sent
to you or more correspondence you can
also go to
www.simplylearn.com and request this
data set too it's just a simple csv file
we'll send out and you can see right
here we have survived so one indicates a
person survived the wreck
zero they didn't make it they were under
the water and the luxury class of the
cabin so if they were in you know what
would value is like one two three
depending on what luxury class they were
and then we have this is kind of
interesting how many siblings they had
so it's kind of an interesting added
statistic in there number of parents on
board and disembark location so where
the destination is
so here we've opened up our studio and
if this is your first time in our studio
you'll notice that it opens up
standardly in three panes the upper left
is for text documents you're bringing in
and then the bottom left is the actual
commands as they're processed and then
on the right hand side you have your
environment set up on there now i've
zoomed in with my font a little
oversized in fact we can even take that
up one more size and see if we can get a
larger setup view here we go so i've set
the font for 18 probably a lot larger
than you need to work on a project and
the first thing i'm going to do is on
the right hand panel we're going to be
working with plots so i'm going to click
on the little plot tab up there and i'm
just going to collapse that over to the
side for right now and then i'm going to
open up the bottom one and you'll see on
the top i actually have
two different tabs team in the back was
really nice to set up the whole package
for what we're working on here and we'll
go through this line by line and then
you'll see as we execute the different
lines they're going to appear down below
so i'll be flipping between these two
left panels and let me go backwards just
for a second here we're going to do this
part so let's take a look at the
installs
and if you look at the installs when i'm
not going to actually run the installs
because i've already run them on my
computer so these are already installed
in my r packages and i don't have to
re-run them
we have a number of packages we're
bringing into our because that's how r
functions and the first number of
packages are all part of our decision
tree so our f selector our r part our
carrot with the dependencies equal true
and our dp lyr and our r part plot
that's a mouthful you'll need to import
all of these in your setup
and the first one which is your f
selector compute your chi squared your
information gain your entropy all of
those formulas are a part of the f
selectors when you bring it in that's
what that package is the r part is your
partitioning of your decision tree so
these are your primary two decision tree
modules that we're bringing in
the carrot is a part for actually
splitting apart the data because we
always want to do a test set a train set
so they built a package carrot to kind
of handle all those you'll see carrot
used a lot of other machine learning
packages when you're doing the r
the
dplyr is for mutating your data so you
can sum it you can classify it you can
filter it
that's all part of the
dplyr and then our part has another
piece called plot and that's for helping
us plot the data as we sort out the tree
because the r part creates a tree but
you still want to be able to plot it and
then we come down here and we have some
additional tools we're going to work
with a spreadsheet this is a microsoft
access spreadsheet so we're going to use
the xlsx package to import it and you
might think it's a little outdated
because i know when i'm doing any new
projects i try to save my data into a
comma separated variable file or
something more standardized a lot of
times you'll end up with these old
databases where they're exporting data
and their export comes in an excel
spreadsheet and guess what this is a
time saver instead of opening up the
spreadsheet resaving it as a comma
separated variable file you can just
open it right up in r which is really
nice and then we have our data tree
which goes right along with uh
displaying the data so we have our
rpart.plot and we're going to put that
into the data trees have a nice visual
and finally you need to install the
package ca tools and ca tools is another
package used for general manipulation of
your data and your vectors so it also
has a split function for training data i
know we have another package for that
but both those packages fit in there as
far as the working with the data so a
lot of times you'll see these loaded in
there together and you'll see in a
moment we'll import the elementary stat
learn package also which is very generic
working with data setup as far as
statistics and data processing now
because my java setup is a little
different because i use a developer
package well the latest update of the
developer package and the r are
struggling to see each other so i need
to go ahead and add this in chances are
you don't need to worry about this but
if you do get an r java error you'll
need to go ahead and add an align to set
your environment and i'm just going to
set the java home i went ahead and
looked up the last solid jre folder
you'll see under program files java you
can look them all up to make sure it's
the jre and not the jdk the difference
between those is one is a standard
executable that's a jre folder it is a
folder not an actual file and the jdk
deals more with developer side on things
and i'm going to go ahead and run this
and if you're in r you can run these
lines individually by holding your
control key down and hitting the enter
button so i've now loaded my workspace
and set my environment here and we can
actually look and just make sure a
system dot
get environment is the opposite one
and i can just look real quick and say
hey what's my java
home set to
and if i run that whoops i forgot to put
brackets around it
there we go
and if i do that you'll see that it's
set to the jdk18025
and again we're looking at the split
screen and let me just move this up here
a little bit and let me hit the enter
key a bunch of times it comes up on the
screen
when i run it and i'm running it line by
line the run text then appears down here
and this is what's actually being
executed so i could just as easily type
it in down here as putting it up here on
the top part
that's just a little bit of r studio and
working with rstudio
so i've shown you the installs and again
i've already installed it on my computer
so it takes a minute or two to install
it
we need to go ahead and then bring those
libraries in to work with
so
basically we're going through all the
different libraries we're using
elements.learn is a standard r library
so it should already be installed you
don't have to install that one and i can
just go right down them and you'll see
as i install them that they show up on
the bottom and every time you go to run
a new setup
you need to go ahead and install these
pull the libraries in you got to tell
your r studio these are the libraries
you're using
and you can see right down here that
as it executes them
it has all the different things one of
them had like a couple different parts
to it so loaded the lattice and the gg
plot to
really nothing to worry too much unless
you see errors down here so if you start
getting error codes
then you might have to go troubleshoot
and find out why it's not installing
correctly or did it install correctly
but it's pretty straightforward we've
covered all the libraries
and again if you want a copy of this
code simply let a comment down below on
the youtube video or visit
www.simplylearn.com
and they'll be happy to send you a copy
of the base code
the next step is we want to go ahead and
load the excel file
after setting the working directory
so let's go ahead and set the working
directory scwd is a command for that in
r
and then this is wherever you have
downloaded your data to and your files
too a lot of times if you get the zipped
framework sent to you it will unzip all
into one location
and then you can look that location up
and put that in here a lot of times it
automatically sets up for you if you're
if you're working in the same directory
in this case you can see i pasted in a
very lengthy
path because i have this as part of my
documents my business docs and simply
learn and marketing videos and so on
when i'll go ahead and do the control
enter and run that so now my working
directory is set
and you can see down below it's executed
this on the
console down here
and if i open up that working directory
you can see i have a ship xls file
that's the data we're going to look at
and we looked at that on the slide
you could also open this up and i want
to go ahead and open it up with a
notepad
by default it will open up as a
spreadsheet oh it is an excel file so
i'd have to open it up as an actual
spreadsheet wasn't thinking that one
through this is one of the problems with
saving stuff as a proprietary ship soft
file even something as widely used as
microsoft
excel spreadsheet
but when we open up the spreadsheet you
can see here the same data we looked at
before
that's what's coming up in this file
and so i take this file we can go ahead
and let's um
create a variable we'll call it add
and we're going to assign it
that's what the lesser than dash means
if you've never used r before and we're
just going to assign it a ship xlsx
and then i'll do my control enter and
you'll see it run down here ship
add is assign shipped.xls
our excel spreadsheet on there
and then let's have a another variable
we'll call it df for data frame and
we're going to assign this
read
xlsx
and that's from the library slx that we
just imported
and we want to read the file add
because we just created that variable
with the ship.xls
and i didn't catch this right away but
you'll see when we open it up in a
spreadsheet
it might be hard to see in your video
screen it has a the first sheet is
called ship one so this data is on the
page ship one in the excel spreadsheet
and we got to make sure that we tell
the reader to look for that
and so we can simply do that in our
command line
sheet name
equals
and it was ship one on there
so we go ahead and hit the control enter
and run this line and it brings it down
below and executes it
it's now reading in that data from that
spreadsheet that's what's going on and
it takes it just a moment to go ahead
and read it in
and then with any
data processing we need to select the
meaningful columns for the prediction so
this is important that we sort through
our data and set it correctly so that
whatever we're feeding it into can read
it correctly
we can do this with
df
we're going to reassign it and we're
going to select
and from there we're going to select df
as our our main data frame going in
and then list the columns that we want
and if we look at the data we have
survived we have a class we have a name
sex and age
and then there's siblings and parents
we really don't want to know the name
because we don't need the name to run
this on here and then we gotta decide
which one of these we want to work with
and the guys in the back played with the
data a little bit and they came up with
the following columns
survived which we need definitely
because that's what we're actually
trying to figure out is whether we're
going to survive or not
what class they're which which class of
the boat they're writing in with their
first class second class
sex and age we went ahead and dropped
the rest of them at least for this
example
and so i can go ahead and do my control
enter and you'll see it execute down
below
and now df
equals
these three columns or
four columns
plus our answer is one of those so i
always think of it as three columns plus
one
but it is four columns
and then for the next step we want to
make sure the data is in the right
format so again i'm going to resign the
df
and we're going to mutate the data
and that means we're going to take each
one of these columns and we're going to
let it know what kind of data that is
so our first one is let me put the
database in or the data frame in there
df
and then we want to go ahead and do
survived equals a factor of survived so
this is a yes no it's letting us know
that this is a 0 or a 1 on here
and then for the class and the
age those are as numeric
there's other ways to process class
since it is a very restricted number on
there but for this we're just going to
do it as a numeric value same thing with
age and you see we didn't do anything
with sex we're just going to leave that
as male or female and that's fine for
this because it'll pick up on that when
we run the decision tree
and we'll do our control enter so now
i've assigned the new df and you can see
it comes down below
as we run it on there so this is now
loaded and df now is a mutated data
frame that we started with and we've set
it up with our specific columns we want
to work with in this case survived class
sex and age and we've formatted three of
those columns to a new setup so one of
them is factor that's what we use for
survive so it knows it's a zero and one
and then we switched class and age to
make sure that it knows that those are
numeric values
now that we have our data formatted we
need to go ahead and split the data into
a training and testing data set and by
now if you've done any of our other
machine learning tutorials you know this
is standard you need to have your data
that we train it with and then you got
to make sure it works on data that it
hasn't trained on
so we'll go ahead and do the splitting
let's take a look and see what that
looks like
and when you're dealing with splitting
the data we're doing a little randomness
so we'll just go ahead and set the seed
to one two three you can set that to
whatever number you want that's just
setting the random variable seed
and we'll go ahead and hit enter on
there
and to do this we're going to create
sample and we can go
equals sample dot
split
so we're splitting up the data
this is actually creating a whole new
column
trues and falses and it's all stored in
sample and we want our data frame and we
use a dollar sign to denote that we're
going to be working with
one of the different columns a nice
thing you can do in r
and it actually shows my survived so df
survived
and then our split
ratio
split ratio i want to add a period in
there which it doesn't have
our split ratio is going to be equal to
and we'll do 0.70 so we're going to take
70 percent of the data
of those that have survived and we're
going to just randomly select which one
of those we're going to use for training
and which one we're going to use for
testing it out later
we'll hit our enter and load that sample
in there
and then we'll go ahead and create our
train and our test data set so i'm going
to set train equal to
and this is where it kind of gets
interesting because we're going to do
subset
and then we're going to do a subset of
our df
where sample
and then we're going to use equals since
this is a logic gate so wherever it sets
sample equal to true we're going to use
that line in df
and this is a course of our so it's all
capitalized for true
so here's our trained data frame we're
creating so when i execute this and it
shows up down below
it goes up and says hey this sample
created a whole bunch of trues and false
and we're going to take those trues and
falses and wherever we've created a true
which is 70 of the data randomly
selected that's we're going to train the
data with and then we need our test set
and that's a subset just the same thing
we just did
and we need our data frame and this is
where the sample equals
false and again when i hit control enter
it goes down this line of code and it
runs it down here in our terminal window
so now we've nicely split our data up we
have our training data set and our test
data set
and this is of course we get to the
point of what we're actually trying to
do which is create our decision tree
and we're going to do that by training
the decision tree as a classifier
this always gives me you spend all this
work sorting through the data
reformatting it in this case mutating it
and filtering it and creating a train
set and a test set
so we're going to go ahead and create
our tree and we're going to assign to it
the r part
that's the module we imported
and for the our part we need to go ahead
and
do what's called a survived and this is
kind of a little complicated to look at
so let's just take a quick look at this
i'm going to go backward on it the first
part is we're importing the data so data
equals train
and then we want to know is who survived
so
the first part we put in here is the
column we're looking for is survived
and you'll see that we have added the
squiggly mark in the period because
we're looking just for this prediction
we just want to know who survived from
these boats
for programming our decision tree and
i'll go ahead and hit ctrl enter
and we've now created the tree that tree
with all those values is now in there
and if you remember from before we've
taken from when we did the closet full
of clutter we've done the same thing
where we have our entropy and that one
line computes the entropy and the
increase in information and it brings
entropy down to zero so it's the same
thing but instead of applying it here as
we did visually to the closet it's now
applied it to the data on the ship it's
now looked at the survival of zero or
one based on female male what age they
are where the best split of the age is
and what class they were in you can see
we have first class if we go down there
i think there's
third yeah third second so i guess it's
class one two and three but you can see
that's how it split it up so it's use
these different variables to minimize
the entropy and maximize the information
gain and that's all done in that one
line of code
boy we worked on all that theory and
computer doesn't fear in one line of
code it's important to understand the
theory behind it so you know what's
happening because as they make changes
to these or if you had special settings
on it you have to know what they're
doing
but in this case you can see that we
once we get it formatted the computer
does all the heavy lifting for us
and it never ceases to amaze me just how
advanced machine learning has become
these days and how easy it is for people
to get into it and learn the basic
setups and be able to compute your
different machine learning models
once we've computed our decision tree
and we built it on there we want to go
ahead and start doing predictions with
it
and what are we going to predict well
you remember that we created our data
with the train and test so we have our
training data which we programmed the
tree for
now we want to see what it does with the
test data so let's see what that looks
like and we can wrap that into tree dot
survived dot predicted
we'll assign that to our prediction
this is nice because we have the command
predict from one of the modules the r
part module that we brought in
i can simply put in here that we're
going to use the tree
we have our test data
and type
this happens to be classification or
class
and this would also be if you were to
distribute this tree you could save the
tree and send it someplace else to be
used on new data this would be the
command line you would use to predict on
here predict you have your tree saved
you have whatever data you're putting
through
and you let it know it's doing a
classification on the tree
and we'll go ahead and run that so now
that's loaded up
and now that we've gone through we've
trained our tree we've run a prediction
on our test data remember the tree had
never seen the test data till now so
we've already built the tree we're just
testing it out
and to do that we're going to use a
confusion matrix for evaluating the
model and let's see what that looks like
that is simply confusion
matrix so once we have the confusion
matrix
which came in from our carrot we need to
compare the two different pieces of data
and the first one is going to be the
value we generated up here we have
tree.survived.predicted
so i'm just going to copy that and paste
it down here
and then the second one is the tree
we're comparing that to
let's see survived
it's not the tree it's easy to get
confused sometimes when you're moving
these things around
we're going to compare it to test
the test group of data specifically
the survived column
and let's go ahead and run this and see
what that looks like
and so let's go ahead and scroll up a
little bit here to where it first
executed the confusion matrix
and the most important part of this is
that we have our prediction
and our reference and so zero means they
didn't survive one means they survived
we had our prediction on here
versus the actual and that's what these
two columns mean
and so when you read this little chart
we have zero zero so both the prediction
and the actual reference said agreed on
218 values for people who did not
survive a little grim there for data
remember i talked about this is morbid
data talking about death rates of people
on boats it says that they both agreed
on 93 so 93 of them where we predicted
the value that they would survive and
the reference came up the same
likewise
the predicted or predicted one
and the reference said no these people
didn't survive well our prediction got
25 wrong
and where it says they didn't survive
and they actually did and got 57 wrong
and we can come on down with the
confusion matrix and we can look at the
accuracy comes up with the 0.7913
or 95 percent ci
so you're looking at pretty high
accuracy
information ratio p value when you're in
statistics the p-value is one of the
things we look at remember that there
are certain values if it's over 0.95
it's considered highly valuable variable
0.5 means maybe anything less than that
means it's probably not connected
you have to look up the p-value a little
bit more on that
then they just have more information
down here
which you can go through
and
you can go through but the important
part is that we have a very high
accuracy that's what we're looking at
this is a very accurate model and again
always remember the domain you're
working with certainly this is an
example and this is a good little piece
of data you can play with but if i was
say betting money and my accuracy came
up as 79 or over 95 ci i'd be like yes
let's bet on that that's a good bet but
if i was betting on a life or death
situation i might kind of rethink that a
little bit if that is if it's going to
affect my life that way you can also
look at this as if you're trying to
figure out where the boats go in this
particular example and where to put the
lifeboats that's actually pretty good be
able to say hey we can increase the
chances of people surviving this
accident by putting the lifeboats in the
appropriate places
and then this is always fun let's
visualize the decision tree one of the
cool things you can do inside of r real
easily and if you remember one of the
modules we brought in has a rpart.plot
we're going to take that and we're going
to dump that into the prp for the tree
and let's go ahead and hit enter
and this is fine let me move this over
so you can get a nice view you can see
how it actually split it up and let me
just rerun that again now they expanded
the right you'll see right here where
one of the biggest splits was whether
the person was male or female
didn't know that was probably one of the
biggest breaks as far as lowering the
entropy and increasing the information
gain
and then once you know sex is male it
came down here and it said you're not
going to survive i guess the men were
throwing themselves overboard on the
boat i don't know maybe they're being
very gallant and letting the women and
children survive which is what i hope
that means
so once you know that it's not a male
and it's a female passenger if you were
in class 3 or above you had a high
chance of surviving if you're less in
class 3 class one or two then it was
based on age and so you can see where
age was greater than 19.
so anybody over 19 had a high chance of
surviving and then if they were or less
than 19 i'm sorry if the age was a
little confusing on that one but if the
age was one sided 19 they probably
survived if not then i said hey if your
age is less than 60 you probably
survived and if not
people who are older probably didn't
make it out of the boat in time so
elderly have a much higher risk which
you would expect you'd expect that to be
the case that elderly would have a hard
time getting off into the lifeboats and
they would probably step aside for the
younger generation i know i would you
know so it might be more of a social
norm statistic as opposed to survival
rate let's go and put this back on over
here
and see what else we can do with this
data you know if you're working with the
shareholders it's good to have a lot of
tools as far as how to display you know
they'll want to see this number here
where you say hey this is what the
confusion matrix looks like and we got a
0.79 accuracy that would be like the
number one thing you talk to the
shareholders about other data scientists
care about the p value and the
information rate and information like
that but this is really the core right
here this is how much data and this also
shows them how much data was looked at
so you have a you can actually just add
these numbers together and you can see
how many different people were in the
this particular data set i mean lines in
the data set but we go ahead and
visualize the 2d decision boundaries and
let's take a look at that that's kind of
fun
it's a little bit more complicated so
i'm not going to go into it in too much
detail today now the guys in the back
put this code together for me which is
great so i'm just going to paste that in
because like i said we're not going to
go into it into too much detail i want
to just show you that there's some other
ways to display the data that is not
just this nice little tree over here
which gives us a little bit more maybe
view of what's going on as you dig
deeper into data that becomes very
important it might not be something so
simple where you can look at in this
case
one two three four nodes so they have
four major nodes that they split the
data in
so we're looking at this we're going to
go ahead and create a set test
equal to test comma c241
we're just assigning color column to go
with the data
okay that's what that is
and then we're going to take set and
have it equal to test
and we'll do x1
and we're going to set that equal to
minimum set
of 1 minus 1 max set of 1 plus 1
by equals 0.01
they had to play with these numbers a
little bit to get this to look right
so we're creating a sequence on here
from our the set we created so our test
set
and then x2 is also creating a sequence
based on different values
and then we're going to put that all
into a grid so let's go ahead and run
that through all the way down to the
grid
and they'll make a little more sense
when we add the column names to the grid
okay so we'll set our test we'll create
our x1 sequence and our x2 sequence
remember a sequence is just like in this
case starting with 0.1 it's like 0.01
0.02 0.03 0.04
so we're going to create a grid with all
these values separated by 0.01 so that's
all we're doing right now
let's go ahead and set that up there's
our grid
and then we want to go ahead and create
some column names and for our grid set
we're going to have our c class and age
so we're just doing the class and the
age on here remember we did sex also
before so it's just class and age on
this chart that we're pulling out
and we're going to create a y grid and
the y grid is going to equal tree
survived predicted
okay so here's our y grid and our
predicted values on there
now we're actually going to do something
we're going to plot and we're going to
plot the y grid oops hold on let me see
what's in here
and let me go ahead and just run the
plot it's got to be the
there we go so let's take a look at this
and see if we can make a little sense of
this code and what's going on here
because a couple of things going on what
we've done is we've plotted a decision
tree classification data set
we've done our plot and we have our set
so our sets equal to our test data
and then we have our main we went ahead
and give it a name decision tree
and then we have our x lab
and our x limit and we've set those up
as class
with our y lab equals age and our x
limit equals range x one comma y limit
equals range of x2
and when you look over here you can see
that we have age on the left and class
on the bottom
and so based on age and class
and so once we put in this nice graph
here we want to go ahead and add our
contours and our points
so let's go ahead and run that and i'm
going to run all three of these so we
can see
all the colors come in on the graph and
this is actually going to take a little
bit because remember
you can make it go a little faster by
changing a couple of the notes up here
well we did .01 from the min to max by
changing that to 0.1 or other values
you can actually run a little quicker
and we're going to create a nice little
decision tree classification test set
just to see what that looks like and how
that data displays
now that was taking so long to run with
0.01 i went ahead and just did a 0.1
so instead of filling the whole page
with different colors for a really
pretty view now i just have these
different colored lines coming across it
gives us another model that we can show
for whoever you're working with in this
case your shareholders of the company or
the individuals who you're posting to
the web for and you can see where we
have the green and the red and we've set
those up to identify from the decision
who's going to make it and who's not
based on age and class
now my favorite one on this and i'm
going to go back and just highlight this
really quick was let me just rerun that
go back to prp tree where we display the
tree
and that's where we split it in part
because this information
gives us some keys that we can then use
in other models so it's good to know
that sometimes what you're taking comes
out and maybe you create a bucket for
people under 19 between 19 and 60 and
over 60 and different things like that
so you can actually put people in
buckets in a class age split
just a quick note on there again you
know lots of different things from which
you can display the data and you can see
how we use the decision tree to figure
out chances of somebody surviving based
on their class and their age we're going
to cover the random forest in r if you
remember from part one we did the
decision tree and no one wants a poor
lone standing tree out in the field we
want a forest and so we're going to
cover random forest still play on wards
there i'm sure the people who designed
it also knew that too when they were
thinking about it so what's in it for
you what is a random forest how does a
random forest work we're going to cover
applications of a random forest some of
the terms you need to know when using a
random forest and then we'll go over the
use case in r predicting the quality of
wine so let's start a little bit with
exploring what is a random forest and
welcome to raphael's vineyard and i
don't even know how to pronounce that in
alsace france the largest wine
production region in the world so they
have
centuries of wine production and data
they've collected on how to make the
best how to make their grapes and grow
them and how to properly get the right
grapes and ferment them like raphael
winemakers around the world are facing a
grave problem so let's meet the man
himself and try helping him out what is
a random forest we're going to come back
to the vineyard but we're going to look
at some other examples along the way too
open up the door and of course uh here
comes raphael that probably i'd probably
look closer to raphael than i do to the
young lad with the beard hey raphael so
tell us how it's going not as good as
before not many people work in this
profession anymore so every stage of
production has gone slower if only we
could somehow speed up the process well
lucky for you i'm a machine learning
engineer how about we automate the
quality prediction process for wine let
me begin by telling you what machine
learning and random forest is machine
learning is a science of applying
algorithms that allow a computer to
predict the outcome without being
explicitly programmed random force is an
ensemble machine learning algorithm so
we're bringing in different pieces and
then putting those pieces together it
operates by building multiple decision
trees remember i told you we don't want
just a lone tree out there in the we
want a forest they work for both
classification if you remember from part
one we had our vendor with his broccoli
and oranges i think he also had carrots
and it also the output given by the
majority of its decision trees is the
forest final output so if you have a
number of decision trees you have five
decision trees and four of them say it's
broccoli then it's probably broccoli and
you can also use it as a regression
model the output given by the majority
of decision trees is a forest final
output just like you do in
classification you can also come up with
actual values and numbers as a
regression model could you explain how a
random force works in layman terms it's
always a good thing to explore the
information on something a little bit
easier to understand and see
sure let's consider the case of sam a
high school student this so reminds me
of my own high school student who's just
started his first year in college asking
all his friends so sam is confused on
which course to take up so he's trying
to figure out what his next class is
going to be at school should he take
music lessons dance lessons math science
maybe social studies so he decides to
ask a couple of his friends for
suggestions and sam approaches jane
first so he comes up to jane and says
hey which of these classes should i take
and jane asked sam a few questions based
on which she can suggest
theoretical do you like theory no he
doesn't like the theory part calculative
do you like calculative because yes i
like doing calculations and so jane
based on a couple question goes she has
a little decision tree there going she
goes mathematics sounds good so james
forms a decision tree based on sam's
response and gives her suggestion and of
course this is based on jane's views and
her history and the data that she's
collected over her years in high school
next sam approach is bella bella asked
him hey do you like the fill of science
and sam goes yes and then bella goes do
you like
new in industry he like new things
coming up in industry and sam goes yes
and bella goes you know you should
similar to jane bella also forms a
decision tree based on sam's response
and gives her suggestion and says hey
how about artificial intelligence sam's
like oh artificial intelligence so sam
next asks terry for his suggestion and
sam goes do you like scoring things
and he goes yes
and he goes do you like theoretical and
he goes no and he comes up and says
mathematics so you have two people
saying mathematics and once a person
suggests an artificial intelligence
since two out of three friends suggested
math sam decides to take mathematics and
there's a lot of subtleties in this
example it's actually a really good
example some of the things we run into
in data science is when we collect data
and we collect from different sources we
might have data from one source that
measures one thing or one set of
instruments and we might have data from
another source that measures something
else we saw that with each of his
friends are measuring different things
and asking different questions that's a
little bit beyond the scope of this
particular tutorial so let's go back to
our wine cellar so you see more the
number of decision trees more accurate
will be the prediction random forests
have a number of applications in market
already if you've been watching any of
our other tutorials you'll see that
these are very common we have in banking
it can be used to predict fraudulent
customers is used to analyze
symptoms of patients detecting the
disease
in e-commerce the recommendations are
predicted based on customers activity
stock market trends can be analyzed to
predict profit or loss
most recently i was watching a review on
weather here in the united states and
the data they pull in for that and one
of the top weather places actually uses
five different models random forest was
one of them i believe they use five
different models to predict the weather
and depending on what the models come up
with and what's going on some of the
models do better than others i thought
that was really interesting it's
important to note so when you see us
repeat the same things over and over and
you're looking at the different machine
learning tools you realize that we use
multiple tools to solve the same problem
and we can find the best one that fits
for that particular situation so let's
see how that fits back in our wine
production to help speed up the process
of wine production we will automate the
prediction of wine quality suppose our
random forest builds three decision
trees we have the first decision tree
which is going to divide everything by
chlorides less than 0.08 and it's either
yes or no and then it's going to look at
alcohol greater than 6 yes or no quality
equals high quality not so good and if
the chlorides were greater than 0.08
quality equals low so there's our first
tree and then our second tree is going
to split it on sulfates less than 0.6
and ph ph less than 3.5 and again we
have it coming down here that if the ph
is low and the sulfites are low the
quality equals high if the ph is a
little higher but the sulfides are low
it's not so good and if the sulfides are
greater than 0.6 we have a quality
equals low and then we'll do a third
decision tree we'll split it based on ph
and we can see below how that tree looks
like with our sugar less than 2.5 if not
it's a quad equals low it's real low
quality and if it is less than 2.5 then
the ph decide whether it's going to be a
quality pie or not so good and if we
track one of our wines down the list
we'll look at it we'll say oh two out of
three decision trees indicate the
quality of our wine to be five the
forest predicts the same so this sounds
promising so let's go ahead and dive in
and see what that actually looks like so
this is the data set that holds all the
attribute values required to predict the
wine's quality and i'll pull this up in
a spreadsheet in just a moment but you
can see here we have fixed acidity
volatile acidity citric acid all the way
to quality and then quality is like a
four five six or seven i believe and
this will be done in r so let's go ahead
and get started on our coding we'll be
using rstudio before we dive into
rstudio i always like to open up the
data in the spreadsheet and look at the
actual data that i have
and they've called it wine quality dash
red.xls so it's a spreadsheet a
microsoft spreadsheet
and when we open it up we'll see that it
matches what we had before as far as the
slide was showing us with the we have 12
different columns the first 11 are our
features our fixed acidity volatile acid
citric acid things you always want to
look at when you're looking at your data
and we've done this before in the part
one but just a reminder we want to note
that we have decimal places here float
values
and a lot of these things especially the
first number of columns
our free sulfur dioxide looks to be
an integer but it varies a lot so we
have you know i see some values all the
way up to 51
7 4.
so we'd probably keep this as a linear
model kind of thing same thing with the
sulfur dioxides densities again decimal
places sulfides alcohol
quality i want you to note in the
quality
that we only have a few qualities here
this isn't
like a spread between zero and a hundred
it looks to be three four five six and
seven
and so when we start looking at the
processes we can have the option of
either doing this as a series of
integers or float values going from
three to seven or we can convert that to
a categorical three four five six and
seven being the categories but we'll
look at that in the coding here in just
a minute and finally you'd want to go
ahead and scroll down through the data
and just look for missing data or
anything weird
obviously you're working with big data
you wouldn't be able to do that if this
was spread across numerous computers and
you had millions of
rows we have what 1 687 rows here so
it's a nice size spreadsheet still
considered a small data set
let's go ahead and switch over and let's
take a look at this in the r
so here we are in our r studio
and if you remember it's uh comes up
automatically in three panels i have my
font on fairly large to help out
the upper left panel is a
file that's open you can have multiple
files and tabs open as you can see on
mine right now i'll probably close most
of those in just a minute
and this is where you can put in your
commands
then you can execute these commands by
either clicking on the run box or
control enter as the hotkeys for that
and all that does is then puts that down
in the console and executes that line of
command you could just paste these
directly in the console i've certainly
been known to do that if i'm loading up
some data and i just want to take a
quick look at it in r because i'm doing
the coding in something else or if i
just want to do a quick explore before i
dive in and figure out what needs to be
done that's one of the tricks you can do
and then on the right hand side we have
our environment history connections
we mainly are going to just be sitting
on plots and i'm just going to minimize
this for right now out of the way when
we dive in if you haven't yet you do
need to go ahead and install the package
random forest i'm not actually going to
do that because i've already run that we
don't need to rerun that but i am going
to go ahead and import it into our
project with the library and then random
forest and we'll do the control enter
you can always hit the run button up
there too
and then now the library has been
uploaded in there and you can see down
below it takes us and just copies it and
pastes it down below and runs it in our
console
and then just a quick troubleshooting
thing my java happens to be the
developer's job the latest release of
the developers java from last week is
clashing with my r and rerouting my
java files so your chances are you don't
need to to look this up or find out
where your java is but there's a jre
folder if you do have an error that
comes up next in the next library you
look that up it's usually under program
files java and you'll see jdk depending
on what version you have on there and
then find that jre folder and i'm just
going to set the environment on there
you have to do that every time you run
the script so with r there is a place in
r where you can set it permanently but
generally it's set to whatever your
system variables are set to so you don't
want to mess with that so you just want
to put this in your code if you're
having problems you can always take it
out then we need to go ahead and bring
in another library
and we're going to be importing a the
spreadsheet so it's an x the
xlsx since it's a microsoft spreadsheet
and i'll go ahead and run that
let's go ahead and create a variable
path we're going to assign to variable
path the location of our folder so this
is a very lengthy one you'll have to
copy and paste it off your computer my
name is richard and you can see under
it's under c column users richer's
documents docs business simply learn
marketing
random forest and then the actual file
which is wine quality dash red.xls
so i put in the whole path in here you
could also set the computer path to
whatever folder you have it in and then
just use just the name of the file but i
went ahead and did this because it a lot
of times it's good to be aware where
your paths are going where you're
pulling your data from
and again i went the control enter so i
could you'll see that that pushed the
line down below and ran that line so our
path is now set
and then let's create a variable called
data
and we'll assign that to a read
and we're going to be reading let's see
where is it there it is and spreadsheet
and before i put in
we need the path
but we also need one more thing on the
spreadsheet because it is an excel
spreadsheet we need to know
which
page we're on so let's go look that up
and in the spreadsheet this might be a
little hard to see because it's a very
tiny font down there but you'll see the
page tabs on the bottom this actually
has two different pages and we want page
one for this project so let's flip back
over and put that in our code
and the term they use is sheet
index i always have to look that stuff
up
and it was sheet index of one we'll go
ahead and execute this
so at this point we've now loaded the
data into the variable data
and it's reading those and i think there
was like a couple thousand rows of data
in there so it takes just a moment to
pull it in
once i have my data in there i always
like to do something like this data
and in
always forgetting r it's head data
and we can run that
and you'll see it prints out that what
we looked at in the spreadsheet so we
have our fixed
acidity
volatile acidity citric acid residual
sugar chlorides free sulfur all the
different things
we're actually looking for quality so
you want to keep that in mind that
quality is the final setting is it a
three four five six what is the quality
on there
and the first thing we need to do is
we're actually going to take the data
quality
and let me see quality there it is
in r the dollar sign means that you're
looking at one of the columns in here or
features as it is so we see data dollar
sign quality and r that means that's
what we're going to be editing
and what we want to do is we want to
change the quality just a little bit
and so we're going to set it equal to
now we're not assigning a variable we're
altering it so data
dollar sign quality equals
and we want to do as is one of the
functions in r and we're going to do as
a factor
and then data
quality because that's what we're
actually editing on there and this stop
just for a second to look at this
factor takes this
and looks at the data as a
categorically so instead of it being on
a continual scale of you know
zero to a hundred or something like that
it actually looks at it as category of
five category of six category of a
category of cat category of dog
there are yes or no categories versus a
continual now there's a lot of different
things in here that we could do the same
thing with
but all of these really are
linear numbers 7.4 0.70
sulfur dioxide 3467. so we really don't
need to mess with any of the other
variables in there but we do want to go
ahead and set this up and we'll come up
here and do our control enter and it'll
run it down below and you'll see data
quality equals as factor data quality so
we've now turned that into a factor or
into a categorical data
and so let me just bring this down a
little bit the guys in the back did the
rest of this next piece of code
there are so many different ways and if
you have been
looking at any of our tutorials
this should look kind of familiar this
is one way to do it you'll see we have
our training data and our testing data
and so we've done here is we've got it
we have a data set size equals
and we're just going to do by the row
and so we want point eight or eighty
percent of the data is going to be our
training set to train our forest and if
you train a forest or any machine
learning model of course want to test it
so we're going to save 20 of the data
for testing
and when you look at this we have the
index
which we set at 80 percent comma and
then a negative index so that's the
remaining setup so it goes from that
index on this is our notation for
sorting out that data and then we create
the index
and we use the term sample
and this is just going to go in there
and set our different samples for in row
size data set size and everything so we
have an index now so the data is indexed
and we're just going to pull off the
first set of index and the end of the
index for our data
and we can run all of this in one shot
we'll go under code
and we'll run
selected lines and so now we have our
data in here we have our training set
and our testing set that's what we
wanted to get to
so once we formatted all the data then
we get to the next real easy step which
is a single line to bring in our random
forest
so let's go ahead and we'll use a
variable rf standing for random forest
and we're going to assign
if you remember correctly we brought in
our library random
if you wonder why i go up here all the
time it's because i'll forget which
letters are capitalized in some of these
because i switch between packages so
much but it's random with a capital f
for forest random forest so the rf is
going to equal random forest
and of course the
we start by telling it which column
we're trying to predict
and of course we can always go down here
and double check we're running this on
the quality there we go quality and
we're using just that column all the way
to the end
and then we've added our team in the
back has gone in and played with this a
little bit and we'll go a little bit
over what they did but i'm going to put
in the values that they have set for the
different options in the random forest
before i do that it would help if i tell
it what data to use data is going to
equal
our training set
and then we have the variables that they
put together and let's just talk a
little bit about what these different
variables mean
so
m try and entry these are some of the
variables you play with with the random
forest the m try not so much
when they first put it out i think m try
was very common four is a good value i
can't remember what the default is but
it's probably three four five or
something like that depending i think it
depends on how many features you have
going in there so you could even just
leave this as a default without too much
troubles
the entry this is where it gets
important and i'm going to make this
one of the suggestions is to always make
this odd like a tie breaker just in case
the default is like 500 or 501
and then finally we have importance
equals true i can't remember what it
defaults to but generally you want to
set the importance equals to true it
actually looks at the correlation
between the different features to make
sure that there is some kind of
correlation as it's doing its
calculations so our one line of code is
going to assign our random forest and go
ahead and train our random forest all in
one execution so this whole thing has
been centered around getting to rf set
to the random forest and let's go ahead
and execute this variable or this line
of code and you'll see it takes a little
bit down here to execute as it goes
through and sets it up
and you'll see it probably takes a
minute or so to execute the code
depending on the size of the data and
how good your machine is
and then with all of our data we can
start looking at the answers we'll just
do rf we'll execute that
and you'll see that the random forest
does a nice job you can see right here
it has our data equals training it
basically goes over everything we talked
about
and you come down here and it has a
confusion matrix which is nice we always
like our confusion matrix when we're
talking to our shareholders and
explaining
what the data comes out with and how it
trains
and we can go ahead and plot our rf
let's see what that looks like
and
as the number of force grows you
remember we set it to 2001 forest you
can also see how the error comes in how
the different error on the different
variables
this kind of a nice graph that gives you
an idea might help you adjust whether
you really want to do 2000 different
forests
you might actually truncate this off at
around maybe 800 because you notice the
lines kind of continue on
again this is just still on the plot
and of course the next step is we need
to go ahead and predict remember we
split our data into two groups
so let's go ahead and get a result we'll
call it result and we'll assign this one
there we go
we'll set this to a data frame
there we go there's our data frame
and then oh let's call this we have our
test our test
quality because that's what we're we're
setting up on our test group with the
quality on there
then we wanted to have a predict
nice little keyword there to go and run
our random for us
and then we tell it that we're going to
predict using our rf our random forest
our testing group
1 to 11 is what we're using type equals
response
so let's go ahead and execute it that's
a mouthful on there
somewhere i left out a comma in there so
it gave me an error but you can see
right here we've set in there now we
have a result and just real quick we
could do the head of the result
result comma five and just take a look
at the first five lines
and you'll see we have the actual value
and what we predicted over here
and we could also just do all of the
results and just see what that looks
like oops
and print that out
and so it has all the different data
we're going through on there
and finally let's just go ahead and plot
there we go we'll put plot up here plot
and let's plot the result
and just see what that looks like
maybe not the best one to show to the
shareholders but it does give you an
idea on the left on the y axis you'll
see that it predicted eight
and this tells you that a lot of the
eight
and the eight scale was pretty probably
gave us
about fifty percent came up there at
eight
really maybe fifty percent it didn't
guess right but it did come up there and
say that it was at least a four five or
six even where it was considered an
eight and so on you can see these
different blocks coming in so that if
you line up the three with the three
four with the four and you kind of cross
index them a heat map would probably do
better but for this example we'll just
do a quick plot of the data
as far as how it works and you can again
see the results that we predicted over
here and you can look those over
of course back in the wine cellar we're
talking to our vineyard owner and if you
remember from before we looked at this
chart right here the error rate is 29.05
percent therefore our accuracy is
70.95 percent if you're doing a vineyard
that's probably pretty good accuracy and
always check your domain when you're
sharing this stuff because if you're
doing something that's life or death
maybe 70 accuracy might not be so good
but if you're looking at where you're
going to distribute the bottles to for
the wine and who's going to drink it you
know 70
accuracy is pretty good for that that's
probably a lot better than having no
accuracy whatsoever and not even knowing
what wines going out to who so we have
automated the process of predicting the
quality of wine i myself prefer to
predict it by sampling it that's great
thank you i'd like to visit this guy and
sample his wine and find out just how
good his different vineyards are today
we're going to cover support vector
machines svm in the hour programming
language support vector machine is a
binary classifier a supervised machine
learning algorithm and in this video we
will learn what all that means so what's
in it for you well we'll discuss what
machine learning is what classification
is and what is support vector machine
we'll also cover understanding support
vector machine understanding an
extension of support vector machine the
svm kernel and we'll cover a use case
classifying horses and mules so what is
machine learning the ability of a
computer to learn from data without
explicit programming the machine learns
from the existing data and predicts
future data so our data set must contain
known outcomes and it must have
sufficient amount of data with those
known outcomes so that the machine can
learn take the data ingest it apply the
machine learning algorithm the algorithm
learns creates a model analyzes the
model and then uses that model to make
predictions machine learning algorithms
come in three major flavors supervised
learning algorithms unsupervised
learning algorithms and reinforcement
learning and today we'll cover
classification under supervised learning
supervised meaning the data set has
known outcomes if it were unsupervised
it would not have known outcomes and we
wouldn't have the categories or classes
necessary for the machine to learn but
under supervised learning we do have the
known outcomes in the data set and under
supervised learning there are two major
types of machine learning algorithms
classification which we'll cover today
support vector machine and regression
classification you predict categories
and in regression you generally predict
values so while we look at supervised
learning keep in mind that
classification
can really be considered
multi-dimensional in the sense that
sometimes you only have two classes yes
or no two or false and sometimes you
have more than two classes sometimes you
have say under risk management or risk
modeling low risk medium risk or high
risk and svm is a binary classifier it
is a classifier used for those true
false yes no types of classification
problems and in supervised learning
features are important if there are a
lot of features svm may be the better
classification algorithm choice as
opposed to say logistic regression so
for supervised learning the computer is
presented with example inputs and their
desired outputs those known outcomes and
the goal is to learn a general rule that
maps inputs to those outputs for example
bug detection or customer churn or stock
price prediction not the value of the
stock price but whether or not it will
rise or fall and weather prediction
sunny not sunny rain no rain the
classification algorithms generally take
past data data that we have those known
outcomes train the model take new data
once the model is trained ingest it into
the model and create predictions is it a
truck or is it a car and keep in mind
that i said features are important and
the number of features whether or not
those features are applicable to your
problem is a whole different discussion
but in some sense you know probably
intuitively that the color of a car
really isn't indicative of whether or
not it's a car or a truck but the length
of the vehicle or the number of axles or
the weight or the amount of seating may
be more applicable to the algorithm into
training the model so what is support
vector machine support vector machine or
svm is a type of classification
algorithm which classifies data based on
its features and svm will classify any
new element into one of those two
classes so we'll give it some inputs the
algorithm will segregate and classify
the data and then create the outputs and
next when we ingest new data an unknown
fruit variable in this example the
algorithm will correctly classify the
fruit apple versus orange so now let's
understand what an svm is and if you
want to understand support vector
machine you really need a good example
and i know that cricut is a wonderful
game i don't know a lot about it but i
know it's very popular around the world
and we're going to use cricket as an
example of svm so we'll classify qriket
players into batsmen or bowlers using
the runs to wicket ratio so a player
with more runs would be considered a
batsman and a player with more wickets
would be considered a bowler and if we
could take a data set say of people
cricket players with runs and wickets in
columns next to their names we could
create a plot a two-dimensional plot in
this example clear separation between
qriket players considered bowlers and
those cricket players considered batsman
and you don't always have a data set
this clean where there is a clear
segregation of data bowlers versus
batsman but for the sake of
understanding svm this example does well
so before we do any separation before we
apply any high-level mathematics let's
just take a look at an unknown value a
new data coming into our data set and
that datum we don't know what class it
belongs to that datum is
a bowler or a batsman we know that much
but we don't know should we consider
that cricket player a batsman or a
bowler and so we want to draw a decision
boundary some type of line separating
the two classes so that we can use that
decision boundary to classify the new
data point of course we could draw lines
there's a yellow line a green line a
blue line there's actually not just
three lines but an infinite number of
lines that we could draw between those
two classes so which one do we pick and
this is kind of reminiscent of simple
linear regression where we find the line
of best fit we want the line of best
separation we want a line that clearly
separates those two groups as much as
possible once we have the correct line
we would be able to classify the new
data point but in this example you can
see if we pick yellow the new data point
would be a bowler but if we picked green
or blue the new data point would be a
batsman so we need the one that best
separates the data what line best
separates the data we'll find the best
line by computing the maximum margin
from equidistance support vectors now
support vectors in this context simply
means the two points
one from each class that are closest
together but that maximize the distance
between them or the margin so the word
vector here you may think well he really
means points data points well in
two-dimensional space yes and maybe even
in three-dimensional space but once you
get into higher dimensional spaces when
you get more and more features in your
data set you have to consider these as
vectors you can no longer really
describe them as points so we call them
vectors and the reason they're support
vectors is because the two
vectors that are closest together that
maximize the distance between the two
groups support the algorithm so that's
why we call them support vectors so if
you look at our example there are a
couple of points at the top that are
pretty close to one another and a couple
of points at the bottom of that graph
that are pretty close to each other and
i'm not really sure looking at the graph
which two are closest but clearly those
points are the ones we need to consider
the rest of the other points are too far
away from the rest of the other points
in other words the bowler points are far
to the right and the batsman data points
are far to the left so we'll look at
these four points to begin with
mathematically we would calculate the
distance among all of these points and
we would minimize that distance once we
pick the support vectors we'll draw a
dividing line and then measure the
distance from each support vector to the
line the best line will always have the
greatest margin or distance between the
support vectors if we consider the
yellow line as a decision boundary the
player with the new data point would be
considered a bowler the margins don't
appear to be maximum though so maybe we
can come up with a better line so let's
take two other support vectors and we'll
draw the decision boundary between those
and then we will calculate the margin
and notice now that the unknown data
point the new value would be considered
a batsman we would continue doing this
and obviously a computer does it much
quicker than a human being over and over
and over again until we found the
correct decision boundary with the
greatest margin and in this case if you
look at the green decision boundary the
green line appears to have the maximum
margin compared to the other two and so
let's consider this the boundary of
greatest margin and now classify our
unknown data value and now clearly it
belongs in the batsman's class the green
line divides the data perfectly because
it has the greatest margin or the
maximum margin between the support
vectors and now we can have confidence
in our classification that the new data
point is indeed a batsman technically
this dividing line is called a
hyperplane and the reason it's called a
hyperplane will become a little bit more
evident in a few minutes generally in
two-dimensional space we consider those
lines but in three-dimensional space and
higher dimensional spaces they're
considered planes or hyperplanes so we
always tend to refer to them as
hyperplanes and the hyperplane that has
the maximum distance from the support
vectors is the one we want so sometimes
called the positive hyperplane d plus is
the shortest distance to the closest
positive point and d minus sometimes
called a negative hyperplane has the
closest shortest distance to the closest
negative point and the sum of d positive
and d negative is called the distance
margin so if you calculate those two
distances and add them up that's the
distance margin and we always want to
maximize that if we don't maximize it we
can have a misclassification and you can
see the yellow margin is much smaller
than the green margin so this problem
set is two-dimensional because the
classification is only between two
classes and so we would call this a
linear svm now we're going to take a
look at kernel svm and if you notice in
this picture this is a great depiction
of a plane not a line this is
three-dimensional space so that's the
plane that separates those two classes
so what if our two-dimensional data
looks like this what if there's no clear
linear separation between the two
classes and machine learning parlance we
would say that these are not linearly
separable how could we get support
vector machine to work on data that
looks like this since we can't separate
it into two classes using a line what
we're going to do and clearly there's no
line i mean convince yourself there's no
line that goes and separates those two
classes so what we would do is we would
apply some type of transformation to a
higher dimension we would apply a
function called a kernel function to the
data set such that the data set would be
transformed into a higher dimension a
dimension high enough where we could
clearly separate the two groups the two
classes in this case was a plane much
the same way you saw the picture a few
slides ago where the plane was
separating the two classes here we
clearly could draw some planes between
the green dots and the red dots and of
course we could draw an infinite number
of planes separating those two classes
but we would draw the one that would
maximize the margin so if we let r be
the number of dimensions then the kernel
function would convert a given
two-dimensional space to a
three-dimensional space and as i said
once the data is separated in three
dimensions we can apply svm and separate
the two groups using a two-dimensional
plane and this is analogous in the
higher dimensions and that last picture
on the right hand side would be some
type of depiction of a higher dimension
hyperplane and there are more than one
type of kernel function there's gaussian
rbf kernel sigmoid kernel polynomial
kernel depending on the dimension and
how you want to transform the data there
are more than one choice for kernel
functions so now let's go through a use
case let's take a look at horses and
mules and see if we can use svm to
classify some new data so the problem
statement is classifying horses and
mules and we're going to use height and
weight as the two features and obviously
horses and mules typically in general
tend to weigh differently and tend to
stand taller so we'll take a data set
we'll import the data set we'll make
sure we have our libraries the
e1071 library has support vector machine
algorithms built in we'll compute the
support vectors using the library once
the data is used to train the algorithm
we'll plot the hyperplane get a visual
sense of how the data is separated and
if it's two-dimensional or
three-dimensional that's great remember
if it's higher dimensional it's tough to
plot those and then we'll use the new
model the trained model to classify new
values in general we would have a
training set a test set and then ingest
the new data but for our example we're
just going to use the whole data set to
train the algorithm and then see how it
performs and once we see how it performs
we'll see did we get a horse did we
predict a horse when we had a horse did
we predict a mule when we had a mule so
here's the r code of course if you want
to run this r code you'll have to
install r and then our studio then
you'll have to ingest the data and then
you'll have to create an indicator
variable to help us with our plots we'll
install our libraries install the
package if you don't already have it
installed i do and then call the library
up into the r session that you're
working we'll create the data frame from
the data that was ingested we will then
view the data frame and of course we
have to explore the data frame hoping
that we don't have missing values or we
don't have outliers if we do have
missing values or outliers we'll have to
either impute those values or delete
those values but in this case let's hope
we don't have any and now for a quick
demo on support vector machines so we
have a working directory where my data
is stored and i'm going to set the
working directory to that data source
and read the data file into r and now
i'm going to create a vector that really
is just an indicator variable it's the
negative ones and the ones that indicate
whether it's a mule or a horse negative
one for a mule positive one for a horse
so i'll create that vector and svm
there's a great package e1071
great library that has the support
vector machine functions that we're
going to use and now i'm going to create
the data frame i'm going to take my data
and i'm going to add to it the is horse
vector
and now let's just take a peek and as
you can see there's the height weight
and whether or not the animal was a mule
or a horse so remember machine learning
we take a data source with known
outcomes and we apply our algorithm to
that data source in this case a data
frame of heights weights and the
indicator variable and then we use the
machine learning algorithm to learn from
that data with those known results so
now let's plot the data the height
versus weight and as you can see the
horses tend to be a lot taller and weigh
a lot more than the mules so now let's
run our algorithm our svm model against
the data and the key here is that it's a
linear model and we've run it and great
now we have a model let's look at the
summary of the model and as you can see
there's the formula that it ran and some
of the information about the vectors and
the classes and there are two support
vectors so now let's find those two
support vectors on our graph and this
might be a little hard to see the
orange outline around this point and
this point indicate that those are the
two vectors that will support this model
and thus we call them the support
vectors now let's get the parameters of
the hyperplane from the model and let's
plot a line that will be our hyperplane
there's our hyperplane line and
therefore to the left and below our
mules and to the right and above our
horses above that line let's take a few
new observations and i've encoded these
so that it would be illustrative we'll
take these new
observations and we'll plot them
and i'm going to generate a new plot red
being the horses black dots being the
mules i'll create an x and y axis i'm
going to plot three
dots and you can see one of them the
green dot the first one kind of falls
near the mules the blue one kind of
falls near the horses and visually we
might conclude hey one's a mule one's a
horse but what about the orange dot well
for the orange dot we really need our
hyperplane we really need something to
clearly indicate which side it's on and
of course by looking at this data
visualization you can tell that the
orange dot is probably a mule and let's
verify those results by sticking those
observations into our model and predict
some outcomes and down below you can see
that for the three data points one two
and three the first one the green one
was negative one that's a mule the
second one was a positive one that's
blue that's the blue point which was a
horse and the third one which we weren't
sure about but clearly the svm model
correctly predicted that that third
point would be a negative one would be a
mule and we can visually see that by the
hyperplane on the graph so that's a
quick example of svm in general support
vector machines are binary classifiers
we don't use them for higher level
classification if you had three or more
classes you might want to use something
like random forest what applications you
can use it for face detection text
categorization image classification and
bioinformatics really anywhere that you
have the need to classify things into
two groups so let's dive into what is
clustering what is clustering so
we'll have a group of people here
hanging out at a table or local coffee
shop i'm guessing coffee shops since
they all have the same mugs and one of
them is uh trying to figure out what
they're gonna do i have 20 places to
cover in four days i guess he's going
traveling that sounds fun one of those
breeze through costa rica or visiting
the us or going to to europe to go visit
all the highlights he's got 20 places he
wants to go and he wants to hit him in
four days very ambitious
and how will i manage to cover all of
them that's the question that he's
coming up how am i going to get to all
these different places in the short time
i have maybe he's a sales team so he has
20 places he's got to do demos for you
can make use of clustering by grouping
the places into four clusters
each of these clusters will have places
which are close by so we're going to
cluster them together by what is closest
to the other one then each day you can
visit one cluster and cover all the
places in the cluster great that's a
great idea you know if you're going to
hit four different places maybe you're
going to cluster whatever streets are
closest together so you don't have to
travel spend all your time traveling the
method of dividing the objects into
clusters which are similar between them
and are dissimilar to the objects
belonging to another cluster so this is
a formal definition of clustering and we
have here we have what we call
hierarchical clustering and partial
clustering and we're going to go more
into detail on hierarchical clustering
and you'll see the difference between
the two where partial clustering doesn't
have the descending graph it just has
groups of things
and under hierarchical clustering we're
going to go over agglomerative and
divisive and you can think of
agglomerative of bringing things
together and divisive as dividing them
apart and then partial clustering the
two most common ones are k-means that's
probably the most common use for partial
clustering and there's also fuzzy c
means and there's other ways of
clustering and other algorithms out
there but these are the two big ones
k-means really being the most common one
used but we're not going to dig too deep
into partial clustering because we're
studying hierarchical clustering today
so what is clustering well the
applications of clustering are pretty
numerous we have things like customer
segmentation what people kind of belong
together how do we group them together
we have social network analysis
so social networks we might look at
sentiments what group of people like
something what group of people don't
like something and then we can use that
sentiments to suggest new cells for them
you know this whole group is into
harley-davidson motorcycles so we cater
to them to sell them harley-davidson
motorcycle parts and we find out that
people in that group also like leather
jackets they also like motorcycle boots
and they like bandanas my brother's into
harley-davidson so
that's why i picked that kind of funny
example but you can kind of see we look
for similarities between these people
and then we group them together
accordingly and that's a good
sentimental clustering is very common in
so many things today we want to know the
sentiments on stocks who is interested
in stocks who's not sentimental analysis
we talked about customer segmentation in
cells well we want to know what kind of
sentimental view people have on
different restaurants if we're going to
open up a new restaurant or a new
putting stores in and of course city
planning a lot of this i just kind of
aimed at the city planning side sitting
planning is big with clustering we want
to cluster things together so that they
work we don't want to put a industrial
zone in the middle of somebody's
neighborhood where they're not going to
enjoy it or have a commercial zone right
in the middle of the industrial zone
where no one's going to want to go next
to a factory to go eat a high-end meal
or dinner so it's very big in city
planning it's also very big in just
pre-processing data into other models so
when we're exploring data being able to
cluster things together reveal things in
the data we never thought about and then
once we have it clustered we can put
that into another model to help us
figure out what it is we want for our
solution so let's go a little deeper
into hierarchical clustering let's
consider we have a set of cars and we
have a group similar we want to group
similar ones together so below we have
you'll see four different cars down
there and we get two clusters of car
types sedan and suv so if you're just
looking at it you can probably think oh
yeah we'll put the sedans together and
the suvs together and then at last we
can group everything into one cluster so
we just have just cars so you can see as
we have this we make a nice little tree
this is very common when you see anybody
talks about hierarchical clustering this
is usually what you see and what comes
out of it we terminate when we are left
with only one cluster so we have as you
can see we bring them all together we
have one cluster we can't bring it
together anymore because they're all
together hierarchical clustering is
separating data into different groups
based on some measure of similarity so
we have to find a way to measure what
makes them alike and what makes them
different agglomerative clustering is
known as a bottom up approach remember i
said think of that as bringing things
together you see i think the latin term
aglow is together because you have your
glomerate rocks where all the different
pieces of rocks are in there so we want
to bring everything together that's a
bottom up
and then divisive is we're going to go
from the top down so we take one huge
cluster and we start dividing it up into
two clusters into three four five and so
on
digging even deeper into how
hierarchical clustering works
let's consider we have a few points on a
plane so this plane is 2d so we have an
x y coordinates kind of makes it easy
we're going to start with measure the
distance so we want to figure a way to
compute the distance between each point
each data point is a cluster of its own
remember if we're going from the bottom
up agglomerative then we have each point
being its own cluster we try to find the
least distance between two data points
to form a cluster and then once we find
those with the least distance between
them we start grouping them together so
we start forming clusters of multiple
points this is represented in a
tree-like structure called dendogram so
there's another key word dendogram and
you can see it is it's just a branch
we've looked at before and we do the
second group the same so it gets its own
dendogram and the third gets its own
dendogram and then we might group two
groups together so now those two groups
are all under one dendogram because
they're closer together than the p1 and
p2 and then we terminate when we are
left with one cluster so we finally
bring it all together you can see on the
right how we've come up all the way up
to the top whoops and we have the gray
hierarchical box coming in there and
connecting them so we have just one
cluster and that's a good place to
terminate because there is no way we can
bring them together any further so how
do we measure the distance between the
data points
i mean this is really where it starts
getting interesting up until now you can
kind of eyeball and say hey these look
together but when you have thousands of
data points how are we going to measure
those distances and there is a lot of
ways to get the distance measure so
let's go and take a look at that
distance measures will determine the
similarity between two elements and it
will influence the shape of the clusters
and we have euclidean distance measure
we have squared euclidean distance
measure which is almost the same thing
but with less computations and we have
the manhattan distance measure which
will give you slightly different results
and we have the cosine distance measure
which again is very similar to the
euclidean playing with triangles and
sometimes it can compute faster
depending on what kind of data you're
looking at so let's start with euclidean
distance measure the most common is we
want to know the distance between the
two points so if we have point p and
point q the euclidean distance is the
ordinary straight line it is the
distance between the two points in
euclidean space and you should recognize
d equals in this case we're going to sum
all the points so if there was more than
one point we could figure out the
distance to the not more than one points
this is the sum of more than two
dimensions
so we can have the distance between each
of the different dimensions squared and
that will give us and then take the
square root of that and that gives us
the actual distance between them and
they should look familiar from euclidean
geometry maybe you haven't played too
much with multiple dimensions so the
summation symbol might not look familiar
to you but it's pretty straightforward
as you add the distance between each of
the two different points squared so if
your y difference was 2 minus 1 squared
would be 2 and then you take the
difference between the x again squared
and if there was a z coordinates it
would be you know z1 minus z2 squared
and then take the square root of that
and sum it all or sum it all together
and then take the square root of it so
to make it compute faster since the
difference in distances whether one is
farther apart or closer together than
the other we can do what's called the
squared euclidean distance measurement
this is identical to the euclidean
measurement but we don't take the square
root at the end there's no reason to it
certainly gives us the exact distance
but as far as doing calculations as to
which one's bigger or smaller than the
other one it won't make a difference so
we'll just go with the so we just get
rid of that that final square root
computes faster and it gives us the
pretty much the euclidean squared
distance on there now the manhattan
distance measurement is a simple sum of
horizontal and vertical components or
the distance between two points measured
along axes at right angles now this is
different because you're not looking at
the direct line between them and in
certain cases the individual distances
measured will give you a better result
now generally that's not true most times
you go with the euclidean squared method
because that's very fast and easy to see
but the manhattan distance is you
measure just the y value and you take
the absolute value of it and you measure
just the x difference you take the
absolute value of it and just the z and
if you had more you know different
dimensions in there a b c d e f however
many dimensions you would just take the
absolute value of the difference of
those dimensions and then we have the
cosine distance similarity measures the
angle between the two vectors and as you
can see as the two vectors get further
and further apart the cosine distance
gets larger so it's another way to
measure the distance very similar to the
euclidean so you're still looking at the
same kind of measurement so should have
a similar result as the first two but
keep in mind the manhattan will have a
very different result and you can end up
with a bias with the manhattan if your
data is very skewed if one set of values
is very large and another set of values
is very small but that's a little bit
beyond the scope of this it's just
important to know that about the
manhattan distance so let's dig into the
agglomerative clustering and agglometric
clustering begins with each element as a
separate cluster and then we merge them
into a larger cluster how do we
represent a cluster of more than one
point so we're going to kind of mix the
distance together with the actual
agglomerative and see what that looks
like and we're actually going to have
three q key questions that are going to
be answered here so how do we represent
a cluster more than one point so we want
to look at the math what it looks like
mathematically and geometrically how do
we determine the nearness of clusters
when to stop combining clusters always
important to have your computer script
or your whatever you're working on have
a termination point so it's not in going
on internally
we've all done that if you do any kind
of computer programming or writing of
script let's assume that we have six
data points in a euclidean space so
again we're dealing with x y and z in
this case just x and y
so how do we represent a cluster more
than one point let's take a look at that
and first we're going to make use of
centroids very common terminology in a
lot of machine learning languages when
we're grouping things together so we're
going to make use of centroids which is
the average of its points
and you can see here we're going to take
the 1 2 and the 2 1 and we're going to
group them together because they're
close and if we were looking at all the
points we look for those that are
closest and start with those and we're
going to take those two we're going to
compute a point in the middle and we'll
give that point 1 5 1.5 1.5 and that's
going to be the centroid of those two
points and next we start measuring like
another group of points we got four one
five zero when they're pretty close
together so we'll go ahead and set up a
centroid of those two points in this
case it would be the
4.5 and
0.5 would be the measurements on those
two points and once we have the centroid
of the two groups we find out that the
next closest point to a centroid is over
on the left and so we're going to take
this and say oh 0 0 is closest to the
1.5 1.5 centroid so let's go ahead and
group that together and we compute a new
centroid based on those three points so
now we have a centroid of 1.1 or 1 comma
1. and then we also do this again with
the last point the 5 3 and it computes
into the first group and you can see our
dendrogram on the right is growing so we
have each of these points are become
connected and we start grouping them
together and finally we get a centroid
of that group 2 and then finally the
last thing we want to do is combine the
two groups by their centroids and you
can see here we end up with one large
group and it'll have its own centroid
although usually they don't compute the
last centroid we just put them all
together so when do we stop combining
clusters well hopefully is pretty
obvious to you in this case when they
all got to be one but there are actually
many approaches to it
so first pick a number of clusters k up
front and this is done in the fact that
we don't want to look at 200 in clusters
we only want to look at the top five
clusters or something like that so we
decide the number of clusters required
in the beginning and we terminate when
we reach the value k
so if you look back on our clustering
let me just go back a couple screens
you'll see how we clustered these all
together and we might want just the two
clusters and so we look at just the top
two or maybe we only want three clusters
and so we would compute which one of
these has a wider spread to it or
something like that there's other
computations to know how to connect them
and we'll look at that in just a minute
but to note that when we pick the k
value we want to limit the information
that's coming in so that can be very
important especially if you're feeding
it into another algorithm that requires
three values or you set it to four
values and you need to know that value
coming in so we might take the
clustering and say okay only three
clusters that's all we want for k so the
possible challenges this only makes
sense when we know the data well so when
you're clustering with k clusters you
might already know that domain and know
that that makes sense but if you're
exploring brand new data you might have
no idea how many clusters you really
need to explore that data with let's
consider the value of k to be 2. so in
this case in our previous example we
stop and we are left with two clusters
and you can see here that this is where
they came together the best while still
keeping separate the data the second
approach is stop when the next merge
would create a cluster with low cohesion
so we keep clustering until the next
merge of clusters creates a bad cluster
low cohesion set up on there that means
the point is so close to being between
two clusters it doesn't make sense to
bring them together but how is cohesion
defined oh let's dig a little deeper
into cohesion the diameter of a cluster
so we're looking at the actual diameter
of our cluster and the diameter is the
maximum distance between any pair of
points in the cluster we terminate when
the diameter of a new cluster exceeds
the threshold so as that diameter gets
bigger and bigger we don't want the two
circles or clusters to overlap
we have radius of a cluster radius is
the maximum distance of a point from
centroid we terminate when the radius of
a new cluster exceeds the threshold
again we're not we don't want things to
overlap so when it crosses that
threshold and it's overlapping with
other data we stop so let's look at
divisive clustering remember we went
from the bottom up now we want to go
from the top down device of clustering
approach begins with a whole set and
proceeds to divide it into smaller
clusters so we start with a single
cluster composed of all the data points
we split it into different clusters this
can be done using monothetic divisive
methods
what is a monothetic divisive method and
we'll go backwards and let's consider
the example we took in the agglomerative
clustering to understand this so we
consider a space with six points in it
just like we did before same points we
had before and we name each point in the
cluster so we have in this case we just
gave it a letter value a b
c d e f
since we follow top down approach and
divisive clustering obtain all possible
splits into two columns so we want to
know where you could split it here and
we could do like a a b split and a cdef
split we could do bce adf and you can
see this starts generating a huge amount
of data
e abcdef and so for each split we can
compute cluster sum of squares and we
can see here the actually have the
formula out for us b j 12 equals n one
of absolute value of x minus absolute
value of x squared so again we're
computing all the different distances in
their squared back to your kind of
euclidean distances on that and so we
can actually compute b and j between
clusters one and two and we have the
mean of the cluster and the grand mean
depending on the number of members in
the cluster and we select the cluster
with the largest sum of squares
let's assume that the sum of squared
distance is largest for the third split
we had up above and that's where we
split the abc out and if we split the
abc out we're left with the def on the
other side
we again find the sum of square
distances and split it into clusters so
we go from a b c we might find that the
a splits into b c
and d into e f and again you start to
see that hierarchical dendrogram coming
down as we start splitting everything
apart and finally we might have a splits
in b and c and then each one gets their
own def
and it continues to divide until we get
little nodes at the end and every data
has its own point or until we get to k
if we have set a k value so we've kind
of learned a little bit about the
background and some of the math and
hierarchical clustering let's go ahead
and dive into a demo and our demo today
is going to be for the problem statement
we're going to look at u.s oil so a u.s
oil organization needs to know it cells
in various states in u.s and cluster the
states based on the sales so what are
the steps involved in setting this
problem up so the steps we're going to
look at and this is really useful for
just about any processing of data
although i believe we're going to be
doing this in r today we're going to
import the data set so we'll explore our
data a little bit there create a scatter
plot it's always good to have a visual
if you can once you have a visual you
can know if you're really far off in the
model you choose to cluster the data in
or how many splits you need and then
we're going to normalize the data so
we're going to fix the data up so it
processes correctly we'll talk more
detail about normalization when we get
there and then calculate the euclidean
distance
and finally we'll create our dendogram
so it looks nice and pretty and we have
something we can show to our
shareholders so that they have something
to go on and know why they gave us all
that money in salary for the year so we
go ahead and open up our and we're
actually using our studio which is the
really it has some nice features in it
it automatically sets up the three
windows where we have our script file on
the upper left
and then we can execute that script and
it'll come down and put it into the
console bottom left and execute it and
then we have our plots off to the right
and i've got it zoomed in hopefully not
too large a font but large enough that
you can see it
and let's just go ahead and take a look
at some of the script going in here
it's clustering analysis and we're going
to work we'll call it my data
and we're going to assign it in r this
is a symbol for assigning and we're
going to go read csv
read csv file
and we'll put that in brackets
and let's before we go any further let's
just look at the data outside of r it's
always nice to do if you can
and the file is going to be called
utilities.csv
this would also be the time to get the
full path so you have the right path to
your file
and remember that you can always post in
the comments down below
and when you post down there just let us
know you want to connect up with simply
learn so that they can get you this file
so you can get the same file we're
working on you can repeat it and see how
this works this is utilities.csv it's a
comma separated variable file so it's
pretty straightforward and you can see
here they have the city fixed charge and
a number of different features to the
data and so we have our ror cost load
demand cells
nuclear fuel cost on here and then going
down the other side we have u.s cities
arizona boston they have central us i
guess they're grouping a number of areas
together
the commonwealth area you can see down
here in nevada new england northern us
oklahoma the pacific region
and so on so we have a nice little chart
of different data they brought in
and so i'm going to take that complete
path that ends in the utilities.csv
and we're going to import that file let
me just enlarge this all the way
upside an extra set of brackets here
somehow maybe i missed a set of brackets
this can happen if you're not careful
you can get brackets on one side and not
the other or in this case i got double
brackets on each side there we go
and then the magic hotkeys in this case
are your control enter
which will let me go ahead and run the
script
and so i've now loaded the data and as
you can see i went ahead and shrunk the
plot since we're going to be looking at
the window down below
and we can simply convert the data to a
string
now all of us do this automatically the
first time we say hey just print it all
out as a string and then we get this
huge mess of stuff
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
so
when you can see here they have you can
probably kind of pull it together is
looking at it but let's go ahead and
just do the head
i will do the head of my data
there we go and ctrl enter on that and
the head shows the first five rows
you'll see this in a lot of different
scripts in r it's you type in head and
then in brackets you put your data and
it comes through in this the first five
rows as you can see below
and it shows arizona boston central and
it has the same columns we just looked
at so we have the fixed charge the ror
the cost the load the
d demand i'm not an expert in oil so i'm
not even sure what d demand is
cells i'm guessing nuclear how much of
it's supplied by nuclear
and the actual fuel cost
and then the different states that it's
in are different areas
and one of the wonders of r is all these
cool easy to use tools that are so quick
so we'll do pairs
and pairs creates a nice graph let me go
ahead and run this
uh whoops the reason it gave me an error
is because i forgot to resize it so let
me bring my plot way out so we can see
it and let's run that again
and you'll see here that we have a nice
graph of the different data and how it
plots together how the different points
kind of come together
this is neat because if you look at this
i would look at this and say hey this is
a great candidate for
some kind of clustering and the reason
is is when i look at any two pairs let's
go down to say cells and fuel costs
towards the bottom right
and when you look at them where they
cross over you sort of see things how
they group together but it's a little
confusing you can't really pinpoint how
they group together you could probably
look at these two and say yeah there's
pretty good commonalities there and if
you look at any of the other pairs
you'll start seeing some patterns there
also and so we really want to know what
are the patterns on all of them put
together not just any two of them but
the whole setup
let me go ahead and shrink my this down
for just a second just a notch here
and let's create a
scatter plot
and this is simply just use the term
plot in brackets
and then which values do we want to plot
and if we remember when we looked at the
data earlier let me just go back this
way
in this case let's go ahead and compare
two just two values to see how they look
and we'll do fuel cost in cells
and it's in my data
so we'll let them know which two columns
we're looking at next to each other
and it will open up our plot thing and
then go ahead and execute that
and we can see on those
close up of what we were just looking at
in the pairs
and if i was eyeballing this i would say
oh look there's a kind of a cluster up
here of five items and
this one it's hard to tell which cluster
to be with but maybe it's six you go in
the top one and you have a middle
cluster and a bottom cluster maybe two
different clusters
so you can sort of group them together
fuel cost and the cells and see how they
connect with each other
and again that's only two different
values we're looking at so in the long
run we want to look at all of them
and then the people in the back
they sent me the script so we can go
ahead and add labels so with my data
text fuel cost cells the labels equal
city
position four
these are numbers you can kind of play
with till they look nice and oops again
i forgot to resize my plot it doesn't
like having it too small and we'll run
that
i mistyped something in here
oh i did a lowercase d and they did a
capital d there we go
so now we can go in here and do this
with my data and you can see a little
hard to see on my screen with all the
different things in there it plots the
actual cities so we can now see where
all the cities are in connection with in
this case fuel cost and cells
so we have a nice label to go with the
graph
and then we can also go ahead and plot
in this case let's do
oh the r o r oops
and we'll do that
also with the
cells
and do my data
remember to leave it lowercase this time
so we plot those two
we'll come over here and it's gonna i'm
surprised it didn't give me an error
and then we'll also add in the
with statement so we put some nice
labels in there
and it's going to be the same as before
except instead of doing the fuel cost
cells we want the r cells and we'll
execute that
oops and of course it gives me an error
because i shrunk it down
so let's redo those two again
there we go and we can see now we have
the ror with cells and we'd probably get
a slightly different clustering here if
i was looking at these cities they're
probably different than we had before
but you could probably look at this and
say yeah these kind of go together and
those kind of go together but again
we're going to be looking at all of them
instead of just one or two
and so at this point we want to dive
into the next step we're going to start
looking at a little bit of coding or
scripting here
this is very important because we're
going to be looking at normalization
we put that in there normalization
and if you've done any of the other
machine learning skills and setup this
should start to look very normal in your
pre-processing of data whether you're in
r or python or any of these scripts we
really want to make sure you normalize
your data so it's not biased
remember we're dealing with distances
and if i have let's say the ror is even
look at this graph here on the right
you can see where my ror varies between
8 and 14.
that's a very small variable and our
cells varies between four thousand and
sixteen thousand
so you can imagine the distance between
four thousand and eight thousand which
is a distance of four thousand versus
eight to ten versus two
the cells is going to dominate so if we
do any kind of special work on this
it's going to look at cells and it's
going to cluster them just by the cells
alone and then ror might have a little
tiny effect of 2 versus 4 000.
we want to level the playing field
turns out there's actually a number of
ways in script to normalize
so i'm just going to put in
the code that they put together in the
back for me and let's talk about it a
little bit so we have z we're going to
assign it to my data
and it's go ahead and
we're going to do a little reshaping
across all rows
or i mean across all columns so each of
the rows are going to have a little
reshaping there
and then we're going to get m which
stands for means
and we're going to apply it to
my data so again we want to go ahead and
create a
the most common variable in there
and then s is going to be the sd stands
for standard deviation
so instead of just doing a lot of times
what they do with normalization of data
is we just reshape the data everything
between 0 and 1.
so that if the lower end is 8 that now
becomes 0 and the upper end is 14 that
now becomes 1.
that doesn't help if it is not a linear
set of data
so with this we're going to look for the
means and the standard deviation for
reshaping the data
and that way the most common values now
become the kind of like the center point
and then the standard deviation is how
big the spread so we want the standard
deviation to be equal amongst all of
them and then finally we go ahead and
take z and with the z we're going to
reassign it and we're going to scale the
original my data which we re shaped
based on m and based on the standard
deviation
and the 2 in here that just means we're
looking at everything in kind of a xy
kind of plot
and we can quickly run these control
enter control enter control enter
control enter so now we have z which is
a scaled version of my data
and now we can go ahead and calculate
the euclidean distance
oops calcu
there we go
and in
r this is so easy once you've gotten to
here we've done all that pre data
processing
we'll call it distance
and we'll assign this to
dist
so d-i-s-t
is
the computation for getting the
euclidean distance
and we can just put z in there because
we've already reformatted and scaled z
to fit what we want
let me go ahead and just hit enter on
that
and i'm going to widen my left hand side
again
i'm always curious what does this data
look like so let's just type in distance
which will print the variable down below
oops
you have to hit ctrl enter
and this prints out a huge amount of
information
as you can see just kind of streams down
there
and let's go ahead and large this
and i don't know about you but when i
look at something like this it doesn't
mean a whole lot to me other than i see
two three four five six
and then you kind of have the top part
six seventeen eighteen
so imagine this is like a huge chart
is what we're looking at
and we can go ahead and use print oh
distance
digits
[Applause]
equal three and let's run that
also keep forgetting that it has to go
through the graph on the right and we
see a different slightly different
output in here let me just open this up
so we can see we're looking at
and by cutting down the distance you can
start to see the patterns here if it's
looking at the different distances
so if i go to the top we have the
distance between one and two
one and three one and four one and five
one and six and then two and three
and so on obviously distance between
itself is zero and it doesn't repeat the
data so we don't care to see two versus
one again because we already know the
distance between one and two
and so we have a nice view all the
distances in the chart and that's what
we're looking at right here and it's a
little easier to read that's why we did
the print statement up here to do digits
equals three make it a little bit
smaller we could even just do digits oh
let's just do two see what that looks
like we might lose some data on this one
if it's uh if something's way off
but we have a nice setup and we can see
the different distances and that's what
we were computed here between each of
the points
and then the whole reason we're doing
this is to get ourselves a nice
dendogram going a nice clustering
dendogram we'll do a couple of these
looking at different things
we'll take a variable hc.l and we're
going to assign it
h cluster
and then distance
that easy we've already computed the
distances
so the h clustering does all the work
for us
and then we hit enter on there so now we
have our hcl which is assigned the h
clustering
computation based on distances and apart
and then i'm going to expand my graph
because we would like to go ahead and
see what this looks like and we can
simply plot that
and hit the control enter so it runs
and look at that we have a really nice
clustering dendrogram
except when i look at it the first thing
i notice is it really shows like numbers
down below
now if you were a shareholder and some
data scientist came up to you and said
look at this this is what it means you'd
be looking at that going what the heck
does 3 9 14 19 1 18 mean
so let's give it some words there
so let's do the same plot with our hcl
hc there we go
and let's add in labels and this is just
one of the commands and plots
so we have labels equals my data
and then under my data we want to know
the city
and we'll have it hang minus one that's
just the instructions to make it pretty
so we'll run that
oops i accidentally ran just hang my one
let me try that again
there we go okay so now you can see what
it's done and the hang my one turns it
sideways that way we can see
central which is central us and kentucky
and we start to actually get some
information off our clustering setup
and the information you start looking at
is that when we put all the information
together you probably want to look at
central america and kentucky together
oklahoma and texas has a lot of
commonality as does arizona and southern
u.s
and you can even group all five of those
florida oklahoma texas arizona
and southern u.s
these regions for some reason share a
lot of similarities and so we want to
start asking what those similarities are
but this gives us a place to look it
says hey these things really go together
you should be grouping these together as
far as your cells and what's what you're
doing
and then one of the things you might
want to do is also we can do the
dendrogram average
this changes how we do the clustering
so it looks very similar like we had
before and there's our hcl we're going
to assign it
we're going to do an h cluster
we're still doing it on distance
oops distance
and this time we're going to set the
method to average so we can change the
methodology in which it computes
the values
and before if you remember correctly we
did median median's a little bit
different than means we did the most
common one and then we want the average
of the median
and let's go ahead and run that
and then we can plot
and here's our hcl
oops there we go here's our hcl and i
can run that plot
and you can see this changed a little
bit
so our way it computes and groups things
looks a little different than it did
before and let's go and put the cities
back in there and do the hang
control copy let me just real quickly
copy that down here
because we want the same labels
and again you can see nevada idaho pujet
i remember we were looking at
southern us and arizona texas and
oklahoma florida so the grouping really
hasn't changed too much
so we still have a very similar grouping
it's almost kind of flipped it as far as
the distance based on average has
but this is something you could actually
take to the shareholders and say hey
look these things are connected and at
which point you want to explore a little
deeper as to why they're connected
because they're going to ask you okay
how are they connected and why do we
care
that's a little bit beyond the actual
scope of what we're working on today
but we are going to cover membership
what's called a clustering membership on
there
and let's create a member we'll just
call it number one
oops the iron member dot one
and we're going to assign to this
we're gonna do cut tree
and
cut tree
it limits it so what that means is i
take my hc dot
l in here
oops there we go dot l
and so i'm taking the cluster i just
built and we want to take that cluster
and we want to limit it to just a depth
of three so we go ahead and do that
and run that one oops let me go run
there we go so now i've created my
member one
and then oops let me just move this out
of the way
we're going to do an aggregate and we're
going to use z remember z from above
and we're going to turn member one into
a list
and then we're going to aggregate that
together based on the mean let me go
ahead and enter run that
so i did member l it's actually remember
one
there we go
and if we take a look at this
we now have our group one fixed charge
and then all your different
columns listed there and most of them
should come up kind of looking between
zero and one but you'll see a lot of
variation because we're
varying it based on the means so it's a
means the standard deviation not just
forcing it in between zero and one
which is a much better way usually to
normalize your data than just doing the
zero one setup
and finally we can actually look at the
actual values
and the same chart we just did
oops
i made a mistake on there with my data
there we go okay
and again we now have our actual data
instead of looking at just the if you
looked up here it's all between zero and
one
and when we look down here
we now have some actual connections and
how far distances different data is
uh again because more of a domain issue
and understanding the oil company what
these different values means and you can
look at these as being the distances
between different items
so a little bit different view and you
have to really dig deep into this data
what we really want you to take away
from this
is the dendogram
and the charts that we did earlier
and that is the cluster output and our
nice dendogram
so this would be stage one in data
analysis of the cells again you'd have
to have a lot more domain experience to
find out what all the individual numbers
we looked at mean and what the distance
is and what's difference between central
america and kentucky and why they're
similar and why it groups all of central
kentucky florida oklahoma texas arizona
and southern u.s together into one
larger group so i'd be way beyond the
scope of this but you can see how we
start to explore data and we start to
see things in here where things are
grouped together in ways we might not
have seen before and this is a good
start for understanding and giving
advice for sales and marketing maybe
logistics city development there's all
kinds of things that kind of come
together in the hierarchical clustering
as you begin to explore data and we just
want to point out that we get three
clusters of regions with the highest
cells region with average cells region
with the lowest cells again those are
some of the things that they clustered
it around and you could actually see
where things are going on or lacking you
know it's this case if you're the lowest
cells no one wants to be in the region
of the lowest sales welcome to this
session where we will learn on time
series analysis using our programming
language so this is basically a mini
project where we will look at time
series data and how we can analyze it
visualize it to basically find some
important information or gather insights
from the data now when you talk about
time series analysis time series is
basically any data set where your values
are measured
at different points in time
so when you talk about time series data
data is usually uniformly spaced at a
specific frequency for example hourly
weather measurements you have daily
counts of website visits monthly sales
total and so on so when you talk about
time series that can also be irregularly
spaced and sporadic for example time
stamped data in computer systems event
log or history of 9 11 emergency calls
now when we work with time series data
for example here i am taking a energy
data set we can see how techniques such
as time based indexing resampling
rolling windows can help us explore
variations in electricity demand and
renewable energy supply over time now
here we will look at some aspects of
this data set which i am considering so
there is this is open power systems data
set and here is the data set i have we
can look at the data set now this is in
a simple format it has time
it basically has values for consumption
and then you have data for wind and
solar and wind plus solar so in certain
cases you have only the date and the
consumption but then if we scroll down
we will also find
data for wind solar wind plus solar and
so on so this is a time series data set
which we would want to work on
sometimes you may also have the data
collected which just does not have the
time but it may also have
time stamp that is it would have say
hour minutes and seconds and that can
also be worked upon so let's consider
this data set and let's work on this
project where we will analyze this time
series data set
now here we can work on this time series
data we can basically create some data
structures out of it such as data frames
we can do some time based indexing we
can visualize the data we can look at
the seasonality in the data look at some
frequencies and also do some trend
detection
now when you talk about this data set it
has electricity production and
consumption which is reported as daily
totals in gigawatt hours
and here are the columns of the data
which i was just showing you so you have
data you have consumption you have wind
you have solar and wind plus solar so
this is the data we have and we will
basically explore say electricity
consumption and production in germany
which has varied over time so some of
the questions which we can answer here
is when is electricity consumption
typically highest and lowest how do wind
and solar power production vary with
seasons of the year
what are the long-term trends in
electricity consumption solar power and
wind power how do wind and solar power
production compare with electricity
consumption and how has this ratio
changed over time we can also do
wrangling or cleaning of this data or
pre-processing of data and create a data
frame and then we can visualize this now
let's see how do we do that so i will
open up my r studio and let's look at
the data set so here is the data set now
i'm picking it up from my machine you
can also pick it up from github so
all the data sets or similar data sets
can be find in my github repository and
here
i can look in the data sets you will
find
a lot of different data sets here there
are some time series data sets such as
power
i can search for power or you have
basically
coal
or you have this
opsd
germany daily data set and there are
many other data sets which you can work
on
now to
get the documentation on this project
you can also look in my github
repository and you can search for
repositories
and then basically you can look in data
science and r
and here there is a project folder where
i have given the documentation sample
data set and also
your time series analysis related
document this is also the code which you
can directly import in your r studio and
you can practice or work on this project
so let's see how does that work
so first thing is we will create a data
frame
from this data set now here if you see
i am using header as true so that it
understands the heading of each column
i'm also giving row.names and i'm
specifying date so there is this date
column in the data set as i showed you
earlier let's look at it again so you
have date consumption wind solar wind
plus solar so you can suggest that date
should become the index column which can
be useful so you can do this now let's
just
create this
let's look at what does this data frame
contain
and here if you see it shows me some
data which
has been
now as a part of this data frame
structure it starts with consumption
wind solar wind plus solar and if you
see this one is becoming my index column
so i can always do a head and look at
part of the data frame using head or
tail so look at the first records so
let's see this now that shows me the
head data i can also do a tail and look
at the
ending values so if you closely see here
we have wind
solar
wind dot solar and that basically has n
a values so there are missing values but
let's look at the tail and that tells me
that there is some data available for
wind and solar and wind solar
now we can always look in a tabular
format using view
and we can look at the data so this
shows me that there are values in these
columns we see any values but if i
really scroll down
i can see some values which would be
available for wind and solar and wind
solar so i can just use view now i can
look at the dimensions of this
particular object
and that tells me there are
rows and four columns you can always
look at the structure that is check the
data type of each column which can be
very useful so if i see here i don't see
the date column because date column was
considered as an index which can be
useful but i also look at my other
columns they are of the num types so
that's the data type for each
attribute or each column here now we
would be interested in looking at this
date column so let's look at the data
type of this date column
now if i try to do this
this will show me that this is null
because date as a column does not exist
because we created it as an index so if
i look at row names
and then i search
for my data show me the index column or
row.names it tells me these are the
values that's the date column which we
are seeing here now we can access a
specific row by just doing a my data and
give the index value or row name value
so let's look at that and that shows me
based on this index you are looking at
the value
you can obviously search for a different
date
something like this you can also pass in
a vector and you can give
range of values so that is 0 1 2006 to 4
of january and we can look at this one
so it shows me
these are the values so here actually
i'm not giving a range but i'm just
selecting multiple values from row.names
now
we already know that in r you have a
summary function so you can always do a
summary and that gives you
for each column it gives you minimum
first quartile median mean third
quartile and maximum values so we are
looking at consumption
we are looking at wind solar and wind
dot solar
now this is good but then if i would
want to really visualize the data access
the data do some analysis then it would
be good to
take all the columns and then we can
later decide to change the data type of
say date column if we want to use it so
earlier i was using date as row.names or
the name of the rows or index what you
call in any other programming language
so here i will just use my data set and
i'll say header is true i'm calling it
data 2 let's look at the data and this
one shows me
five columns where in my first column is
the date
consumption wind solar and so on now
looking at the structure so let's look
at the data type
so it tells me that if now i'm
interested in looking at the date column
from my data to data frame it tells me
it is a factor
with four 384 levels and these are the
values
so
it is not in a date time format it is a
factor now what we can do is we can
convert this into a date format how do
we do that so let's have a variable x
and i'm going to use as dot date
function and i'm going to pass in my
date column so that's assigned to x now
let's look at the head of x and it shows
me the values we will also see what kind
of class it is and we will look at the
structure of x so class already says it
is date type and look at the structure
so it shows me the format
now we have converted this column or
column related value into x now how do i
basically
extract values out of it or make it a
part of data frame so first i will use
so all once it has been converted in
date format i will go for as dot numeric
and here i will create a variable called
year and i will just do a format on x
which is basically of date type and then
i am saying
percentage y so that will get me the
year component out of this let's look at
the values
that shows me year component
now similarly we can get the month out
of this and then basically look at the
month values we can get the day out of
it and we can get the day component now
if i look at my data 2 which we had
created earlier this basically had date
consumption wind solar wind solar so
what i can do is i can add these
extracted columns such as year month day
to my data frame using a c byte that is
column bind and i will assign it to my
data 2 again so let's do this and now if
you look at head it shows me
date so that should be date format
consumption now this one might not be
date format but we'll see you have
consumption wind solar and we have
extracted the year month and day which
can help us for group by we can do some
aggregations we can do a plotting and we
can do various things by these
additional columns now let's look at
first three rows here so i'll say one is
to three for my data 2 and that shows me
some data here you can always do a head
and look at the sample of data so that
basically shows me month
day
your columns and then you have your date
now what we can do is we would want to
visualize this data we would want to
basically understand the consumption now
as i said if we want to visualize the
data say for example i want this which
is consumption of data over years and
this one is in terms of gigawatts per
hour as we were mentioning here gigawatt
hours so if i would want to create this
visual to basically understand the
pattern of the data
how do we do it so we can you create a
line plot of full time series of
germany's
electricity consumption using the plot
method now how do we do that so here
one of the option is i can straight away
use the plot method
i can then say what would be in my
x-axis what would be on my y-axis
what would be the type of
graph i would want to plot what is my
name on x-axis y-axis and this is the
simplest way so i'm saying my data 2 i'm
extracting the year column
and here i'm taking the consumption so
let's create a plot and here if you see
we are looking at a plot we do see some
tick times and we see that the data has
been divided with every two years so
from 2006 onwards to 2016
but then really this data does not give
me
uh you know a very useful way of looking
at the rate or understanding it might be
what i can do is i can use the same way
but i can give apart from x-axis and
y-axis i can say
that
limits that is x limit is 2006 to 2018
and y-limit is from 800 to 1700 so we
can do this and let's look at this again
this is a plot but it really does not
help me in visualizing and understanding
the data so what are the better options
i can go for multiple plots in a window
as of now we are just sticking to one
plot in window so if you would want to
have multiple plots you can always
change the value here and make it two or
three that will say how many rows and
how many columns as of now we will just
keep it as it is par
mfro now
if i would want to plot i can straight
away give the column name so i'm
interested in getting the consumption
now i can just do a plot i'll say
mydata2 and i will choose the second
column which is consumption which we saw
here
from our data so consumption was the
second column so i can just do a plot in
a straightaway way without mentioning
your x axis y y-axis limits and so on
and if you look at this this one
is giving me
a pattern now here i am looking at
x-axis y-axis which is not really named
we do not have a name to this graph
and we are looking at the data it does
show me some kind of pattern but
might be we can make it more meaningful
so i can do it this way where i say
mydata second column let's give access
as year x axis y axis is consumption
now that has changed
the x axis and y axis now i can also
give some more details i can say type
should be line
i have the line width i'm saying color
is blue
and let's do this so this looks more
meaningful might be shows a wavering
pattern of consumption over years
i can also give a
limit of x that is 0 to 2018 and that
basically shows me the range now we can
change that and we can be more specific
and saying x limit should be 2006 to
2018 and let's look at this now this one
once you have given a proper limit it
shows the line graph and it shows what
was the consumption in 2006 and over a
period till 2018.
i can then
use any of these options are fine but it
depends on what and whom you are
presenting the data or what kind of
analysis you are doing so i can do a
plot i can choose column second x lab
which is x axis
y axis type is line width
giving x limit y limit and then i'm
giving a title to this which is
consumption graph
and then basically you are looking at
the line graph
now those are the options which you can
do either you could be very specific or
you could just
give
your column which you want to plot or
obviously make it more meaningful by
giving all the details
now what we can do is if we would want
to look at
this data and understand it better
rather than just looking at a simple
line i can take the log values so here
i'm saying log of
my data to second column so i'm taking
log values of consumption and i'm taking
the difference of logs so i can say
difference and then you can basically
increase or decrease this by multiplying
it by some number so rest remains the
same i'm changing the color and let's
look at this plot and you see this
basically is giving me a better pattern
which makes meaning here we see the log
values so this is you are using a simple
plot function
in r you can also use ggplot now for
that we can install the ggplot package
it's already there in my machine so i'll
say no
i will access this by using the library
vgg plot
and now i can use gg plot to plot so
the way you specify here you can say my
data 2 that's the data frame i am saying
type as o and when i am saying line i am
basically going to
use x axis which is here y is
consumption and let's look at this plot
so again we are back to the one which we
were doing earlier really does not make
any sense
gives us some data but then really does
not give me enough information
i can
in my aesthetics i can say x as year y
is consumption i can do a grouping and
then i can give line and plot so again
we have some information but really does
not help me right
now let's look at other example so i'm
just doing the same thing here and i'm
looking at line type being tasked i'm
using the gg plots other methods such as
geom line and gm point to give me more
information and if i look at the
plot it does give me data it tells me
what are the different values it gives
me some kind of pattern but i would
still prefer the way we were doing with
plot
now
we can change the color and obviously
add details to it so what we see is when
you use the plot method which i did
earlier it was choosing pretty good tick
locations that is every two years
and labels the years for the x axis
which was helpful
right but with these data points which
we were seeing here
or say for example this one
or say this one
or say this one we are looking at some
data but then that
really is quite crowded
and it is hard to read you can look at
the values but then it really does not
give you enough information so we can go
for plot method but then we will see how
we can consider different data now if i
would want to plot the solar and wind
time series so let's see how do we do
that
so
wind column is what i'm interested in so
first thing is it was always good to
find out the minimum and the maximum
values in every column so i am saying
minimum i'm saying let's put in here my
data 2
and then let's look at the values so we
are looking at the columns
we know consumption is the second column
wind is the third column
and
you have solar as the fourth and this
one is the fifth so let's say let's find
out the minimum of each of these columns
which we would want to plot so let's say
minimum of data
third column and here i'm also saying
remove the n a values because we do not
want to consider the n a values so let's
let look at the minimum that shows me
5.7757
what is the maximum value it is 826 so
that also helps me in giving a limit if
i want to plot wind on y axis i can give
a y limit from 5 to 850
consumption wise let's find out the
minimum from second column and maximum
and similarly for solar find the minimum
and maximum and wind plus solar minimum
and maximum so this will be helpful when
you would want to plot multiple graphs
or
give some limits so that's fine now for
multiple plots as i said
instead of having one plot let's plot
consumption and wind and solar and try
to see a pattern so i can say par
function and i will say three rows and
one column
so
now when i start plotting you will see
you will have multiple plots in one
single window so let's see how we do it
so here
let's look at plot one so this one is
consumption as we did earlier
and let's look at the data so that gives
me some data you can always do a zoom
and you can look at the data you can
basically expand this graph or you can
reduce this graph to see
what kind of pattern we have in
consumption similarly we can
basically choose
date being
x-axis
my consumption being y-axis right so
this is being more specific because here
we have a range but it really does not
give me enough information so i will
basically give x-axis y-axis i will give
the name that is daily totals and then i
will basically give consumption color
and y limit based on my minimum and
maximum limits so let's do this
and now we can
look at the data here so let's see this
data
makes a little more meaning because we
are looking at the dates
and let me do a zoom so it shows me all
the dates it shows me the data points it
shows me how the data
pattern is changing for consumption
now
this is for consumption so what we can
do is
we can also extract specific data so if
you see here i have done some testing
where i am saying okay i would want to
get
a date specifically
i would want to extract some value so we
are looking at the date column but if
you remember we did not change the data
type we just changed the data type of
date column we extracted year month out
of it
it would be good if we can
convert a column into date time format
and put that in our data frame now
let's look at the plot2
this is mainly for
your
column
which should be consumption and wind and
solar so here i see it is solar data
and i can plot this one
to see how it looks like
and that tells me from 2006 onwards we
have some pattern i can
be more specific where i say
i would be giving date and then
the
column for solar x-axis y-axis what is
the type what is the y limit and what is
the color
it is always good to specify your x and
y axis given name rather than let it
automatically pick up now this makes
more meaning because it shows me some
dates
similarly we can do for wind
so either you do it just by giving the
column
or you give your x and y axis so let's
look at this one
and this shows me the data so we can
choose plot 3
this one we can choose plot two
we can choose plot one and we can put
all that data in one graph
so that's when you are putting in multi
plots in one particular graph you can
always do a zoom
you can always look at the data right
and this is usually useful to look at
the pattern what kind of pattern we see
what data we have and so on now
moving forward so we have seen how you
are creating these plots all in one
window let me reset this back to one
plot per window
and let's basically plot time series in
a single year so what we have seen is
that when you look at the plot method it
was quite crowded then we looked at
solar and wind and if you compare that
you will see your consumption pattern
your solar pattern your wind pattern and
basically we can see from this
particular data some kind of pattern
so electricity consumption is highest in
the winter
where we will see what is the
consumption
is it highest in winter or is it in
summer we can see that by breaking a
year
further into months we can see that but
we see a pattern which goes for every
year or every two years being highest at
a particular point of time and then it
drops down
so electricity consumption is highest in
winter and that might be due to
electrical heating
and increased lighting usage and lowest
in summer
now when you look at electricity
consumption appears to split into two
clusters we can always look at the
consumption one with oscillation
centered roundly around 1400 gigawatts
so you can always look at 1400 gigawatts
and you see all the values here which
are in that particular consumption
another with fewer and more scattered
data points simply roughed around one
one five zero so if you really expand
this you can see you will have lot of
data points at this point
now
we might guess that these clusters
correspond with weekdays and weekends
which we can see if you break that data
into yearly monthly weekly and so on now
if you look at solar production
that is highest in summer when sunlight
is most abundant and lowest in winter so
obviously when you are making or
gathering some insights when you are
looking at the data you are also using
your domain knowledge your business
knowledge your
you know knowledge of business to
understand how this goes
if you look at wind power production
that's again highest in winters and
drops down in summer
so due to stronger winds and more
frequent storms and lowest in summer
so there is some kind of increasing
trend in wind power production over
years which we can see here
over the years
and
all the time series data what we are
looking at
is
referring or showing us some kind of
seasonality that is we are looking at
seasonality in which a pattern is
repeating again and again at regular
times
at regular intervals so if you look at
consumption solar and wind time series
that oscillates between high and low
values on a yearly time scale which we
can break down and see i'll show you
that
it corresponds with the seasonal changes
in weather over the year
so seasonality
does not have to correspond with
meteorological reasons for example if
you look at retail sales sales data
that will show you yearly seasonality
with increased sales in particular
months
so seasonality when we say can occur on
other time scales so the plots what we
are seeing here
they are fine but if you look at those
plots they might
show some kind of weekly seasonality
also
so in your consumption corresponding to
weekdays and weekend so let's plot for
one single year now how do i do that so
first is i will look at my data to
that shows me the structure it shows me
date which is factor other columns which
are all numerics
now like we did earlier i'll repeat this
step where i'm going to convert the date
column into date type
look at head of it look at class of it
look at the structure of it right and
then what i want to do is i want to add
this
and to my data frame so i will create a
variable called mod data
and this one will have as data
and i'm formatting
the value of x which is date time into
month day and year so let's do that
and now you look at the mod data which i
created like modified data so this is
the format i have it is in date type if
you carefully see here
and then i can look at the head of it
so it saves me more data
now
we are what we did here is when i said
my data 3
so
we did a
c bind and i did a mod data which is
going to add this column to my
other columns of my data too so my new
data frame is mydata3 let's look at the
structure of it and you see there is
this date column i can delete it i can
remove it i can let it be right so that
depends on our choice might be we want
to once our analysis done we want to
remove the mod data right so we can keep
both of them
now
let's
basically extract data for a particular
year now how do you do that so this is
some wrangling so i will say mydata4
let's call it mydata4 and i will use
subset function so subset will work on
mydata3 that's the data and what i'll do
is i will do a subset how does how is
the subset found so i'll say take the
mod data
column the value should be
greater than or equal to 2017 and should
be less than
2017 december 31st so i'm getting data
for one year and i'm storing it as my
data four
let's get the head of it and you see we
are specifically looking at 2017 related
data
now let's do a plotting of this where i
will only
create a plot for one year so i'm saying
my data for that's my new
data what we got
so
here i am going to take the first column
which is mod data
i am going to take the third column
which is consumption so i am looking at
the date format for one year consumption
values for it and then rest of the
things as we have done earlier let's
look at the plot and this makes more
meaning right so when you look at this
plot it tells me jan to jan it shows me
some kind of pattern where i have
divided the year into months
right and it is broken down into say two
months so jan and march and may and july
and so on but we still see a pattern and
that gives me good understanding of
pattern where i've broken it down into
months
so this is where you have taken time
series in a single year to investigate
further and this is what we see
right now we can clearly see there are
some weekly
oscillations
what one more interesting feature is
that at this level of granularity that
is when you're looking at yearly data
there is a drastic decrease in
electricity consumption in early january
and late december during the holidays so
probably we can assume that this is
holidays now i can zoom in further and
look at just jan and feb data
let's see how we do that and let's see
how we work by zooming in the data
further
so to
zoom in the data further let's see how
we do it now here we have this mydata4
which is basically having a subset right
so let's work on this one so i will say
my data four which earlier i was taking
data three i was doing a subset and i
was giving the date but this time i will
make it more narrower so i will say my
data 4 i will say subset from my data 3
and i will choose mod data column which
we have modified with the date format i
will choose the starting date as 1701
that is jan and then let's go till feb
and let's create this
now let's look at the head of this so it
shows me we have the data which is jan
and then you you can basically look at
more on this
now again as i said earlier let's find
out the minimum of this from the
first
column so that is basically your mod
data so let's look into this one
and that basically
will give me minimum and maximum let's
look at the values so this one tells me
jan 17 january 1
and maximum is
your
feb 28th second month 2017. so we are
actually looking at two months data here
let's look at the y minimum so this is i
will look at
column three now what is column three
consumption so let's look at the minimum
value for consumption
maximum value of consumption let's look
at the values which can be given as our
limits
now this is the minimum and maximum now
let's do a plotting for this data which
has been narrowed down
for consumption based on my data so i'm
saying
my first column which is mod data and
then third column which is consumption
i'm giving some
naming convention for sorry namings for
your x-axis y-axis
what is my
consumption
or what is my title here what is the
color and then you see i'm using x limit
to give the minimum and maximum limit
and y limit so let's look at this data
and if you
look at this data
it is specifically for two months and
again i can look at the pattern here
what i can also do is i can add some
grid here
so i can basically look at this data and
make more meaning out of it so it is
bi-weekly data you can see now i can add
a line here using ab line
and then i can basically choose what
lines i would want to add horizontally
so that basically allows me to dissect
the data and look at data in a more
meaningful way i can also
add vertical lines so vertical lines is
i'm saying sequence will be minimum
maximum and i'm saying an interval of
seven
so let's do this and this basically has
added some lines every week and you can
see at the end of week it is dropping
and then it is starting again it peaks
somewhere in the middle of the week and
again it
drops down so this is you are looking at
your consumption data right now what we
can also do is we can create some box
plots so when we looked at zooming in
data for jan and feb you can add some
data points like this so consumption is
highest on the weekdays as i showed you
here and lowest on the weekends so this
is what we are seeing when we are
breaking the data or zooming it further
for a couple of months
so we have vertical grid lines
and we have nicely formatted tick labels
that is jan 1st and 15th feb 1st and so
on so we can easily tell which days are
weekdays and weekends with use of these
grid lines and basically breaking it
down so there are many other ways to
actually visualize your time series data
depending on what patterns you are
trying to explore you can use scatter
plots you can use heat maps you can just
use histograms and so on
now moving further we would want to
explore the seasonality right so when
you further explore the seasonality of
our data
we can use box plots basically to group
the data by different time periods and
display the distribution for each group
now how do we do that
let's come here and let's see how box
plot works so i can just do a simple box
plot and i can choose my consumption
column and that gives me just the
consumption data but this really does
not give me any meaning i can look at
solar data i can look at the wind data
and we can also see some outliers here
so we can create box plots but
if we would want to do a box plot what
is box plot it is basically a visual
display of your phi number summary that
is you want to look at your mean median
you want to look at your 25th percentile
50 percentile
or 75th percentile so we can use a
quantile function use the consumption
column and then you basically give
a vector which shows you find number
summary so that's your quantile and then
let's do a box plot
so if you are looking at quantile it
tells me what is the minimum what is
25th percentile 50 75th and 100 that's
from my consumption column so let's
create a box plot for consumption
let's give it a name as consumption
let's give y axis as consumption and a
limit
for
y axis now that's my consumption graph
so i can look at yearly data now that
will make more meaning rather than just
looking at the complete consumption data
so how do we do it yearly so we will say
consumption
and then i will say the year column so
it is consumption but grouped based on
year
so here i can give x axis y axis and i
can give y limit so let's create this
and this makes more meaning we can give
some coloring scheme here but now i'm
looking at 2006 2007 8 9 and so on and
we can look at the data what is the
range right it gives me 5 percentile or
sorry 5 number summary of the data per
year and it basically allows me to look
at the seasonality of this similarly we
can create box plot
by just giving consumption early group
and here i am giving the title as
consumption y axis
x axis and y limit
wherein i can also use last so this is
one more feature which you can do and
that basically will give me the tick
points if you compare this one to the
previous graph
so when i created this previous graph i
had 2006 2008 and i had from 600 to 1800
and if i go for the next one
i am basically seeing more useful
information now let's look at monthly
data so
i would want to group it based on months
and let's create that so this gives me
the monthly data where i'm looking at
months
and i could select
a particular year or i can just do a
grouping based on months
so
i can have multiple plots to see a
difference here so let's do this
now let's create a box plot for
consumption which is monthly data and
let's give it a color let's look at the
wind data which is again grouped monthly
and let's look at the solar data which
is grouped monthly
now if i zoom in
it basically gives me the seasonality of
the data
for your wind for your consumption for
your solar so what we are doing is we
are creating these box plots
which are giving us
values now what i can also do is i could
look at the day wise also but before we
look into this how do i
infer some information from these box
plots which are being created so this is
what we have done where we are looking
at the data for month and these box
plots give me year seasonality which we
were seeing in earlier plots but give
some additional insights so if i look at
the data here it tells me
the electricity consumption is generally
higher in winter
now this is based on months so we can
see consumption is higher in winters
and lower in summer so we can obviously
look at our plot we can see where it is
lower where it is higher
and then we can
look at the median and lower two
quartiles are lower in december and
january compared to november and
february so that is you look at the
quartiles and you will see
that
the median and lower two quartiles are
lower in december and january
here jan and december so you can look it
from my plot
now
this is giving you some idea on
seasonality
now
that might be due to business being
closed over holidays now this one we
were also seeing when we looked at time
series for 2017 only and box plot
basically confirms that there is this
consistent pattern throughout the years
now when you look at
your
solar and wind power production both
will give you a year seasonality what we
are seeing here
and
if basically i look at the data so
it depends on what parameters you are
choosing but if you look at solar it
will reflect the effect of occasional
extreme wind speeds associated with
storms and other transient and since we
are grouping it based on months we can
see this pattern is quite evident every
year
now what we can do is we can group the
data day wise
so here let me again reset this to
one plot per graph
now i'll say box plot i'll say
consumption which is group based on day
now we know that there is a day column
and let's give a while limit and let's
look at the data so this is where i'm
grouping the data day wise
so you look at 31 days and you look at
the box plot so this is where you are
plotting it on a daily basis
so you can look at the data you can
break it down to a particular week so
here i have given
day and i have chosen all the 31 days
but i can break it down to a week and i
can look at the data so
if we look at the data per week or per
day we can basically infer that
electricity consumption
where i am doing a consumption group by
day
is higher on weekdays than on weekends
so
time series with strong seasonality
can
often be represented with models that
can decompose signal into seasonality
and long trend
now this is
an easy way now how do we look at the
frequency of the data that could be
interesting to see
so let me
look at
say the yearly data
which we were seeing here
now let's go further and here we have
looked at data so what we will do is we
look at the frequency now when you look
at the frequency
when you talk about frequency in your
data so we have the modified date column
which gives me a frequency and if we
really look into the data that will tell
me
that the data is on a daily basis so for
that let's look at my data 3 again which
gives me data and you can just see
all the data data or dates are in
sequence so you're 22 23 24 25 26 and so
on i can look at i can access a dplyer
package
that is basically allowing me to work in
a better way now i can look at the
summary of this and for all my columns i
am seeing
what is the minimum phi number summary
date and consumption so date does not
show me anything because this is not in
a date format it is just a factor but
other things have the fine number
summary so we are looking at wind plus
solar
we are looking at year and month and day
and all these columns now what we will
do is we will want to find out
the sum of each
column
how many entries does it have and we
will say the value should any value
should not be considered so let's look
at this one so it tells me for my
particular columns
so let me run this again
and that shows me
for each column how many values you have
and
these
counts
do not include the n a values
now similarly i can find out
specifically for consumption i can find
out is there any n a value so i'm saying
is dot n a and let's find out if there
is any n a value or missing value in
consumption it says zero
okay that's good if you look in wind
it tells me there are
1463 entries which are any
similarly solar
similarly
wind dot solar or wind plus solar so it
gives me a count of
n a values that is missing values
and also values which are not missing so
to understand frequency what we can do
is we can find out the minimum
on the date that is the first column and
i am saying
rm
na dot rm is true that is get rid of n a
values and find out the minimum
and let's look at the minimum value
this is the minimum from my modified
date
now if i would want to get the frequency
i can basically use sequence function so
i can say
from x minimum that is the minimum value
i want to look at the frequency that is
day wise and let's just look at five
entries and see if there is a
day by day frequency
so let's look at the value of this and
obviously it tells me there is device
frequency so that allows me to look at
the frequency look at the type of it it
is an integer class is a date
so similarly we can say from x minimum
we can basically look at the frequency
month wise
and i can again look at five records so
that shows me monthly data
right so
i can
extract the data for frequency similarly
yearly data and that's also very useful
now
we can select data which has any values
for wind so how do i do it i would want
to find out the wind column and i want
to find out
where the values are in a so
i will create a variable
and here i will say my data 3
and then i give a conditional where i
say is n a
in the column so let's do this
now once i've done this
once i've done this i have said that my
selected wind data from my data 3 where
we said n a values
and i will give the names to this so
name should be in my data 3 i'm
interested in mod data consumption wind
and solar so these are the four columns
i'm interested in let's look at first 10
records here or first 10 rows so that
tells me these are the values where wind
has n a
or missing values
i can always do a view and that gives me
the complete data
so it basically shows me
1463 entries
and here it shows me all n a values so
you can look at all the way to the end
and it shows me wind has n a solar does
have some value here
in the last row but then also if you see
the numbers have
a difference so you have one four six
one and then you have two one seven four
so there is a difference so there is
some data in between where wind has some
values so we have found out any values
now what we will do is we will select
data which does not have any values so i
will call it cell selected win2
i'll again use my data 3 i will say
which but now i'm saying not any
from this column and i will select the
data for the columns so i'm interested
in looking at
10 records and this shows me not any
value so no more missing values so if i
really look at this data as i saw
earlier which has n a and if i look at
these values which are not any for the
wind column so looking at these two
result we will know that in year 2011
wind column
has some missing values
so let's focus on year 2011. so how do i
do that let's call it a different
variable i'll say mydata3 i will say
here when i say which where we were
saying na
here i will say the year should have a
value of 2011 and i want all these
columns
let's look at the data here and this is
showing me 2011 but
we
are not seeing all the values so there
are some values but then there are some
missing values also for 2011 based on
whatever analysis we have done so let's
look at the class of this it is
basically a data frame do a view
and this one will help me in finding out
where are the n a values so if you just
scroll down
looking at all the data let's search if
wind column has a n a or a missing value
and i will see
if there is any missing value in which
column or which row it is for the wind
column so we have all the values which
are existing
i could select and search for one
specific value and i'll show you how we
can do that so here let's scroll all the
way down so it's like you're exploring
your data
and seeing is
wind column having n a or missing value
for a particular row
and let's scroll here and here you see
there is a missing value for one
particular row so
13th
december 2011 has wind value
15 december has wind value but
your 14th december does not have right
similarly we can search so there was
only one entry which was missing now
that could be for some reason might be
it was not calculated might be it was
not tabulated so we have a missing value
and that
can affect my plotting that can affect
my analysis so let's look at the number
of rows
in this which will tell me how many rows
we have
for 2011 so it tells me 365 so that is
basically the number of days in a year
now we will find out if
there were any values so we earlier
checked total number of na values per
column
that is
in your row number 265 to 269
we can see here 265 to 269
so this is where we were seeing
are there any n a values right so let's
go back here
and
we want to find out the number of n a
values for a particular year how do i do
it so i can just do a sum i will say is
n a
now i am interested in my data 3
wind column and i am saying my year has
to be 2011 but i am finding out the n a
values
so let's do this and it tells me one and
that's right that's what we saw when we
did a view let's see how many non-any
values you have and that is 364 so that
basically
satisfies my logic so it's 364 plus one
missing so there are 365 let's look at
the structure of this it tells me you
have modified date and date format you
have consumption wind and solar now
let's create a variable
selected wind4 i will save in three that
is which was having all my n a and
non n a values for 2011
i will say
let's find out the n a value
because i'm interested in finding out
that particular row so i'm saying find
out where the value is n a and i want
all the columns
let's look at this one and this is my
specific
row
which has a n a value
now
we know that data follows a device
frequency which we have clearly seen now
let's select data which has n a and
non-na values
so
let's say let's call it test one i will
use win3 which has
any non-na values but now i will say i
want the modified date which should be
greater than 12 12 2001. now remember we
had when we were doing a view we saw
that one particular day or what we see
here 14th of december there is no date
so i will select a subset of data
which includes this n a and non n a that
is might be i can take 13th of december
and 15th of december so let's start from
12 12
so the date should be greater than 12 12
that means 13 and it should be less than
16 so that is 15
and the columns
right so
now we have some data let's look at this
so i have
a i've selected a subset of data i could
have done this using subset also so i
have any and non-any values now
why are we doing this so sometimes you
might have some data for a particular
column and you may want to find out if
there are any missing values might be
you want to fill them up or replace them
with something so that is usually useful
when you are doing a trend detection so
say for example you have data for every
month and might be in one one of the
months you have missed or might be you
have data for every year collected
monthly and then in one of the years for
couple of months you don't have the data
like i can say 2016 i have data for all
12 months 2017 all 12 months 2018 might
be i don't have data from march and june
2019 i don't have
data for same months so i can forward
fill or backward fill them using the
previous year's same month data so we
can do that so here i have test data
where i've extracted a subset of data
i can look at the s
class of this it is a data frame
structure of this it has the columns now
let's use that library
and
function and use the tidy our package
and what we will do is we will fill it
up so i will use test1 i will fill the
wind column which has a missing value
now once you do this if you notice it
has done a forward fill so it has taken
the previous value and it has just
filled up that so you can
fill up the data using different
directions such as up and down left and
right and so on so we can take care of
missing values
in our frequency data which allows us to
basically
analyze the data in a better way now
here we will want to also look at some
more data so this is to deal with
frequencies of fill column
wherein you can take care of missing
values forward filled so filling values
can be done in different directions as i
said and you may want to first convert
your time series to specified frequency
if
your data does not have a frequency but
we had now if you do not have a
frequency might be you can convert it
into a frequency such as weekly daily
monthly as i showed you and then
basically you can
do a forward fill
for the value so for example if i have
my data i can break it down into weekly
and then look at the values and if there
are any values missing for weekly data i
can use a forward fill so that can take
care of my frequency data
then
let's look at the trends of the data
which is the last part of this project
so basically let's look at the trend so
when you say trend what does that mean
so in time series data you always have
some kind of trend so that will exhibit
some slow gradual variability
in addition to higher frequency
variability such as seasonality and
noise
now to visualize these trends what we do
is we use what we call as rolling means
so we know how our data is spread over
year or month or day but how about
looking at a rolling average and see
what is the difference so a rolling mean
will tend to smooth a time series by
averaging out the variations and
frequencies
so this can be higher than the window
size so there is something called as
windowing where you can choose a set of
time frame
you can also average out any seasonality
on a time scale equal to window size so
this will allow you to look at lower
frequency variation in the data so when
we are looking at electricity
consumption time series we already saw
there is a weekly pattern there is a
yearly seasonality which we saw using
box plots so we can also look at the
rolling means of the time scales how do
we do that so for this you can use some
package like zoo and then you can
basically use a rolling mean
using this zoo package
and you can say what is the
frequency with which you want to
calculate the rolling mean
now how do we do this
let's look at this data so here i'm
going to my look at my data 3 which we
have been using so far
now let's call it a three day test you
can give it any name i am going to use
my data 3
i am using the pipe in function
now i will use dplyer and i will arrange
the data descending in here now you can
always break it down step by step and
you can see the result of this
so i'm going to arrange this data in
descending order of year
so obviously my last one 2017 or 2018
will be on the top you want to group the
data by year so it depends on how many
years we have we'll see so you can group
the data by year now this data is then
used to basically mutate so mutate
function is going to allow me to use
this rolling mean so i will call it as
says zero three day so i'm going to
calculate a rolling mean every three
days
for my consumption column
and
basically let's ungroup this so let's
see how this works
sorry yeah let's look at this and
here when i'm doing a three-day test
let's look at the result of this and
then i'll explain this so if you see
here we have the test three day column
now this has the rolling average now
what does that mean so first value here
what we see is one three six seven
is the average consumption in 2017
from the first date with a data point on
either side of it that is you can look
at
this
date so 1 1 3 0
then you look at
you are looking at the value 1 3 6 7
here so you look at 1 1 3 0 1 4 4 1 1 5
3 0 if i take a mean of these so for
example if i would just do this part
and that
is giving me
mean
okay because i have a comment so let's
basically add anything as comment and
then let's do this so it saves me one
three six seven that's what we are
seeing here right so you've got getting
a rolling average every three days
similarly if you want every five days it
takes the five values and it gets the
mid value right so you can always find
out the mean
rolling mean
for a particular frequency now let's do
that for seven days that is weekly data
and yearly data that is 365 days so how
do i do it same logic my data test
now i am using my data 3 i'm arranging
it in a descending order i'm grouping by
year
so when you do a group by year so
earlier when we did a grouping by and
when we looked at the data it was
telling me how many rows we had
right so let's do a grouping by year and
let's say test 0 7 so that's a rolling
average every 7 days and i'm also saying
take care of the n a values similarly
i'm getting rolling average every 365
days might be you can do quarterly might
be you can do half yearly and let's do
this so let's
create this my data test and let's look
at the result of this so i will use my
data test i will say arrange
based on modified date now we know there
is a column called modified date i want
to just look at 2017 data so i am doing
a filter
right and then i will choose what are
the columns i am interested in so i will
look at the 7 and 365 day and let's look
at say first 7 records
so let's do this
and that basically gives me the
consumption value modified date year and
my rolling seven day average order of
seven day mean
which is for first seven days and then
365 you will not see the data here but
if i do a view on this i can basically
see the values
so you can always select a particular
column to see the values
these are the values for every 7 day
rolling average
this is for 365 days every 365 days so
you see all the values are missing but
every 365 entry you will have basically
some data
now
let's do a plotting of this and
basically visualize this data which we
are seeing rolling average so let me
first do a plotting one plot per graph
and let's do a plotting i will take
consumption data
x-axis y-axis
color and give a title to this so let's
create this and that's my consumption
data which is
spread over a period of time and that's
fair enough but now let's add some more
plot to this so i will add the seven day
rolling average to this
so for second plot to be added in the
same one in r you can use points so i
will say points i will choose 7 data
column
type is line width
x limit y limit and color so let's do
this
and that's my
pattern seven day rolling average which
basically gives me some kind of trend
similarly i can add one more here and
this time i will choose the 365 day
and look at the pattern
lines so now you see some dots here well
you could do it in a different way so i
can just add legend to this and i can
say legend will be aware in x-axis and
y-axis so i am saying it will be 2500
and y is 1800 so my legend will come in
somewhere here i am saying my legend
will have consumption
test
and this one i can give some names i can
give what is the color
i can say what kind of
legend it explains what is
for each color and then basically a
vector so let's add a legend to this and
i've added a legend now you can do a
zoom and look at the data
and
here i see that
my x axis is fine but y axis is going a
little
about of my plotting area so i can
actually change that so here i have 1800
how about making it 1600
and let's look at this one
so we can basically
uh go for this one and start again here
plot
and points and line and then add a
legend
right and you can basically place your
legend anywhere in the plot so this
basically is giving me the trend what
i'm looking at
my
rolling average
so similarly you can look at the trend
for wind and solar data so what we are
seeing here is when you look at trend
this is one more way of looking at it
you can always create plots in different
ways so
seven day rolling mean has smoothed out
all weekly seasonality which we were
seeing here in my graph where you look
at every seven day preserving the yearly
seasonality so
seven day will tell
that electricity consumption is
typically higher in winter and lower in
summer so better is you break it down
uh yearly so here if you look at every
year you can see when is winter when is
summer
what is the seasonality what your trend
what you are seeing here and if there is
a decrease or increase
for few weeks
every winter
so similarly if you look at 365 now as
you said as i said rolling average
basically
reduces the variation so if i look at
360 by rolling mean we can see long term
trend
in electricity consumption is pretty
flat now that's what we are seeing it's
kind of pretty flat there is not much
variation over the years if you really
join these dots
so
we can basically see some highs and lows
and that gives me a trend now this is
how you can do a trend detection and
similarly we can do plotting for wind
and solar so this is a small project
which i demonstrated using r now all
this code
which you have here in the form of a
project dot r file you can find here in
my github page this is the document
which explains some things feel free to
download this and you can add details to
it this is the sample data set which you
can also find in my repository in the
data sets folder so continue learning
and continue practicing r
and with that we have come to the end of
this video tutorial on machine learning
with our full course i hope you enjoyed
watching this video please subscribe to
the simply loan channel and don't forget
to hit the bell icon thank you for
watching and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you